WE'RE OPENING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE HEARING OF WERE.
WE'RE ALMOST AT A QUORUM
HOWEVER IN THE MEANTIME THERE'S
SOME HOUSEKEEPING MEASURES WE
NEED TO DO SO WITHOUT FURTHER
ADO I WILL BEGIN. BY TALKING
ABOUT ART- OUR CORPOATE
RESTRICTIONS DURING THIS TIME.
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY
HEARING DUE TO CONTINUE TO STAY
AT HOME ORDER WE'RE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING- DO IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING SO WE'RE ONLY
ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WATCH AND PARTICIPATE
IN THE HEARING IN PERSON WE
ALSO REQUIRE AN MSP WARNED AND
PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. TESTIFYING WORK
WHETHER IN THE ROOM OR AT THE
VIDEO CONFERENCE IN SIGHT IF
YOU DO NOT HAVE AMASSED WE CAN
PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU WE HAVE A
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY. PUT A
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM. TODAY IN
ROME FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. WE CAN
ONLY ACCOMMODATE A MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF IN A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PUBLIC OF THE
PUBLIC AND MEDIA. SO WE CAN MAX
MAINTAIN SIX FEET UP SPACING.
THEY'RE ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING PROTOCOL FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL. AND FOR THOSE HERE IN
THE ROOM. IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN A ROOM WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY ON A BILL PLEASE RAISE
YOUR HAND AND I WILL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WOULD ASK
THAT THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCHED A
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM WHAT YOU HAVE WHAT
YOU'RE DONE TESTIFYING OR
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. PLEASE BE
SURE TO OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITAL. INCLUDING LIMITING-
ELEVATOR USE TO ONE PERSON AT A
TIME. FOUR TO BE. PRETTY W. B.
R. WITNESSES. IN ADDITION TO
BEING ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM
INSIDE THE HEARING ROOM WE HAVE
SOME BILL WITNESSES MAKING USE
OF OUR WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOMS WHICH ARE
CORRESPONDING ROOM FOR OUR
HEARING IS ROOM ONE TWO SEVEN
ONE TWENTY SEVEN. THESE
WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON THE
SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH
THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE FROM
OUTSIDE OF THE HEARING ROOM AND
ALSO ASK THEM QUESTIONS. WOOD
DILANTIN WITNESSES WE WILL ALSO
BE USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY IN A BILL.
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AGAIN THAT'S. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. ANY ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO AGAIN THAT'S ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. YOU
CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON
THE ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV SCREEN. IF YOU'RE
CALLING THEN PLEASE DO SO AS
THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOUR IT
IS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOUR
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING TO
ADD BILL RESENTATION. THE
OPERATE ONLINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN QUEUE. BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE A
BILL. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST IN YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE TO
SOUND DISTORTION. PLEASE ALSO
BE ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE A
MAIN WITNESS. OF YOUR MAIN
WITNESSES PROVIDING TESTIMONY
FOR OR AGAINST THE BILL YOU
REMAIN IN A LIFELINE AND WE
NEED TO MEET YOURSELF UNTIL YOU
ARE CALLED ON TO SPEAK. IF
YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH
THE MODERATE A PHONE SERVICE
YOU CAN CALL THEM COMMITTEE AT
NINE ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE
THREE SEVEN FOUR FOUR AND MY
STAFF WILL BE HERE TO HELP. I
ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. THANK YOU FOR BEING
WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT MATHIS
TO CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL TO
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE. I WHICH DO WE'RE REAL
CLOSE TO A QUORUM. BOB THE
FOLLOWING WE THE MEMBERS HERE
THE FOLLOWING ITEMS. HAVE BEEN
ARE OFF CALENDAR AND HAVE BEEN
PULLED BY THE AUTHORS. I ITEM
NUMBER SIX AB SEVEN HUNDRED A
CUNNINGHAM CRIMINAL PROCEDURE
ARRAIGNMENT AND TRIAL WAS
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR. I ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB. THIRTEEN
FIFTY ONE ONE THREE FIVE ONE
NOT PETRIE-NORRIS CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES BUT NOW HAS ALSO
BEEN PULLED BY THE AUTHOR.
JUNGLELAND TO A QUORUM AND YOU
KNOW WHAT WILL WAIT ONE MORE
MINUTE SO HOPEFULLY WE GET. TWO
MORE MEMBERS FROM THE COMMITTEE
AND I WANT TO THANK- ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS LEE C. R. THOR. AND
MISTER CORK FOR BEING HERE. ON
TIME PROPS TO WE CAN BEGIN THIS
MEETING- QUICKLY SO THE OTHER
MEMBERS WILL YOU PLEASE JOIN WE
HAVE A- WE HAVE A USER VERY
LONG LONG. LONG COMMITTEE
HEARINGS WOULD BE HELPFUL IF WE
COULD START ON TIME. AND I GET
TO THE TO THE BUSINESS AT HAND.
SO WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE STILL
WAITING FOR A QUORUM. BUT OUT
OF DEFERENCE TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHOI WHO'S WHO'S HERE AHEAD OF
TIME AND ON TIME- WE WILL ALLOW
HIM TO MAKE HIS PRESENTATION
NOW. OF MR CHOI. HELLO MISS
CHOI ARE YOU READY TO MAKE YOUR
PRESENTATION. YOU CAN GO AHEAD
NO ONE ELSE IS HERE. YOU HAVE
DE. WE SHOULD REWARD YOU FOR
BEING HERE ON TIME AND AHEAD OF
TIME SO YOU GET TO GO FIRST.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS
WHO ARE PRESENT HERE. I AM
PLEASED SO 2% ASSEMBLY BE A LAW
TAKE NINETY TWO ON KNOWN AS SAW
SEX OFFENDER REGISTRY- LUITPOLD
PASSED. THIS. EIGHT NINETY TWO
WOULD IMPOSE HIM IMPORTANT
ACCOUNTABILITY ON THOSE SO WHO
PREY ON CHILDREN BY REQUIRING
ADULTS SO COOL SALAS SEX ACTS
FROM A MINOR TO REGISTER AS A
SEX OFFENDER. EXISTING CRIMINAL
LAW- MAKES IT A MISDEMEANOR
OFFENSE WHEN ONE PERSON'S
SOLICITS OR ENGAGES IN ANY
PROCESS CHECK PROSTITUTION THAT
IS SO WHEN ONE PERSON PAYS SO
ALL AGREES TO PAY FOR SEX ACTS
WITH FIAT MONEY OR SOMETHING
ELSE OF VALUE. CURRENTLY A
PERSON FOUND THE GUILTY OF
PAYING FOR SEX ACTS IS A GUILTY
OF LAW GENERIQUE A MISDEMEANOR
PUNISHABLE BY UP TO SIX MONTHS
IN COUNTY JAIL AND OR A FINE UP
TO ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS EVEN IF
OF THE PERPETRATOR NEW THE
PERSON RECEIVING THE PAYMENT
THAT WAS SUCH A MINOR. THAT
MEANS. NOT TODAY THEREFORE
FIFTY YOUR OLD MAN PAYS A
SIXTEEN YEAR OLD THE CURRENT TO
HAVE SEX WITH HIM THAT MAN
WOULD DOCTOR POSSIBLY PHASE
CELLPHONE IS A SMALLER ONE
THOUSAND DOLLAR FINE. THAT IS
SO UTTERLY RIDICULOUS AND-
PORTALS A HOLE IN THE FACE TO
VICTIMS AND THEIR FAMILIES. A
YOUNGER SON LIFE AND OUR
HAPPINESS I CAN BE TOTALLY
SHALLOW. WHY IN THE TELL LAW
GIVES THE A SEXUAL PREDATOR IS
SLAP BALL ON THE WRIST. AB
EIGHT NINETY TWO TECHS ON
IMPORTANT STEP. IN THE- TILTING
THE SCALES ALL OF OUR JUSTICE A
BACKGROUND IN FAVOR OF THE
VICTIMS AND ADDITIONALLY
REQUIRING ANY ADULT WHO IS SAW
CONVICTING OF ALL. SOLICITING A
SEX SEX FROM A MINOR TO
REGISTER AS A SEX OFFENDER.
THIS IS OUR COMMON SENSE. THERE
IS NO KNOWN SCENARIO IN WHICH A
FIFTY YEAR OLD. ALDERMEN SHOULD
BE ABLE TO PAY A- MODEST OF
FINE AFTER PAYING. YEP THE PEP
OF THE PAYING TO PAY A
SECTIONAL WITH A SIXTEEN YEAR
OLD GIRL PHYSICISTS ARE A STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION AUTO
CORRECT OR THIS OF GROCER IN
JUSTICE. THIS BILL IS SO
SUPPORTED BY. RCS ITALY HEY. OF
WHICH IS A CALIFORNIA STATE.
LAW ENFORCEMENT. ASSOCIATION.
AND THE POOREST WHICH IS OUR
PEACE OFFICERS RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION ALL FOUR OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I'VE
WORKED ON AB EIGHT NINE TWO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHOI. DO YOU
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
BUT I SAW NONE ON HERE BUT I
JUST WANT TO DOUBLE CHECK IF
YOU HAD ANYBODY WANT TO TESTIFY.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE NONE. DID.
THEY WILL GO TO THE TO THE UP
TO THE RUN FORTY TWO OH TWO ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHT. NINE TWO SEEING
NONE IN THE AUDIENCE OR ANY
WITNESSES ON THE VIDEO SCREEN-
SEEN NONE WE WILL NOW OPEN UP
THE LINES A. T. AND T. OPERATOR
FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB.
EIGHT NINE TWO. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB EIGHT NINE TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT NINE TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. IT LOOKS LIKE I
CURRENTLY HAVE TWO IN THE QUEUE
IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR
THE FIRST COMMENT. THANK YOU
OPERATOR. WHILE WE WAIT WAIT
CAN I MOVE THE BILL ACTUALLY.
YEAH GOT CALDERON. MINIMAL
TECHNICAL FIRST MIGHT COME FROM
LIE ONCE PLEASED AHEAD. GOOD
AFTER MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COULD LARRY MOORE'S ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU IT JUST ONE
MOMENT FOR NEXT COMMENT.
WHAT
WHAT NINE NINETY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY NINETY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MARINA DEL
OF A BIGGER SHALL AND I JUST
WANTED TO STATE THAT I SUPPORT-
THIS THAT EIGHTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU. OKAY DOLLAR LISTED TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I HAVE
A CAN'T BE SURE ACLU-
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND A SANDY
FINALLY. SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON- KATHY SURE HAPPENED
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION LET ME
JUST START BY SAYING ADULTS WHO
ENGAGE IN SEX ACTS WITH MINORS
CAN ALREADY BE CONVICTED FOR
OFFENSES THAT REQUIRES
ACCENTUATE JUST THREE. NINE TWO
WOULD REQUIRE DEFENDANTS
CONVICTED OF THE MISDEMEANOR
OFFENSE OF SOLICITING A MINOR
FOR PROSTITUTION TO REGISTER-
AND THIS IS IN THE SENSE THAT
INCLUDES BUT IS NOT LIMITED TO-
PEOPLE WHO THOUGHT THAT MINORS
FOR PROSTITUTION AND THEN
ENGAGE IN SEX ACTS WITH THEM
AND MAYBE SOMEONE WHO IS
THEMSELVES- A YOUNG PERSON WHO-
IS ENGAGED IN SEX WORK AND IS
PERSUADING A MINOR TICKET. TO
DO THAT FOR EXAMPLE. HELLO SEX
OFFENDER AT ALL OVER. INCLUDE
OVER NOW SEVEN OFFENDERS
ATTITUDE SIXTEEN ALREADY LAW
ENFORCEMENT CANNOT USE THE
REGISTRATION SYSTEM AS THEY
TENDED TO MONITOR THE OFFENDERS
WHO POSE A HIGH RISK OF RE
OFFENDING BECAUSE OF THE SHEER
NUMBER OF OFFENDERS WHO ARE
REQUIRED TO REGISTER AND THE
AMOUNT OF. BASICALLY PAPERWORK
THAT THAT IT'S REQUIRED JUST TO
MAINTAIN THE SYSTEM SIX THIS
BILL WOULD WORSEN THAT PROBLEM
BY ADDING A SIGNIFICANT GROUP
OF OFFENDERS WHO ARE CONVICTED
OF A LOW LEVEL AND- VOEPEL I.
WAS GREETED AND THANKED- BUT
CAN ALWAYS ALSO THE ORDER FOR
THE CRIME ADDRESS IN THIS BILL
THE CRIME BULLETIN PROSTITUTION
INVOLVING A MINOR IF THE JUDGE
THESE THAT THIS BILL WILL DO
NOTHING TO IMPROVE PUBLIC
SAFETY BUT INSTEAD POINTLESSLY
ADDS ADDITIONAL LONG TERM
PUNISHMENT IN THE FORM OF- TEN
YEARS OR MORE OF- BEING
REQUIRED TO REGISTER AS A SEX
OFFENDER FOR THESE OFFENDERS
BURGEONING WITH THEM AND MAKING
IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR THE
OFFENDERS INVOLVED CAN MOVE ON
AND GET YOUR CRIMINAL CONDUCT
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR. NO
VOTE. THANK YOU. THE EX. HI I'M
BY LINE UP IN A PUBLIC DEFENDER
SAN FRANCISCO FOR OVER TWENTY
YEARS I STARTED OUR SECTIONAL
FONG UNIT BAXEEN COUNTLESS
SOLICITATION CASES. MAKE NO
MISTAKE A LOT OF AGAINST
SOLICITING MINORS ARE TOUGH
ENOUGH THAT THEY ARE. THERE'S
NO NEED CREDIT AMENDMENT UNDER
CURRENT LAW REGISTRATION IS
REQUIRED IF YOU SELECTED A
MINOR WITH THE INTENT TO
SOLICIT MONEY. BUT IF THE MAN
THAT WILL HAVE THE EFFECT OF
SWEEPING AND TOO MANY PEOPLE
BECAUSE IT MAKES AN HONEST
MISTAKE A REGISTRABLE OFFENCE.
HONEST MISTAKES ARE EASY TO
MAKE TWENTY YOUNG SEX WORKERS.
TRYING TO LOOK OLDER. IN ONCE
CHAU. IT TOO DIFFICULT TO
DEFEND THE CASES. WORK
SYMPATHETIC YOUNG GIRL DRESSED
TO LOOK EVEN YOUNGER WILL
TESTIFY THE JURY WILL PAY HE
SHOULD HAVE KNOWN AND APPLY A
STRICT LIABILITY STANDARD.
WORSE YET HONEY SCHMIDT WILL BE
EVEN MORE SEVERE THAN
ANTICIPATED THE REALITY IS IT
WILL BE A LIFETIME REGISTRATION
IN MANY SITUATIONS PARTICULARLY
ONE BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE ARE
CHARGED BECAUSE THEY ARE
RACIALLY BIASED RISK ASSESSMENT
TOOL WHICH IS SIGNED HIGHER
RISK TO THOSE WITH PRIOR
ARRESTS AND MINOR CONVICTION.
THAT IS BOLD AND OVER COOLEY
NEIGHBORHOOD AND HIGHER IT
INCLUDES CHEER THREE BECAUSE
LIFETIME REGISTRATION. OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT WILL BE OVERLY
AGGRESSIVE POLICE AND
PROSECUTORS WILL TARGET
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. AND THE
DOOR WILL BE OPEN. JUST UP ON
POOL STATE UPPER. SEVENTEEN
ZERO WILL BE TRAPPED LOOK OLDER
IN DIDN'T TAKE THE COURTS IS DO
WE WANT TO MAKE. WHO SORT SO
WITH TAX WORK A REGISTERED.
I'VE HAD MANY COULD NOT LOBBY
STATEMENT WHO MADE THE THAT.
UNDER LAW THEY CAN ABLE TO DO
COUNT. ADDRESS PROP WERE ABLE
TO RETURN TO THEIR JOBS. AND
FAMILY. DO NOT REGISTRATION HAS
THE OPPOSITE. HUMILIATING LABEL
CAST PEOPLE TO EXERCISE. AND
COULD INTEGRATE INTO THE NEW
DEAD. CRIMINALS WITH. OVER THAT
PUNISHMENT. A LOT SUPPORT YOU
SEE DID NOT BE AN- FIFTEEN
YEARS UNLESS AMENDMENTS NOT
PREVAIL ESPECIALLY WHEN THE
WAITER. ALL DISPROPORTIONATELY
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED.
THANKS FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- TO ANY WITNESSES ON THE
VIDEO SCREEN SEEN NONE FOR BOTH
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR CAN YOU
OPEN UP THE LINE FOR OPPOSITION
TO AB EIGHT NINE TWO. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT NINE TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN SIR
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT NINE TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
NO COMMENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. SEEING NONE. MISTER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU MAKE UP I
APOLOGIZE I NEED TO TAKE ROLE.
NO THEN I HAVE TO GET IN MOTION.
WHAT DO ROLE FOR A QUICK JONES
SAWYER HERE LACKEY. BARRICADE
HAND CORK SANTIAGO C. R. TWO C.
R. TWO WEEKS. LEE FARMS PRESENT
CAR PRESIDENT- I'M A TICKET
VANTAGE OF IF YOU JUST GIVE ME
A SECOND WE HAVE A PROPOSED
CONSENT CALENDAR IF YOU ITEM
NUMBER THREE A. B. SEVEN SIX
FORCE ABOUT HIS CONTEMPT OF
COURT VICTIMS INTIMIDATION ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN A. B. SEVEN ONE
EIGHT CUNNINGHAM PEACE OFFICERS
INVESTIGATION MISCONDUCT-
NUMBER ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB
NINE TO FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
SEXUAL ASSAULT FORENSIC
EXAMINATION REIMBURSEMENT- A.
B. NOT ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB
TWO FIVE TWO JONES SAWYER
CONTRABAND IN STATE PRISONS-
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB
THIRTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
TRANSPORTATION TRANSIT JUST
DISTRICT POLICING
RESPONSIBILITIES I DON'T NUMBER
SIXTEEN AB SIX EIGHT NINE
PETRIE-NORRIS COMPREHENSIVE
STATEWIDE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
PROGRAM I DON'T KNOW BUT TWENTY
AB NINE THREE ONE PHILIP
KUBIAK. HOPEFULLY I GET IT
RIGHT PEACE OFFICER TRAINING.
DUTY TO INTERCEDE. MAY HAVE A
MOTION TO ACCEPT CONSENT SOME
OF. CALL THE ROLL. THIS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR JONES SAWYER
CHEN SO YOU'RE A LACKEY LACKEY
I OUR CAN PARKING HAD A COURT.
CORRECT I SAN DIEGO C. R. TWO
C. R. TO ATHLETICS. WICKS I LI
LI I. THE KIDS GOOD CALORIES
ADOPTED MRS SARATOGA I BELIEVE
YOU HAVE A MOTION YEAH I'M
GONNA MOVE THE BILL. WE HAVE A
THE MOTION TO APPROVE IN A
SECOND. AND YOU ARE MAKE
CLOTHES NOT MISTER CHOI. GUITAR
IS SUPPORTING TO HEAR OR
POSTING WITNESSES SO- TIED THIS
BILL TO- MY NO FANS SAW OR
RACIAL ISSUE. THIS IS SON
NOTHING TO DO WITH THAT ANY
RACIAL- ISSUE OF THE COLOR OF
THE SKIN ALL OR A DISS SONG
JUST SAW MY YOU KNOW MY NO
OFFENSE AS WE KNOW- IS SINCE
OUR LAST YEAR- ME TOO MOVEMENT
TO A SEXUAL OFFENSE ARE IN THE
JOB SETTING SO OFTEN FAMILIES
HEADING SOUTH HAS BEEN BIG BIG
ISSUE. THIS IS UP TO PROTECT US
THE GENERAL PUBLIC OFF FROM
THIS KIND OF ALL PERPETRATORS
OF SEXUAL IT IS SPECIALLY
MINERS THINK OF ALL THAT THE
INCIDENTS CAN HAPPEN TO YOUR
CHILDREN THIS IS. SAUCE SUCKS
ALL. OF SO. IS OFF ON THE PART
TO OVER. I MEAN THE PRIME HAS
BEEN ALREADY COMMITTED TO
SENTENCE HAS BEEN MADE TO AS
YOUR NORMAL ALTHOUGH THE PEOPLE
WHO. HAVE BEEN OFFENDED THOUGH
AND THE FOUND GUILTY OF ALL
REQUIRED TO REGISTER AS A TAX
OF SEX OFFENDERS SO AFRAID OF
WHAT THE MOVE A TOTAL. ALL
AREAS. HOW IN THE WORLD. THE OR
DOLLARS ALSO IS ADDING- SEX AND
END UP LOWERING THE MINERS SO
FOUR SACKS OF FULL EXCHANGE OF
THE VALUE OF VALUE OUR MONEY-
AND THAT THEY ARE OKAY AND THAT
THEY SHOULD NOT BE REGISTERED
THIS IS SAW OFF COMMONSENSE LAW
IT IS SAW UP TO YOUR GOOD
JUDGMENT I LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
I'VE WORKED. THANK YOU MISTER
CHOI MS YOU YOU MAY OR MAY NOT
KNOW- BLOOD D. D. A. OF LA AT
THE TIME. BUT ALSO TALKED ABOUT
THE TIME TO SPEND ON THE SEX
OFFENDER REGISTRY AND THAT WE
NEED TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT
THIS WAS NOT THE ANSWER AND
ALSO THE D. A. FROM ALAMEDA
COUNTY. HAS ALSO MENTIONED THAT
KIND OF THE SAME THING AND SO
UNFORTUNATELY- GOING BY THE
PEOPLE HAVE TO ACTUALLY DO THE
WORK OF LAW ENFORCEMENT I'M AN
ACTOR RESPECTFULLY ASTRONOVA.
CALLED COLORADO. AB EIGHT NINE
TWO BY SOME MEMBER CHOI THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER NO JONES SAWYER NOW
LACKEY. LACKEY I BARRICADE HAD.
ERIC HE HAD HI CORK. NO QUICK
NOTE SANTIAGO C. R. TO. THE
HOTEL I WICKS. WICKS NOW.
LEAGUE LEAN NOW. I'M SORRY THAT
MEASURE FAILS. WE ARE NOW
LOOKING FOR AUTHORS IF I DON'T
SEE ANYONE. RELATIVELY SOON WE
WILL HAVE MEMBERS. BEGIN GET
THIRTIES GIVEN SIXTY SECONDS
AND THEN OTHERWISE. YEAH YOU
WILL BEGIN. HIS FIRST COOPER.
TO YOU MAY BEGIN MR COOPER
YOU'RE UP NEXT.
THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BURST.
ACCORDING THE FBI HATE CRIME IS
A CRIMINAL OFFENSE AGAINST A
PERSON MOTIVATED BY THE
OFFENDER'S BIAS AGAINST A RACE
RELIGION DISABILITY SEXUAL
ORIENTATION ETHNICITY GENDER OR
GENDER IDENTITY VIOLENT ACTS OR
HATE. EXCUSE ME WELL THAT'S OF
HATE ARE ACTS OF TERROR PLAIN
AND SIMPLE VICTIMS OF VIOLENT
HATE CRIMES ARE MORE LIKELY TO
EXPERIENCE THE POSTTRAUMATIC
STRESS SAFETY CONCERNS
DEPRESSION ANXIETY AND ANGER
THE VICTIM OF CRIMES THEY'RE
NOT MOTIVATED BY BIAS. THEY
CONTINUE WITH THEIR LIVES OF
WHO THEY ARE HOW THEY LOOK WITH
NO ESCAPE FROM THAT. WHO WE
TALKING ABOUT HERE I WILL TELL
YOU. THE DEPARTMENT JUSTICES
TWENTY NINETEEN UNIFORM CRIME
REPORT DETAILS THAT HATE CRIME
PERPETRATORS OR MORE MOTIVATED
TO COMMIT THEIR CRIMES BASED ON
RACE FIFTY FIVE POINT 8%
RELIGION TWENTY ONE POINT FOUR
PERCENT. AND SEXUAL ORIENTATION
NINETEEN POINT 6% BETWEEN
NINETEENTH DISTINCTION- THEIR
WHOPPING SEVENTY EIGHT POINT
SIX WERE HATE ACTS DIRECTED
THAT AN ACTUAL PERSON NOT
PROPERTY AND 21% OF THOSE WERE
VIOLENT ASSAULTS. SPECIFICALLY
LA. IN LA THAT IS DISTURBING
LAST YEAR'S NUMBERS RECORDED
HATE CRIMES WITH THE WORST IN A
DECADE NUMBER THE LAST SIX
YEARS HATE CRIMES IN LA HAVE
GONE UP BY THIRTY SIX PERCENT.
IN THAT TIME FRAME THE MOST
SHOCKING INCREASES HAVE
OCCURRED IN THE ANTI
TRANSGENDER. RELIGIOUS JEWISH
MIDDLE EASTERN AND ASIAN
COMMUNITIES. S. S. AGAINST
TRANSGENDER PERSONS ROSE BY
SIXTY FOUR PERCENT. RECORDED
INCIDENTS OF HATE ERE ALARMING
SIXTY TWO POINT 2% AGAINST GAY
MEN. I GUESS THE PERSON BECAUSE
THEIR RELIGIOUS BELIEFS ROSE
ELEVEN PERCENT. 89% OF WHICH
WERE ANTI SEMITIC. THE NEW
LEISTER COMMUNITY WAS
DEVASTATED AS SUCH ACTS AGAINST
THEM INCREASED BY OVER A 142%
IT WILL BECOME TO AWARE OF
LATELY THE ASIAN COMMUNITY HAS
BEEN TARGETED EXPERIENCING A
30% INCREASE. MIND YOU THIS IS
PRIOR TO THE EPIDEMIC OF
ASSAULTS WE'VE SEEN THE
COMMUNITY IN TWENTY AND TWENTY
ONE SO FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY DATA. CONNECT
THE PAPER UNIVERSAL MANY
ASPECTS. THE VICTIM WA UNABLE
TO CHANGE THE WAY THEY LOOK.
THE WAY THE TRUTH THE WAY THAT
USED TO LIVE THEIR LIVES. FOR
THEIR PERSONAL RELIGIOUS LIVES.
THERE COMPLETELY UNSUSPECTING
OF DANGER PRE OPPOSED TO FALL
LIVING IN FEAR OF THEIR LITTLE
REMARKED. THEY GO TO A STORE A
PARK A RESTAURANT. A PLACE OF
WORSHIP FOR JUST WALK DOWN THE
STREET. THEY'RE LOCKED IN
CONSTANT FEAR. AND ONCE THE
VICTIM THE FEAR NEVER ESCAPES
THEM. THEY'RE NEVER RELEASED
THE VIOLENT ACT OF HATE LIVES
WITHIN THE REST THEIR LIVES
THEY'RE NEVER RELEASED FROM THE
PRISON. AB TWO SIXTY SIX WILL
MOVE THE MOST VIOLENT ACTS OF
HATE CRIMES IN THE PENAL CODE
FOR ME SERVICE CLASSIFICATION.
TO A VIOLENT CLASSIFICATION. AB
TWO SIXTY SIX ONLY APPLY IF I
PLAYED AGAIN ONLY APPLIES TO
THOSE INDIVIDUALS AND WHICH A
COURT HAS DINNER AXEL HINA'S.
SILVA THERE'S THAT THE STATE
PRISON. AB TWO SIX SIX DOES NOT
ADD ONE MORE DAY. TO A
CONVICTED PERSON'S COURT
ORDERED SENTENCE BUT IT KEEPS.
THEM IN THERE TO FILL THE
COURTS. WITH COURTS DO YOU MESS.
AB TWENTY SIX SIX. WILL MAKE A
PERSON CONVICTED. HATE CRIME.
AND SENT TO PRISON IN ELIGIBLE
FOR EARLY RELEASE. IS
INDIVIDUALS HAVE BEEN
INDOCTRINATED THAT CONDITIONED
WITH A POISON THAT HAS BEEN CUT
IN THE INTO THEIR MIND SO
DEEPLY. THAT'S AFFECTED THEIR
HEART. THE CONDITION THAT CAN
TAKE TIME TO REHABILITATE. MANY
MORE TIME NOT LESS. SOME PEOPLE
ARE EVIL DOES EVERY TO DO THE
MAJORITY THEIR SENSES OF THE
COURSE THE NECESSARY FOR FULL
REHABILITATION. AND I AM
UNAPOLOGETIC FOR THAT SO I ASK.
WHERE THE CHAMPIONS OF SOCIAL
JUSTICE ON THIS ISSUE. WHERE IS
THE QUALITY CALIFORNIA. THE
JEWISH FEDERATION. CARE AND A
POP UP THE NEXT VICTIM. THE
VICTIM DOES NOT HAVE TO BE FOR
THE NUMBERS NOW THAT EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU KNOW AT LEAST
ONE HATE CRIME VICTIM I URGE
YOU IN THESE ORGANIZATIONS TO
JOIN ME IN THIS FIGHT TO
ELIMINATE HATE CRIMES. AND THIS
IS MICHAEL AUTHOR SWIMMING EVAN
LOW. YES MR LOW. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH RESEARCHER AND COLLEAGUES
I WANT TO THANK OUR JOINT
AUTHORS IN ADDRESSING THE ISSUE
AT HAND SPECIFICALLY. AS YOU
ALL KNOW THAT THERE IS A RISE A
DANGEROUS RISE ON THE ATTACK ON
FELLOW AMERICANS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND IN OUR
NATION. AND THAT INDIVIDUALS IN
OUR STREETS ARE BEING TARGETED
VICTIMIZED AND MURDERED
SENSELESSLY. AND IN THE SAME
DIRECTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE FOCUSED ON
JUSTICE REFORM BUT THESE ISSUES
AND PROTECTING OUR COMMUNITIES
ARE NOT MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE. I
THANK THE CHAIR FOR HEARING
THIS BILL NâNG OPPORTUNITY TO
BE RESPONSIVE I FIND MYSELF
EVERY SINGLE WEEKEND NOW
MARCHING IN THE STREETS RALLY
WITH INDIVIDUALS CRYING OUT IN
ASKING WHAT WE CAN COLLECTIVELY
DO. AND I AM APPRECIATIVE OF
THE CONVERSATION TO ADDRESS AND
SEE WHAT WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
TACKLE THIS ISSUE. HAVE YOU
SEEN THERE'VE BEEN A NUMBER OF
MEASURES INCLUDING BUDGET
AUGMENTATION ON COLLECTING DATA.
SO THAT WE CAN HELP EMPOWER
LOCAL COMMUNITIES ON DATA
COLLECTION BUT THAT'S ONLY ONE
PIECE OF IT AND AGAIN THIS IS A
SENSIBLE MEASURE. TO HELP
ADDRESS AND BE RESPONSIVE TO
THE COMMITTEE'S AT HAND WHILE
ALSO RESPECTING THE DIRECTION
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WITH EMPATHY. AND WITH
COMPASSION AND WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU MR LOW MISTER COOPER-
ANY WITNESSES IN THE AUDIENCE
IN SUPPORT. ANY WITNESSES ON
THE VIDEO SCREEN. SEEN THAT
EIGHTEEN T. COULD YOU OPEN UP
THE PHONE LINES FOR WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. WHEN YOU WERE
SIXTEEN OR I'M SORRY THANK YOU
IF. THIS PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
FOR SUPPORT OF AB TWO SIX SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE CURRENTLY HAVE
THREE IN Q. IT'LL JUST BE ONE
WHITE OF ONE TWENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON- MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS LARRY MORSE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
THANKS THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CORY SO ZILLOW ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ONE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM EATING
BEEF FAT CALLING ON BEHALF OF
SAN DIEGO COUNTY GET YOU
ATTORNEY SUMMER STEPHAN AND WE
ARE STRONG SUPPORTER OF AB TWO
SIXTY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE MORE
COMMENTING JUST BE ONE MORE FOR
THAT WERE.
AND OVER TO LINE ONE
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH MISTER MEMBERS RUN
MULTIVERSAL SHARE FLOTATION
OAKLAND COURT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FOR COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS. THANK YOU
OPERATOR AND NOW WE IN OP A OF
A K. THE SHOW- IF YOU'LL YOU
CALL CALIFORNIA. AND MARGOT
GEORGE C. DEEP DEEP STATE FIFTY
A CALDERON BUT WITH THE OFFICE.
KAREN MEMBERS SHE FOR A YOU
CALICO ACTION- WE HAVE. A WITH
IT THE ASSEMBLY ON URGENT TO.
ACTIVE WAY TO FIGHT HE COULD IN
OUR SOCIETY AND IT'S BY ACTIVE
VIOLENCE MOTIVATED BY HATE.
THIS BILL HOWEVER NOT ABOUT
VIOLENCE CRIME IT IS ABOUT
HARSHER. FOR FILE CRIME. OUR
GETTING NONVIOLENT CRIMES BY RE
CATEGORIZING THEM AS PILOTS
WHAT DO NOT TO STOP THE
VIOLENCE HATE CRIME. THURMOND
FELONY HATE CRIME BUT NOT
FELONIES BANDEL THAT OVER NINE
IN AND FIFTY DOLLAR AND DOWN
CAN BE A FELONY HATE CRIME AS
FOLLOW COMMITTED ON THE BASIS
OF THE ACTUAL PERCEIVED
CHARACTERISTICS OF THE VICTIM
IT. TO CRY DEFINITE. ONE OF THE
FELONY IS COMMITTED THAT IS
ALSO A CRIME IT CAN BE. AS A
FILE FELONY WOULD INCREASE
PENALTY THE PRESIDENT THAT HE
CRIME. TRYING TO BUY FIGHT
VIOLENCE CRIMES BY INCREASE THE
SIZE NON OFFENDERS AREN'T.
MAKES LITTLE. WE RESPECT ASK
YOUR NO. THANK YOU. MCGEORGE
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M MARCO CHIU
FOR THE PUBLIC WHO SAYS. THE
CALIFORNIA PA TO WITH STAN
APOLOGY THE WITH COMING OF
COLOR EMMA WHO CLEARED THE OF
HATE CRIMES IN PUNISHED DOES
NOT IT'S A TO THE PROBLEM AND
FACT INCREASING IS. WE HAVE
ALREADY WITNESSED THIS BILL
CALL OF MASS KERR HAS MADE A
COME LAST DAY AND A THAT SCARES
REESE THANKS HEALTH CARE MIDDLE
HEALTH TREATMENT AND HOW TO
INSTEAD AND STILL MORE. WE MUST
OPPOSE AB SICK SIX BECAUSE IT
WOULD DO NO TO END UP EPIDEMIC
OF HATE CRIMES ENDING HATE
TAKES MORE WORK AND DEDICATION
AND PROS SPENDING INCREASING
AND ARE PER. AS A- I WENT WITH
MY FATHER WITH THE CLOCK MORE
YOUR WITH THE EIGHT. TO THE
CREW CORNEA COMMUNE. EUROPE
STORE. IN THE LATE NIGHT
FIFTIES. AND INNER FORM COMING.
THE CLERK KLAN AND THEIR
NEIGHBORS BOB HAVE. FIRED
THROUGH THEIR WINDOW IN ATTEMPT
TO BUY THEM ALL THEIR- THEY
WERE. TO LEAVE I THOUGHT HELP.
A BIRTH TO HAVE FOR HUMANITY
AND ARTS THERE TODAY ALL.
TODAY'S THE SOUTHERN LOST HAS
ITS POINT PROGRAM TO FIGHT HATE
SEVEN BODY CYNIC MANY THE LAST
FROM THE- ACT. SO FORCES
SUPPORTED THE. TAKE UP EDUCATE
YOUR CREATE AN OLD. PRESSURE WE
HERE ARE WE STATE. T. H. X.
BIASES TOWARD EARLY OFTEN HOME
CAN OFFER LET OF TOLERANCE
ACCEPT. J. DEEPER LOOKING YOUR
CELL OR BY. AND STIR OUT. THIS
POINT PRO CAN BE BEST SO AS
COME TO DISOBEY HATE AND TALK
THAT AT. IN THE WORKPLACE AND
IN COMMUNITIES EXCEL FUNDING AS
A PURSE DOES. IT FROM A TO THAT
IS TO LEARN OF AND THEN THE I
BELIEVE THAT EVERY VOICE
MATTERS. AT ALL PEOPLE ARE BY.
NO WAY AS WELL THAN I WISH URGE
SHOULDN'T VOTE ON A TWO SIX SIX
THANK YOU THANK YOU WILL BRING
IT BACK THE INTO THE HEARING
ROOM. AT ANYONE IN UPPER IN THE
ROOM. EIGHT TWO SIX SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN FOR OPPOSITION
OF EIGHT EIGHT TWO SIX SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
ONE IN Q. WILL GOING TO WHITE
EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. CANTERO
DARNELL ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I DO HAVE ONE MORE IN Q.
IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR
THAT LINE. NINE NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS GREGORY PUT OUT
OF COMMISSION AND JUSTICE IN
THE SPECTRAL OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU WILL
BRING YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS MISTER COURTESY
ARTURO. AND STILL LACKING- SO I
DON'T HAVE A QUESTION BUT I DO
HAVE A COMMENT. ON AND THAT IS
WHY COLEEN NONVIOLENT FELONIES
VIOLENT- YOU WILL ACTUALLY
INCREASE THE TIME IN JAIL
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T GET AS MUCH
CREDIT. ALSO THAT- THIS WAS
PART OF PROPOSITION TWENTY
WHICH WAS OVERWHELMINGLY VOTED
DOWN. AND FOR THAT REASON I
CAN'T SUPPORT THIS- THIS BILL
THANK YOU SO WHEN I WAS IT
MISTER GEN OKAY THERE WASN'T A
QUESTION. SO NEXT THIS IS YOUR
OUT OF. THANK YOU I WANT TO
THANK A- MISTER COOPER MR LOW
FOR I'M BRINGING THIS COMMON
SENSE MEASURE FORWARD HERE THEY
HATE THEY TALK ABOUT LOSING
PEOPLE AND THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT HAVE THAT I MAY
HAVE THAT INSIDE THEM- BUT THEY
DON'T ACT OUT ON IT THE PROBLEM
IS WHEN THEY REALLY START
ACTING OUT ON THAT. THERE
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE ENOUGH OF A
DETERRENT OTHERWISE WE WOULDN'T
BE HAVING THE PROBLEMS THAT WE
HAVE TODAY. SO WHAT WE ARE
DOING IS CLEARLY NOT WORKING.
AND WE NEED TO DO MORE TO
CREATE THOSE DETERRENTS AND
HOLDING PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THEIR RIDICULOUSLY. MISGUIDED
BEHAVIOR AND- SO- I APPLAUD YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
TRYING TO ATTACK THIS WITH
COMMONSENSE AND ACCOUNTABILITY
AND- SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING AT
NIGHT MOTION TO MAKE A MOTION
TO APPROVE THEM MISTER MISTER
COOPER MR LOW YOU CAN WHATEVER
ANYONE SAID YOU CAN WRAP IT UP
IN YOUR- IN YOUR CLOTHES OKAY.
OKAY ALL RIGHT MOTION TO BY THE
WAY YES. WELL I JUST LIKE TO
FOLLOW UP ON- MISTER SEA OUR
TOES ACCOLADES. AND SAY THANK
YOU TO BOTH OF YOU FOR BEING
THE VOICE OF THE- MANY PEOPLE
WHO AREN'T ABLE TO SIT THERE.
AND EXPLAIN TO US WHY WE SHOULD
BE SUPPORTING THIS MEASURE.
WHEN THE JUDICIAL ARM
APPROPRIATELY RESPONSE TO
ACTIONS OF HATE. WE SUPPORT
VICTIMS AND THEY DESERVE THAT
LEVEL OF SUPPORT AND I'M PROUD
TO SUPPORT THIS MEASURE WHICH I
BELIEVE. DOES WHAT'S SORELY
NEEDED IN OUR SYSTEM. THANK YOU
MISS WICKS Q. I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S- DESIRE TO TACKLE THE
HATE CRIME ISSUE BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S VERY REAL AND
PRESENT IN OBVIOUSLY WE'VE BEEN
EXPERIENCING IT- IN A MULTITUDE
OF WAYS IN OUR COMMUNITIES WELL
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THIS
COUNTRY FRANKLY- BUT I SHARED-
MISTER CORKS CONCERNS WITH THE
BILL- YOU KNOW. NOT ALL HATE
CRIMES ARE VIOLENT AND SO IF
SOMEONE- HAD PROPERTY DAMAGE
OVER NINE HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS
THAT WOULD BE THEN CONSIDERED-
A VIOLENT FELONY- AND WOULD
HAVE ACCORDINGLY THAT
PUNISHMENT- AND I ALSO SHARE
THE CONCERN AROUND THE POINT IS
REYES AROUND PROP TWENTY THIS
IS THAT THAT WAS THIS WAS
INCLUDED IN PROP TWENTY THAT
WAS VOTED DOWN- SO FOR THESE
REASONS I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY BUT I DO
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
AND- AND HOPE THAT. THE AUTHORS
CONTINUE TO TACKLE THE ISSUE.
THE OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. MISTER COOPER AND MR
LOW WHOEVER WANTS OR BOTH
JOINTLY. HOWEVER YOU WANTED.
YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
COLLEGE FOR COMMENTS. YOU KNOW
YOU HEAR YOU HEAR ABOUT. SO
MUCH OF THE THAT HURT AND THAT
PAIN DIRECTORS PAIN AND I KNOW
THAT EACH OF YOU FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE COMMUNITIES NEAR
DISTRICTS- AND YOU HEAR
SPEECHES ABOUT WHAT WE NEED TO
DO TO TACKLE THIS ISSUE BUT
ALSO MADE BEFORE YOU THAT IT IS
NOT ENOUGH JUST FOR ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
STATE BUDGET TO DO DATA
COLLECTION OR TO HELP WORK WITH
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE COME UPON US TO
PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES LET ME
TELL YOU WHAT I'M HEARING FROM
MY COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND THEY
FOR CIDER COMMITTEE IS.
ESPECIALLY DURING THE ISSUE OF
BLACK LIVES MATTER WHERE OUR
BLACK AND BROWN BROTHERS AND
SISTERS MARCHING WITH US IN
SOLIDARITY AND DOING THE TYPE
OF WORK THAT IS SO ON POINT
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE I WANT TO
COMMEND ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER
FOR DOING JUST THAT AND SAYING
WHAT DO WE HAVE AT OUR DISPOSAL
TO HELP ATTACK ON A DRESS THESE
ISSUES. AGAIN THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO LOOK AT
SOMETHING SENSIBLE AND THESE
ISSUES ARE NOT MUTUALLY
EXCLUSIVE I WELCOME THE
PARTNERSHIP AND APPRECIATE AND
RESPECT THE POSITION OF THE
COMMITTEE AND INDIVIDUAL
MEMBERS BUT ALSO USE THIS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY THAN TO SAY IF YOU
ARE NOT SUPPORTIVE OF THIS WHAT
IN ADDITION WILL YOU DO TO BE
PROACTIVE VERSUS JUST SIMPLY
THE STATUS QUO WELL YOU DO TO
BE A CHAMPION AND HELPING TO
ADVOCATE FOR THOSE THAT DON'T
HAVE A VOICE AND THAT'S WHAT
YOU SEE HERE TODAY THE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN TWO MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE TRYING TO
TACKLE AN ISSUE. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONTINUED
DIALOGUE WITH US COLLECTIVELY
AS A WHOLE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU MISTER COOPER.
THE GOOD MR LOW WHAT WHAT WE
YOU DO I THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE AND I WORRY ABOUT YOU
EVERY DAY. ON THE WEEKENDS AND
ROUTE IT THAT THESE PROTESTS IN
THESE ISRAELIS. TO RELIGIOUS
AGING HATE CRIMES I WORRY ABOUT
YOU. SOMETHING HAPPENED TO YOU
BECAUSE YOU'RE REYES. I MET
YOUR FATHER MANY TIMES I WORRY
ABOUT YOUR FATHER GO IN THE
STORE. IF SOMEONE ASSAULTING
THE COLORS GREAT BODILY INJURY.
AND I'LL TELL YOU WHAT. DE
QUESTIONS FINE WE'VE GOT WILL
PLAY FOR MILLION FOR A HOTLINE
SO TELL US MORE. WELL THERE'S
MORE CRIMES AGAINST THE API
COMMUNITY WHAT KIND OF
DECISIONS WE KNOW THAT. YOU
REPORT THAT'S GREAT. BUT WHAT
ARE WE DOING. AND MR CORK MADE
A COMMENT ABOUT PROP TWENTY
FILLED. PUMP TWENTY HAD MANY
MOVING PARTS TO IT. THAT WAS
JUST ONE PART WAS MULTIPLE HATE
CRIMES. WELL NOT JUST THE HATE
CRIMES BILL THIS IS HATE
CRIMES. VERY NEARLY TO FIND.
FIVE FULL MISTER CORKS. MOTOR
THINKING. PROP FIFTEEN THE
BUSINESS THAT TAX THAT FIELDING
CAME BACK. PROPOSITIONS SIXTEEN
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION. THAT WAS
VOTED DOWN. PROP EIGHTEEN TO
THE SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD VOTE
YOUR BILL. THAT WAS VOTED DOWN.
PROP TWENTY ONE RICK CONTROL
THAT WAS VOTED DOWN. PROP
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY FIVE WE WERE
LIVE THAT WAS VOTED DOWN. PROP.
TWENTY FIVE BILL REFERENDUM SO.
NO IT DOESN'T. THAT THIS IS NOT
MATH OF COURSE. IF YOU THINK
ABOUT IT. THIS IS THE ONLY HATE
CRIMES CAUSING GREAT BODILY
INJURY SOMEONE- INJURING
SOMEONE AND YOU'RE DESTROYING
YOUR VISUALIZING A PLACE OF
WORSHIP. SO FOR SOMEONE TO GET
SENT TO STATE PRISONAS WE KNOW
RIGHT NOW MOST FOLKS GO TO
COUNTY JAIL BECAUSE REALIGNMENT
SILVA JUDGE EEMS THAT CRIME SO
VICIOUS SO BAD THAT HE'S IN
SOME OF THE STATE PRISON.
THAT'S WHAT HE'S DOING SO WHAT
IT DOESN'T DO. IT DOESN'T TAKE
AWAY GOOD TIME IT DOESN'T TAKE
AWAY PROGRAM TIME IT TAKES A WE
WORK TIME THAT'S ALL IT DOES
FOR STILL GETTING THOSE CREDITS.
SO THE BIGGEST TAX WE WORK TIME.
SO THE JUDGE SENTENCES YOU TO A
SENSE. NO TAKING ACCOUNT OF ALL
THE GOOD TIME WORK TIME BLAH
BLAH BLAH BLAH BLAH IT IS A
SENTENCE. SO BUT THIS BILL SAYS
IF YOU DO SOMETHING SOLD BONTA
SALINAS THAT YOU KNOW WHAT YOU
DON'T GET TO GET OUT SIX MONTHS
EARLY THAT'S ALL THE BILL DOES.
THIS NUTRITIONAL TIME. THE
JUDGE THAN SHE ORIGINALLY.
THOUGHT SO THE BIG ISSUE WITH
THAT. AND IT AND IT'S SOMETHING
TO THINK ABOUT LOOK WE SEEN FOR
OUR ASIAN COMMUNITIES. YOU KNOW
WHAT WHAT WHAT IS THE
LEGISLATURE DONE SO FAR.
NOTHING PEOPLE ON THEIR HANDS
ALL THESE CAUCUSES. THE TALK
ABOUT THINGS OF PEOPLE'S RIGHTS
WE WILL DEFEND PEOPLE WILL
DEFEND OUR LGBTQ COMMUNITY. OUR
API COMMUNITY. FIRMEST HOLD A
STEP OUT AND GET INVOLVED I
APPLAUD HIM FOR THAT. WHAT IS
DOING THE RIGHT THING FOR HIS
PEOPLE AND FOR ALL OF
CALIFORNIA. GUSTA FOR SOMETHING
OTHERWISE DIFFICULT LIKE THE
PROUD BOYS. THEY'RE OUT DOING
THIS TYPE OF CRIME. AND THAT'S
A SHAME THAT'S A SHAME WHO
REPRESENT THE VICTIMS. RIVERS
FOR LOCAL PEOPLE HUNDRED FORTY
TWO PERCENT. IN VIOLENT CRIMES.
READY TO HEAR FOR THAT 142% BUT
CALIFORNIA HAS A HOTLINE SO WE
CAN FIND THAT OUT REALLY. THAT
IS HORRIBLE. THAT IS HORRIBLE.
IT'S TIME TO STEP UP AND SAY
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH AND NOT JUST
THIRTY EIGHT HE WILL DO
SOMETHING LET'S DO SOMETHING IS
NOT THAT DATA SAID IF SOMEONE
IF YOU BEAT UP OLD MAN WITHIN A
SERVICEABLE OLD. ASIAN LADY
BEAT HER UP YOU KNOW WHAT YOU
SHOULD SEE TWO BUTTONS JAIL AND
NOT GET OUT EARLY. SO IT'S ONE
LESS THING TO PICK YOUR PICK IN
THE PERPETRATOR THE PROBABLE
IT'S- THE TICKET CAL COMMUNAL
BETWEEN. SO WITH THAT- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER I THANK
YOU FOR SLOW- I'M- I'M PROBABLY
ONE OF THE FEW. THAT REALLY
UNDERSTANDS. WHAT IT'S LIKE TO
BE SINGLED OUT REMEMBER TARGET.
ON YOU AS A BLACK ELECTED
OFFICIAL- OR EVEN TO GO TO
OTHER CAUCUSES AND OTHER
MEMBERS WHO SAID MAY HAVE SAID
IT'S NOT OUR ISSUE. WE NOW
KNOW. IT'S ALL OF OUR ISSUES.
EVERY LAST ONE OF US IS OUR
ISSUE. AND I THINK IT'S BECOME
VERY CLEAR NOW WHAT I WOULD
LIKE TO OFFER BECAUSE SAID IT
SAID WHAT SHOULD WE DO NOW. I'M
REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
GENERAL. WHICH IS DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. ALTOGETHER WHICH
INCLUDES HATE CRIMES ARE
SPECIALLY HATE CRIMES AND- WE
NEED TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT THAT
AND I WOULD LIKE. TWO OF MY
COLLEAGUES. FROM NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA TO JOIN WITH ME TO
TRY TO CRAFT A DOMESTIC
TERRORIST BILL. BECAUSE IT'S
NOT JUST A WHITE OR BLACK PINK
OR WHITE OR LATINO THING OR
LIKE OR OR OR WHITE OR API.
WE'VE GOT SOME WE HAVE AFRICAN
AMERICANS DON'T THAT MAY HAVE
SOME PROBLEMS SO HE- DOES NOT
HAVE A COLOR LINE IT IS
PERVASIVE AMONGST EVERY COLOR
LINE NOT JUST ONE SO IT IS A
GENERAL CAUCUS PROBLEM. AND
WHEN IT COMES TO COMES TO D.
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE TRANSGENDER
AND OTHERS IT IS OUT OF CONTROL
SO WE NEED. TO CUT WE'D
ACTUALLY DO NEED TO COME
TOGETHER AND FIGURE THIS OUT- I
WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE TO SAY
PEOPLE WHO PUT TARGETS ON A
BLACK MAN THAT THAT'S A HATE
CRIME. BUT A. . SIX SIX WHICH
WOULD MAKE THAT AND THAT'S
THAT'S NOT A VIOLENT. AS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAD TO EXPRESS
TO ME MAKE ME UNDERSTAND. THAT
IS NOT A VIOLENT HATE CRIME
THAT HE DIDN'T THINK IT ROSE TO
THE LEVEL. OF MY SECURITY MY
FAMILY SECURITY WITH THE
SECURITY. OF MY STAFF. AND SO.
WHILE I BELIEVE THIS MEASURE
MAY NOT COMPLETELY GET TO IT
AND I LAST MEMBERS TO VOTE NO.
BUT I WOULD ASK THAT WE ALL
VOTE YES LATER. TO COME UP WITH
THE OVERALL PLAN TO GET THIS
DONE I AGREE WITH BOTH OF YOU.
THAT WE SHOULD CONTINUE TO SIT
ON OUR HANDS AND WE COME UP
WITH A COPY HAS A BILL TO
ACTUALLY TACKLE THIS. IN ITS
ENTIRETY. NOT JUST NOT JUST A
PROBLEM FOR IT BUT EVEN PEOPLE
WHO. WHO ALL RIGHTS AND
TERRIBLE THINGS WE NEED TO. WE
SHOULD REALLY GET WE REALLY
NEED TO NAIL THIS BECAUSE
DOMESTIC TERRORISM SEEMS TO BE
THE HARDEST THING. AND NO ONE'S
TACKLE UNIT IN CALIFORNIA IN A
IN A IN A SUBSTANTIVE WAY. SO I
BOB. I WILL TAKE A BACKSEAT LET
YOU TAKE THE LEAD ABROAD TAKE
THE LEAD I AM GOING TO TAKE THE
LEAD. BUT PLEASE HELP ME WITH
THAT. UNFORTUNATELY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
CALDERON ON AB TWO SIX SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER THE
MISSION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER. NO JONES SAWYER NOW
LACKEY LACKEY HI BARRICADE
HANNAH. QUIRK NOW CORK NOW
SANTIAGO. C. R. TWO. HI THERE
TELL I WICKS. WICKS NOW LEAD.
LEAN NOW. UNFORTUNATE MEASURE
FAILS BUT THE IDEA THE CONCEPT
IS NOT. OKAY. TRYING TO
CRIMINALIZE EVERY STEP HAS SOME
OF THE PRISONERS YOUR SOLUTION
THANKS. WHAT WAS THAT. FOR READ
THE NEXT WE HAVE- MISTREATMENT.
A. B. SIX SEVEN NINE ARE IN
CUSTODY INFORMANTS PROHIBITS
THE USE OF TESTIMONY BY. CUSSED
A BITE BECAUSE HE INFORMED.
THANK YOU- MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
I WANT TO THANK YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR ALL OF THEIR HARD
WORK AND THEIR HELP WITH THIS
BILL INCOMES IN CUSTODY
INFORMANTS HAVE PROPOSED HAVE
PROVEN TO BE A SIGNIFICANT
CAUSE OF WRONGFUL CONVICTIONS
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE IN
CALIFORNIA THERE HAVE BEEN TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTEEN KNOWN
EXONERATIONS. OF THESE TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTEEN CASES NINETEEN
INVOLVED FALSE CLAIMS OF JAIL
HOUSE INFORMANTS EIGHTEEN TO
THE CENTRAL INDIVIDUALS ARE
SERVING LIFE SENTENCES AND
COLLECTIVELY THESE MEN AND
WOMEN SPEND THREE HUNDRED AND
FIVE YEARS WRONGFULLY
INCARCERATED. NATIONWIDE SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE WE'VE
KNOWN THAT 17% OF WRONGFUL
CONVICTIONS. HAD TO DO WITH
INACCURATE TESTIMONY WITH FROM
JAIL HOUSE INFORMANTS AND I
WOULD SUBMIT TO YOU. THAT IF WE
KNEW THAT THERE WAS A TEST A
FINGERPRINT TEST OR D. N. AND
DNA TESTS THAT WE KNEW WAS 17%
INACCURATE WE WOULD NOT ALLOW
THAT TEST TO BE USED. TO
INCARCERATE PEOPLE TO CONVICT
PEOPLE OF SERIOUS CRIMES. THE
USE OF IN CUSTODY INFORMANTS IN
CRIMINAL PROSECUTIONS. BY ITHAS BEEN A LONG TIME
INVESTIGATIVE TOOL BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT. BUT DESPITE
SCANDALS REVEALING THE
CONSTITUTIONAL IMPLICATIONS OF
THE USE OF INFORMANTS AND THEIR
APPARENT ABILITY TO LOOK THE TO
LIFE THE PRACTICE CONTINUES TO
THIS DAY. RECENTLY AN ORANGE
COUNTY THEY HAVE FACED NATIONAL
CRITICISM FOR THEIR SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT USE OF INCENTIVIZED
INFORMANTS TO ELICIT ELICIT
INCRIMINATING INFORMATION FROM
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS TO
SKIRT CONSTITUTIONAL
PROTECTIONS THIS IS BEEN.
WRITTEN ABOUT EXTENSIVELY IN
THE L. A. TIMES AND ELSEWHERE
AND IS REALLY BROUGHT GREAT
SHAME TO THAT POLICE DEPARTMENT
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT OUR OWN
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA HAS ASKED THE
LEGISLATURE TO ADDRESS AND SET
STRONG PARAMETERS. LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFER OF BENEFITS
IN RETURN FOR PROVIDING
INFORMATION INCENTIVIZES THOSE
IN CUSTODY FABRICATE TESTIMONY
IN EXCHANGE FOR THESE BENEFITS.
HOWEVER OFTEN THESE BENEFITS
ARE REALLY PROVIDED A REVEALED
AHEAD OF THE INFORMANT'S
TESTIMONY. PROTECTS PROTECTING
IT FROM EFFECTIVE CROSS
EXAMINATION. IF THE DEFENSE WAS
TO OFFER IN ADVANCE INCENTIVES
TO A DEFENSE WITNESS THIS WOULD
BE CONSIDERED TAMPERING OR
BRIBE REALLY IN THERE FOR
ILLEGAL. WHAT THEY DO IS THEY
GO TO THESE JAIL HOUSE
INFORMANTS AND IT'S KIND OF A
WINK WINK TESTIFIED THEY DO IT
KNOWING FULL WELL THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO BENEFIT FROM IT IF
THEY MADE THEM THAT OFFER AHEAD
OF TIME THAT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED BRIBERY AND YET WE
ALLOW IT TO BE DONE ON THE REAR
END. LAST YEAR JUSTICE COURT IN
LIEU OF THE SUPREME CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT CALLED UPON THE
LEGISLATURE TO DO SOMETHING.
ABOUT LAW ENFORCEMENT'S USE OF
INCENTIVIZE INFORMANTS BECAUSE
OF THE PRACTICES DIRECTOR
CONSTITUTIONAL PROTECTIONS AND
PUBLIC SAFETY I PUTTING A
PERKINS AGENT IN A JAIL CELL
WITH SOMEONE WHO'S ON TRIAL AND
NOT TELLING THEM THAT WHATEVER
THEY SAY MIGHT BE USED AGAINST
THEM. THAT SKIRTS THE MIRANDA
WARNING COMPLETELY AND I DON'T
SEE HOW WE ARE ABLE TO DO THAT
RIGHT NOW IN CALIFORNIA. SB SIX
SEVENTY NINE IT WOULD END THIS
PRACTICE TO PROTECT THE
INNOCENT AND THE INTEGRITY OF
PROSECUTIONS FOR VICTIMS AND
SURVIVORS OF CRIMES. TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT THIS MORNING R.
SCOTT SANDERS A CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEY THAT WORKED ON TWO
DEATH PENALTY CASES AT THE SAME
TIME INVOLVING THE SAME
INFORMANT. AND IN THE PROCESS
AND BILLING ONE OF THE LARGEST
INFORMANT SCANDAL IN THE
COUNTRY I MELISSA DAGO CONNELL
A STAFF ATTORNEY WITH THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA INNOCENCE
PROJECT IN SANTA CLARA. I
APPRECIATE YOUR THOUGHTFUL
CONSIDERATION OF THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BILL AND I WOULD
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
AND YOUR YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT. FOR THEY- MISTER
SANDERS AND MISSILE CONNELL YOU
MAY BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS SCOTT
SANDERS IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
WELL REPRESENTING DEFENDANTS IN
TWO SEPARATE DEATH PENALTY
CASES I LEARNED THAT BOTH OF MY
CLIENTS HAVE BEEN APPROACHED BY
THE SAME JAIL HOUSE INFORMANT
YOUR PART IN THE COUNTY JAIL.
WITNESSES PRESENTED THIS IS A
COINCIDENCE AND DENIED A
COORDINATED EFFORT TO DIRECT
INFORMANTS TO QUESTION
DEFENDANTS ABOUT THEIR CASES.
HOWEVER IT'S THREE IN ONE
RAVELLO IS ACTUALLY TAKING
PLACE WITHIN OUR JAILS THE CASE
AGAINST MY CLIENT WHO KILLED
EIGHT PEOPLE AND RATTLED AS
WELL. THE MISCONDUCT WOULD LEAD
FIRST TO THE REFUSAL THE DA'S
OFFICE IN TWO THOUSAND. FIFTEEN
FURTHER DISCOVERIES OF HIDDEN
DATABASES THAT LOGS IN
UNTRUTHFUL TESTIMONY LED THE
TRIAL JUDGE IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN TO PROHIBIT A
SENTENCE OF DEATH. IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWENTY FOUR YEARS
AFTER THE COURT OF APPEALS
AFFIRMED THE REFUSAL THE DA'S
OFFICE. ADMITTED THAT SOON
AFTER THE APPELLATE RULING THE
AGENCY ACTUALLY BEGAN
WITHHOLDING CRITICAL INFORMED
EVIDENCE. THAT HAD BEEN
UNCOVERED BUT THIS IS REALLY
JUST THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG AS
WE LOOK BACK OVER THE DECADES.
IDENTICAL LEGAL KIND OF GIVEN
ORCHESTRATED IN CASE AFTER CASE
IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE WE
ARE POISED TO LEARN THE RESULTS
OF THE DOJ CIVIL RIGHTS
INVESTIGATION. APPEARS AT THE
AGENCY MAY BE FOCUSED ON A
HUNDRED CASES THEY'RE ALREADY
BEEN MORE THAN TWENTY INCLUDING
MULTIPLE MURDER CASES HAVE BEEN
REDUCED. AT A SCENE REDUCE
SENTENCES NEW TRIALS AND
DISMISSED CHARGES. I SHOULD
HAVE THIS IS EMPHASIZED THAT BY
NO MEANS IS ORANGE COUNTY AN
OUT LIAR MANY COUNTIES MAY NOT
EXPERIENCE THEIR SCANDAL. YET
OKAY HAVE THE SAME ISSUES
BENEATH THE SURFACE BEFORE
ORANGE COUNTY THE LARGEST
INFORMERS SCANDAL OCCURRED IN
LA IN THE EIGHTIES AND EARLY
NINETIES. LESSONS WERE IGNORED
NOT JUST BY ORANGE COUNTY HAVE
SPOKEN ABOUT THESE ISSUES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WHAT I'VE
HEARD AGAIN AND AGAIN. HOW
COUNCIL HAVE NOT BEEN TOLD
ABOUT RECORDS THE REASONS
INFORMANTS REMOVED IN THE JAIL
DOCUMENTATION OF PRIOR
PERFORMANCE NOTES AND RECORDS.
ABOUT TACK ACTS WITH INFORMANTS
WHAT THIS IN QUESTIONING MEANS
IS A KEY IN FOUR. KEY INFORMANT
EVIDENCE HAS BEEN HIDDEN
RECORDS HAVE BEEN DESTROYED AND
KEEP POLICIES WERE NEVER PUT IN
PLACE. THE TRUTH IS THAT
INFORMANTS ARE FIXTURES WHICH
IS WHY. IT'S BEEN SO APPEALING
OVER THE YEARS BUT THEY COMBINE
SEEN MOST OFTEN WHEN THERE'S AN
OBVIOUS WEAKNESS IN THE CASE.
CASES WERE ONE INCENTIVIZE
WITNESSED UP QUESTIONABLE
HONESTY CAN. BE THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN A WRONGFUL IN. AND IT.
TO QUIT. ONE OF THE REASON WHY
THIS PER. LIKE YOU SAY
LEGISLATION IS SO. IS THE
LOCATION OF WHERE THE
INFORMANTS WITH BEHIND THE JAIL.
THERE IS NO. THAT ONE. RECALL
DISCLOSURES A JAIL DEPUTIES WE
DID NOT AN UNSPOKEN AGREEMENT
CORPS SECRET BENEFIT THAT
THAT'S TO BE PROVIDED IN THE
FUTURE. NOR WILL ANY WILL
ENSURE THE INFORMANTS PASSED
DECEPTION IN THE JAIL OR PRIOR
INFORMING EFFORTS WILL BE FULLY
DISCLOSED. IN ALL OF THESE
PROBLEMS EXIST IN ADDITION TO
THE FACT INFORMANTS ARE
APPROPRIATELY DESCRIBED AS THE
MOST UNRELIABLE WITNESS IN THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM. THEREFORE WELL
WE WILL NEVER FULLY CORRECT
WHICH GOING SO TERRIBLY WRONG.
BECAUSE OF THE USE OF JAIL
HOUSE INFORMANTS THIS BILL
APPROPRIATELY RECOGNIZES THE
IMPORTANCE OF NOT CLOSING OUR
EYES TO THE COMPELLING LESSONS.
WE HAVE ALREADY LEARNED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT GOOD
AFTERNOON GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE
MEMBER MELISSA O'CONNELL FROM
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
INNOCENCE PROJECT I WAS ONE OF
THE ATTORNEYS FOR OUR CLIENT
JACK FAGAN. JACK LOCK THIRTY
FOUR YEARS OF HIS LIFE
INCARCERATED FOR A CRIME HE DID
NOT COMMIT. IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
SIX JACK WAS CONVICTED OF FIRST
DEGREE SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCE
MURDER AND SENTENCED TO LIFE
WITHOUT THE POSSIBILITY OF
PAROLE. BEHIND THE TESTIMONY AS
TO INCENTIVIZE JAILHOUSE
INFORMANT WHO CLAIMED HE
CONFESSED TO THEM. MAN MADE A
CAREER OF INFORMING ONE WAS
INFORMING ON AT LEAST THREE
OTHER CASES AT THE SAME TIME OF
JACK. THEY BOTH HAD LENGTHY
CRIMINAL HISTORY INCLUDING
CONVICTIONS FOR BURGLARY.
ROBBERY AND FALSELY
IMPERSONATING A POLICE OFFICER.
AND BOTH RECEIVED LENIENCY FOR
THEIR TESTIMONY AGAINST JACK.
JACK ALWAYS MAINTAINED HIS
INNOCENCE BUT IT WOULD TAKE
OVER THIRTY YEARS SEVENTEEN OF
WHICH FOR WITH OUR OFFENSE. TO
CHANGES IN THE LAW AND THE
ADVENT OF DNA EVIDENCE SHOWING
JACK COMPLETE ABSENCE FROM THE
CRIME SCENE AND THE PRESENCE OF
OR MORE LIKELY PERPETRATORS.
FOR THE COURT OF APPEALS TO
REALIZE JACK INNOCENT. AND THE
INFORMANT BLYDE. ON OCTOBER
ELEVENTH TWO THOUSAND AND
NINETEEN AB SEVENTY FIVE YEARS
OLD PARTIALLY BLIND AND AFTER
MOVING THIRTY FOUR YEARS OF HIS
LIFE WRONGLY INCARCERATED. I
CAME HOME FROM R. J. DONOVAN
STATE PRISON A FREE MAN. IT
WOULD TAKE. OKAY IF YOU COULD
IMAGINE IT WOULD TAKE FAR MORE
TIME THAN IS ALLOWED TODAY TO
SHARE THE LOSS AND PAIN BACK
FACTORED IN THE THIRTY FOUR
YEAR. THE GENTLEMAN. WAS NOT
EASY. BUT JACKSON BALLOT
ADVOCATE FOR CHANGES IN THE
LAWS REGARDING INFORMANTS THAT
NO ONE WOULD FOLLOW IN HIS
SHOES. I AM NOT IN STRONG VOICE
AND JACK. BUT THE REASON I'M
HERE TODAY TO SHARE HIS STORY
AND JACK IS NOT. BECAUSE ON
DECEMBER TENTH OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE DAYS BEFORE JACK FOURTEENTH
MONTH HOME. WE LOST JACK
BECAUSE THE NINETEEN.
LEGISLATURE PASSES GRAND LAWS
BECAUSE OF GREAT TRAGEDIES
SUFFERED BY A SINGLE PERSON AB
SIX SEVEN NINE IS THE GRAND LAW
AND IT'S A POWERFUL ONE BUT WE
OWE IT TO JACK TO ENSURE NO
MORE GREAT TRAGEDIES OCCUR DUE
TO THE FALSEHOOD A JAILHOUSE
INFORMANT. WE THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS FRIEDMAN FOR
HER LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE
AND WE RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. BUT THE ANY MEMBERS IN THE
IN FORTY TWO OH TWO WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT. SHE NONE ANY MEMBERS
ENDED VIDEO. HELLO BILLY-
SCREEN. SEE NONE AT&T OPERATOR
COULD YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES. FOR A. B. SIX
SEVEN NINE FRIEDMAN. OKAY IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY SIX SEVEN NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN SIR SUPPORT OF
AB SIX SEVEN NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND WE HAVE ABOUT SIX IN Q.
WATER LINE NINETY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MARKELL JONES. THE COURT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
ONE FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
KATHY SURE ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT EIGHTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CANACCORD ARE NOW ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VITAL ONE
FORTY EIGHTH PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
DID NOT SEE OVERLANDERS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA. FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE CO SPONSOR
IT'S CALLED ABOUT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GREGORY FIDEL
WITH INITIATE JUSTICE STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BYE NINETY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
JASMINE HARRIS BUT THE
CALIFORNIA AND COALITION AND
SMART JUSTICE CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU NOT
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- COREY
CELLS ALONG SEAT SSA LA MORE CD
HEY. ON THE FRONT. IN
OPPOSITION SB SIX SEVEN NINE
MISTER. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS LARRY MORSE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
SIX SEVEN NINE THE BILL SEEKS
TO REPEAL THE TRUTH AND
EVIDENCE PROVISION IN ARTICLE
ONE SECTION TWENTY NINE OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION WHICH
STATES THAT EVIDENCE SHALL NOT
BE EXCLUDED IN ANY CRIMINAL
PROCEEDING THE BILL WOULD
CREATE A BLANKET PROHIBITION OF
ANY. ANY TESTIMONY BERMAN IN
CUSTODY INFORMANT NO MATTER HOW
MANY OTHERS OUTSIDE OF CUSTODY
CORROBORATED THAT TESTIMONY IT
IS NOT LIMITED TO INCENTIVIZE
TESTIMONY WE ARE UNAWARE OF A
SINGLE STATE IN THE COUNTRY
THAT IS ADOPTED SUCH A POLICY
WELL THE BILL FOCUSES ON A FEW
EXAMPLES OF CONVICTIONS THAT
WERE OVERTURNED AT LEAST IN
PART BECAUSE OF INFORMANT
TESTIMONY IT IGNORES THE FACT
THAT TESTIMONY FROM IN CUSTODY
INDIVIDUALS HAS BEEN USED TO
SOLVE SCORES I'M SERIOUS AND
VIOLENT CRIMES. UNDER THIS BILL
A PROSECUTOR WOULD BE PREVENTED
FROM USING THE TESTIMONY OF A
MISDEMEANOR DEFENDANTS IN
CUSTODY FOR SAY A D. Y. WHO
OVER HERE'S ANOTHER IN CUSTODY
INDIVIDUAL ADMIT TO A SERIES OF
MURDERS OR RAPES OR ARMED
ROBBERIES OR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
OR ANY CRIME THE TESTIMONY
WOULD BE PROHIBITED EVEN THOUGH
THE SO CALLED IN BECAUSE THE
INFORMANT VOLUNTEERED THE
INFORMATION UPON HIS RELEASE
FROM CUSTODY AND DID NOT SEEK
ANY MONETARY BENEFIT OR LEGAL
ADVANTAGE. FROM PROVIDING THE
INFORMATION AND IT IS
CORROBORATED BY NONCUSTODIAL
WITNESSES CALIFORNIA ALREADY
HAD BEEN PLACED AMONG THE
STRICTEST PROTECTION REGARDING
IN CUSTODY AND FORMER TESTIMONY
INCLUDING A REQUIREMENT THAT
SUCH TESTIMONY BE CORROBORATED
AND THAT COULD NOT BE
CORROBORATED BY ANOTHER INMATE
UNLESS THE PROSECUTION COULD
ESTABLISH THERE WAS NO.
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN ME AND MY-
FORMS ON INCOME IN. SIMONI WERE
APPROVED IN THE TWELVE. THE
SPONSOR ABOUT FOR IN EXAM OF
CASE SINCE TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
WHERE ONE THE JURY WAS
INSTRUCTED ON HOW DO YOU INFORM
ATTACHED TO MONIQUE AND TO.
THERE WAS CORROBORATED FALSE
TESTIMONY OF AN IN CUSTODY
INFORMANTS THAT RESULTED IN AN
INNOCENT PERSON BEING
CONVICTED. THE CONVICTION OF A
SINGLE PERSON FOR A CRIME HERE
SHE DIDN'T COMMIT IS TOO MANY.
BUT IN ORDER TO ASSESS THE
SCALE OF THE ALLEGED PROBLEM
THIS BILL PURPORTS TO ADDRESS
THE SPONSORS WOULD NEED TO
PROVIDE DATA THAT SHOWS HOW
MANY TIMES. INTERCITY INFORMANT
TESTIMONY PROVED TO BE RELIABLE
TESTIMONY AND HELPED CONVICT A
GUILTY PERSON. WE WOULD IMAGINE
THAT THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL
HAVE EXAMPLES OF I WOULD
DISCUSS THE MONEY IN SERIOUS
CASES. IN WHICH DNA OR LATER
EVIDENCE SHOWED EYEWITNESS
TESTIMONY TO HAVE BEEN ROCK
WILL BE NEXT BE SEEKING TO
EXCLUDE EYEWITNESS TESTIMONY.
SIMILARLY WE WOULD EXPECT THAT
THERE ARE EXAMPLES OF FALSE
CONFESSIONS THAT WERE NOT
COERCED THAT HAVE LED TO
INNOCENT PEOPLE BEING CONVICTED
AND INCARCERATED. ARE WE NEXT
GOING TO EXCLUDE CONFESSIONS
FROM BEING ENTERED INTO
EVIDENCE. AS I USED TO TELL
JURIES WHEN TRYING CASES THE
JURY SYSTEM ISN'T PERFECT
BECAUSE NO SYSTEM DEVISED BY
MORTALS COULD BE. HOWEVER IS
THE BEST SYSTEM HUMANITY HAS
EVER KNOWN AND IT IS BASED ON
RESPECT FOR THE INTELLIGENCE OF
JURORS. THAT THEY ARE ABLE TO
PROPERLY ASSESS ALL EVIDENCE
INCLUDING EVIDENCE THAT COMES
FROM LAY WITNESSES EXPERT
WITNESSES AND YES IN CUSTODY
INFORMANTS. THAT COLLECTIVE
INTELLIGENCE IS REINFORCED BY
JUDGES WHO GUIDE THEM AND
EVALUATING SUCH TESTIMONY. THE
REPEAL OF THE TRUTH AND
EVIDENCE PROVISIONS OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION
ADVOCATED BY THIS BILL. IS
UNNECESSARY. AND WE URGE A NO
VOTE. THE SUSPECT IS. THANK YOU
MISTER MORRIS. MRS ALSO. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN COREY
CELLS CELL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. AS MY
COLLEAGUE STATED CURRENT LAW
PROVIDES PLENTIFUL PROTECTIONS
FOR DEFENDANT WHEN IT COMES TO
THE USE OF INFORMANTS TESTIMONY
SIX EIGHTY SIX SEVENTY NINE
ELIMINATES THOSE SAFEGUARDS AND
SIMPLY BEAMS ALL SUCH EVIDENCE
OR TESTIMONY INADMISSIBLE.
WITHOUT REGARD TO THE SEVERITY
OF THE CRIME THE NATURE OF THE
INFORMATION FOR THE RELIABILITY
OF THE PROVIDER. THIS BILL
COULD IMPACT THE PROSECUTION OF
ANY NUMBER OF CRIMES THAT WILL
LIKELY MAKE CRIMES COMMITTED IN
PRISONS AND JAILS EVEN HARDER
TO PROSECUTE. THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION BECAUSE OF THE
HIGH BAR FOR MEASURES THAT
ATTEMPT TO EXCLUDE ANY RELEVANT
EVIDENCE FROM ANY CRIMINAL
PROCEEDING AND FOR GOOD REASON.
COURTS AND JURIES MUST BE
PERMITTED TO JUDGE WHAT MIGHT
PROVE TO BE RELEVANT
INFORMATION. WITHOUT THE
ARTIFICIAL AND ARBITRARY BRAND
CREATED BY THIS MEASURE. FOR
THOSE REASONS AND- STATED- CSSA
MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB SIX
SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ARE ANY WITNESSES IN THE-
IN THE ROOM FORTY TWO- TO IN
OPPOSITION ANY ON THE VIDEO
SCREEN IN OPPOSITION. EIGHTEEN
T. OPERATOR YOU MAY NOW GO TO
THE PHONE LINES- FOR AB SIX
SEVEN NINE. IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB SIX
SEVEN NINE TO PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN FOR OPPOSITION OF AB HERE
SIX SEVEN NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
WE CURRENTLY HAVE ONE COMMENT
IN Q. AND WHAT A LINE ONE FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BRANDON UP ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SHERIFF IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO%
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU WILL NOW
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
MISTER HOLCOMB J. R. TERM MR
LACKEY. EMPRESS POWER CAN'T
MISS FRIEDMAN THANK YOU FOR
HAVING CONCERN FOR THE
SEVENTEEN THAT ARE WRONGFULLY
CONVICTED. AND I SHARE THOSE
CONCERNS AND I THINK WE NEED TO
WORK ON WAYS TO ENSURE. JUST AS
THE ONE OF THE WITNESSES STATED
THAT LESS AND LESS OF THAT
HAPPENS. BUT WHEN I LOOK OUT ON
OUR LITTLE AUDIENCE THAT
DOESN'T EXIST HERE TODAY. IF
YOU TAKE EVERYONE OF THOSE
CHAIRS EXCEPT FOR THE LAST ROW
THAT GENTLEMAN AND PUT PEOPLE
IN THERE AND THEN FILL THIS
UNDER SECTION THAT'S HERE. WITH
ONE ROW PLUS FOUR SEATS. THAT'S
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN PEOPLE
THE WRONGFULLY CONVICTED BY
THIS PROCESS. AND PEOPLE THAT
YOU SAY HAVE BEEN CONVICTED BY
THE PROCESS AND THE PEOPLE THAT
HAVE BEEN CONVICTED BY THAT
PROCESS REPRESENT RAPISTS
pMURDERERS. ROBBERS VIOLENT
FELONS- IT RUNS THE GAMUT AND
THOSE PEOPLE. THEIR FAMILIES
WANT JUSTICE. AND THEIR
FAMILIES DESERVE JUSTICE AND TO
SAY BECAUSE THE SEVENTEEN WE
NEED TO WORK ON THEIR PROBLEMS
A LITTLE BIT MORE MAKE SURE
THEY'RE NOT UNJUSTLY. CONVICTED
AND WE'RE GOING TO SACRIFICE
THE OTHERS IT'S A LITTLE TOO
MUCH FOR ME. SO I WILL NOT BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL- I THINK
THERE ARE WAYS AND TEY'RE
BECOMING BETTER WAYS OF
ENSURING THAT WE DON'T HAVE
FALSE TESTIMONY. AND THAT THOSE-
WAYS THAT THAT ARE ARE BEING.
AND YET THE- HOW HOW WOULD I
WANT TO SAY THAT THE FACTORS
THAT ARE IN COMMON THEY'RE
CONVICTING PEOPLE THAT
SHOULDN'T BE CONVICTED ARE
BEING FLESHED OUT WHAT
TECHNOLOGY AND- AND FRANKLY
WITH COMMON SENSE- WE WILL
CONTINUE TO IMPROVE ON THAT.
BUT WE CAN'T SACRIFICE THE
OTHER 83% OF SUCCESSFUL
CONVICTIONS BECAUSE OF THAT.
THANK YOU. CAN I GET YOUR
CORRECT CAN I JUST CLARIFY
SOMETHING RUDE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT. THE SADISTIC WAS NOT
THAT OUT OF ALL OF THE TECH THE
CONVICTIONS THAT WERE OBTAINED
WITH JAIL HOUSE INFORMANTS 17%
OF THOSE ARE INACCURATE. IT'S
OUT OF ALL THE CONVICTIONS MOST
OF WHICH DON'T USE JAILHOUSE
CONFORMANCE OF ALL THE WRONGFUL
CONVICTIONS 17% OF THAT TOTAL.
EXCLUDING THE ONES THAT DIDN'T
USED JAILHOUSE INFORMANTS 70%
OF PEOPLE THAT WE KNOW WERE
WRONGFULLY CONVICTED SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE. HAD TO
YOU HAD. THE USE OF ITACCURATE
OF LYING JAILHOUSE INFORMANTS I
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT SO THAT WE
ALL UNDERSTAND THIS INTERESTED
LACKEY THREE PERCENT. IS ALSO
THE SAME CATEGORY. OKAY MR
LACKEY. YEAH I THINK YOU YOU DO
BRING UP A- A CONCERN AND I DO
BELIEVE THE NET CUSSED
INFORMANT'S TESTIMONY. SHOULD
BE USED WITH CAUTION AND
CLEARLY INCENTIVIZE TESTIMONY
NOT USED. HOWEVER I THINK THE
BAND IS TOO STRONG. AND I THINK.
FOR EXAMPLE I THINK THAT- FLAT
BAND. OF THIS KIND OF EVIDENCE
WILL MAKE INVESTIGATION IN
PRISON CRIMES NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE
SO I THINK THAT THAT'S- THAT'S
MY CONCERN AND I DO THINK YOU
HAVE A STRONG ISSUE HERE THE
DESERVES. SIGNIFICANT ATTENTION
I JUST DON'T THINK THIS QUITE I
THINK THIS A LITTLE TOO HEAVY.
AND SO I WON'T BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT IT BUT I DO SUPPORT
YOUR EFFORTS AND THE
PERSPECTIVE OF TAKING A LOOK AT
IT BECAUSE OF THE TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU SPARKING. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND- I WANT TO
START BY THINKING THE AUTHOR
FOR THIS WORK I LIKE YOUR
WITNESSES REPRESENTED A MAN ON
DEATH ROW WHO WAS PUT THERE FOR
TEN YEARS- WRONGFULLY CONVICTED
USING A JAILHOUSE INFORMANT.
AND HE LOST TEN YEARS OF HIS
LIFE HE WASN'T OUT OF JAIL WHEN
HIS GRANDDAUGHTER WAS BORN HE
WAS IN ISOLATION ON DEATH ROW
FOR THOSE YEARS WHICH YOU CAN
ONLY IMAGINE WHAT HAPPENED HIS
MENTAL STATE. AND HE WAS LUCKY
ENOUGH TO END UP WITH. A
PRIVATE INVESTIGATOR WHO IS
WILLING TO TAKE ON HIS CASE PRO
BONO. AND AS A RESULT HE ENDED
UP WITH LAWYERS THE COULD TAKE
ON HIS CASE MYSELF AND MY TEAM.
AND WE GOT HIM OUT. THAT WAS
TEN YEARS LATER YOU HEARD
ABOUT. THE GENTLEMAN THIS
LAWYER REPRESENTED THIRTY SEVEN
YEARS LATER. SO I ALSO WANT TO
MAKE CLEAR THAT WE DON'T KNOW
ALL THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
WRONGFULLY CONVICTED. THE
NUMBER IS THAT MISS FRIEDMAN IS
DISCUSSING ARE THE ONES THAT WE
HAVE FOUGHT HARD TO GET
RELEASED TO THERE ARE MANY MORE
OF THEM I BELIEVE IN JAIL THAN
THOSE THAT WE TALK ABOUT AND
KNOW ABOUT. AND. TO HAVE. LIVED
AND WORKED IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND SEE THE
FAILURE OF OUR SYSTEM. AND YES
SOMETIMES IT WORKS AND WHEN IT
WORKS IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT AND
PEOPLE DESERVE JUSTICE AND
SOMETIMES IT FAILS PEOPLE AND
IT FAILED THE VICTIMS IN THE
CASE THAT I WORKED ON AS WELL.
BECAUSE YEARS LATER WE WERE
LETTING A MAN WHO DIDN'T COMMIT
THAT CRIME AND THEY DIDN'T GET
JUSTICE BECAUSE THE PERSON
ACTUALLY DID KILL THOSE FAMILY
MEMBERS. HAD WALKED THE STREETS
ALL THOSE YEARS AND SO WE'RE
THEIR WRONGFUL CONVICTIONS I
BELIEVE THE VICTIMS HAVE BEEN
FILLED AS WELL I DON'T BELIEVE
IT IS JUST THE PERSON WHO IS IN
JAIL EVERYBODY HAS BEEN FELT IN
THAT MOMENT BECAUSE I CRIME
HAPPENED. AND SO WHAT WE NEED
TO DO IS MAKE SURE THAT THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM WORKS. AND IT
WORKS FOR EVERYBODY. THAT WE
ARE NOT INCARCERATING SOMEONE
FOR ONE DAY FOR A CRIME THEY
DIDN'T COMMIT. WE HAVE TAKEN
THEIR FREEDOM AWAY AND WE NEED
TO TAKE THAT INCREDIBLY
INCREDIBLY SERIOUSLY. WHICH IS
WHY IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM WE GIVE EXTRA PROTECTION
THAT'S WHY WE PROVIDE COUNSEL
PRO BONO. RIGHT THROUGH PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ARE COMING JUSTICE
SYSTEM. SOMETHING WE DON'T DO
IN CIVIL SYSTEM. BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE TAKING SOMEONE'S
FREEDOM AWAY IS SO IMPORTANT
THAT THEY DESERVE EVERY
POSSIBLE PROTECTION. AND THIS
IS GETTING A PROBLEM THAT IS
VERY REAL AND I'VE SEEN
FIRSTHAND. AND I THINK THAT I
REALLY WANT TO COMMEND THE
AUTHOR AND THOSE THAT ARE
BRINGING THIS WORD FOR THIS
VERY IMPORTANT CONVERSATION BUT
I WANT TO ADDRESSING US
INCENTIVES ACTUALLY NOT
ACCURATE. SO THE BILL. DEFINES
IN CUSTODY IN FORMAT AS SOMEONE
OTHER THAN A CODEFENDANT AND
ACCOMPLICE A CO CONSPIRATOR OR
PERCIPIENT WITNESS. SO FOR JAIL
FOR CRIMES COMMITTED IN JAIL.
SOMEBODY WAS IN CUSTODY WOULD
BE ONE OF THOSE THINGS. MAYBE
THEY WITNESSED IT. MAYBE
THEY'RE A CO CONSPIRATOR AND
THEY WOULD BE ALLOWED TO
TESTIFY UNDER THIS BILL. SO
THAT IS ACTUALLY NOT I JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT INACCURACY
BECAUSE THAT IS NOT WHAT THIS
BILL DOES AND I WAS ACTUALLY
WHEN I FIRST HEARD ABOUT THE
BILL. SOMETHING I LOOKED INTO.
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S A- EVEN
IF. THAT'S A CRIME WAS
COMMITTED ONE OF THE CO
CONSPIRATORS GOES TO JAIL. AND
IS NOW IN CUSTODY THAT PERSON
SHOULD BE ABLE TO TESTIFY. AND
YOUR BILL ALLOWS THAT AND I
THINK THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
AN IMPORTANT EXCEPTION SO.
DESPITE WHAT THE OPPOSITION IS
SAID THIS IS NOT A COMPLETE
BAN. IT IS A BAN ON THOSE THAT
ARE USING THIS IN CUSTODY
INFORMANT TO. GET THE
PRIVILEGES THAT THEY GET BY
DOING IT AND THAT IS. I ALSO
WANT TO POINT OUT IMPORTANT
THING ABOUT THIS BILL. WHICH IS
NOTHING STOPS IN IN CUSTODY
INDIVIDUAL FROM COMING FORWARD.
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT OR TO
ANYBODY AND SAYING. I HEARD
THIS GUY SAY HE COMMITTED THIS
CRIME. AND HELPING SOLVE THAT
CRIME. AND THEN HAVING LAW
ENFORCEMENT GO OUT SOLVE THAT
CRIME GET THE CORROBORATING
EVIDENCE. AND PUT ON A CASE AND
PUT THAT PERSON IN JAIL. THANK
HAS TO BE INFORMED IS IMPORTANT
THEY NO LONGER ARE ADMISSIBLE
IN A COURT OF LAW. BUT THEY
SERVED AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN
SOLVING THAT CRIME THAT IS
STILL ABSOLUTELY ALLOWABLE
UNDER THIS IS. ABOUT THE
ADMISSIBILITY OF THE EVIDENCE
WHICH IS DIFFERENT. THAN THEIR
ROLE IN SOLVING THE CRIME AND I
THINK BOTH OF THOSE POINTS ARE
REALLY CRITICAL AND WHY THIS
BILL IS WELL CRAFTED IN WHITE
GETS IT EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE
ASKING WHICH IS. WHAT WE ARE
PUTTING FORWARD IN A COURT OF
LAW TO PUT SOMEONE IN JAIL.
SHOULD BE RELIABLE TESTIMONY.
AND THEY'RE SUCH SERIOUS
QUESTIONS ABOUT THEIR
RELIABILITY THIS TESTIMONY DO
WE NEED TO LOOK HARD AT
OURSELVES AND SAY IS THIS
APPROPRIATE. I THINK THAT'S THE
QUESTION BEING ASKED AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING IT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. I JUST WANNA
MAKE A ONE CLARIFYING. ISSUES
STATED THAT. THESE PRISON. OF
THAT HAPPENED. CLEARLY IN THE
PRESENCE OF OTHER- IT BECAUSE
THE PEOPLE. THEY COULD TESTIFY
WHAT THEY SEE BUT NOT WHAT THEY
HEAR. THAT'S MY CLARITY. I
GUESS WE SHOULD ASK FOR ONE OF
THE ATTORNEYS TO CLARIFY
BECAUSE I THINK IF THEY HEAR IT
AS A WITNESS IF I SEE A CRIME
AND- OR A SENSE TO. THE IN
JAIL. I'M GOING TO SHOOT YOU AN
EYE WITNESS THAT I CAN TESTIFY
THAT BECAUSE THAT DOESN'T MAKE
ME INFORMED NOW BY HERE AFTER
THE FACT. FOR MY BUDDY. THAT
SOMEONE ELSE DID IT THEN I
CAN'T TEST FOR THAT BUT I THINK
I JUST HEARD WHAT I HEARD TO AS
A WITNESS SHOW. UP MISTREATMENT
THAT IS NOT. UNDER WE USE THE
DEFINITION. AS DEFINED IN LAW I
AM. MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF OUR TOWN IS
CORRECT BUT I'M HAPPY TO HELP
ONE OF OUR- LAWYERS ARE.
LAWYERS WITNESSES- WHO'S AN
EXPERT IN THIS ARE. SURE TO GET
THERE. THEY CAN MAKE IT. VERY
STILL ON A COULD MAKE A QUICK.
CLARIFICATION OTHERWISE. IF WE
IF WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A-
LAWYER DEBATE WILL BE HERE TILL.
THE END OF TIME OF. IT WILL AS
THOUGH FROM INNOCENCE AGAIN
ACROSS NOT TO BY AN LAWYER LEAD
BY- WE DELAY. TO DEFINE
LANGUAGE INCOME AND FOR IS ON
OF EXIT LAW IN POK SECTION
ELEVEN SEVEN EIGHT. AND ELEVEN
ELEVEN POINT FIVE WHICH HAD
BEEN REST REFERENCED BY SEVERAL
OF THEM THE OPPOSITION THAT ARE
EXISTING LAW WE ARE NOT
CHANGING THE DEFINITION OF THE
DEPARTMENT FOR THAT LOOK AT THE-
J. THIS WICKS YOU HAD A
QUESTION. I'LL KEEP IT VERY
BRIEF I JUST WANT TO COMMEND
THE AUTHOR FOR THE BILL I WOULD
LOVE TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
LOOKING FOR SUPPORTING IT.
THANK YOU. AND I'M OF THE BILL.
RIGHT OKAY WE HAVE A SECOND
MISSILE MISTER CLARK SO. FAR
DAVID. THERE ARE HUNDREDS
REASONS OKAY AND WHAT ISN'T
SIGN. SORRY BEN FRANKLIN SAID
IT IS BETTER ONE GUILTY PERSON
SHOULD GAME THAN ONE INNOCENT
PERSON SHOULD SUFFER. I REALLY
DON'T. THAT IT'S GOING TO BE A
HUNDRED TO ONE BUT I'D SUPPORT
THAT AND- I'D ALSO LIKE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR CLARK. DO WE HAVE
ANYONE ELSE WITH ANY COMMENT.
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU I WOULD
LIKE TO ADDRESS A FEW OF THE
COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
IF YOU DON'T MIND MISTER CHAIR
SURE ONE OF THE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION COMPARED THIS
WITNESS TO I. TO I. WITNESS
TESTIMONY BEING AN ACCURATE NOW
WILL BE LEARNING MORE MORE
ABOUT HOW I WITNESS TESTIMONY
CAN BE INACCURATE BUT I THINK
THERE'S A FUNDAMENTAL
DIFFERENCE OF SOMEBODY WHO
MAKES A MISTAKE. FOR A VARIETY
OF REASONS AND SOMEBODY WHO HAS
A BUILT IN A BIAS ARE AN
INCENTIVE TO LIE OR TO PRETEND
THEY HAVE INFORMATION THAT THEY
DON'T AND I THINK WE HAVE TO
REMEMBER THAT WITH THIS AND
THAT EVEN THOUGH WE'VE KNOWN
ABOUT THESE PROBLEMS FOR MANY
MANY YEARS WE KEEP SEEING THESE
EGREGIOUS EXAMPLES OVER AND
OVER AGAIN AND AS- MY-
COLLEAGUES- FROM SANTA CLARA.
OF SOMEWHERE IN SOMEONE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF OUR QUE HAN
SAID AND IT WAS I MEAN I WISH
SHE HAD GIVEN THE TESTIMONY SHE
SPOKE SO POWERFULLY IN SO WELL
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS JUST
THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG I AND I
REALLY BELIEVE THAT IF WE HAD A
TEST THAT WAS WE WERE RELYING
ON TO CONVICT PEOPLE THAT HAD A
17% ACCURACY WE WOULD JUST NOT
ALLOWED IN THE COURTROOM- I
WILL SAY THAT I AM GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION I THINK THAT YOU
KNOW IF THERE ARE VALID
CONCERNS WE WANT TO ADDRESS
THEM. AND WE ARE VERY OPEN WE
WE'VE HAD PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH SOME OF THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ACROSS
THE STATE SOME OF THEM HAVE
COME TO US AND SAID THIS IS A
PROBLEM WOULD LIKE BETTER
PARAMETERS IF THEY COME TO US
AND GIVE US TWO EXAMPLES WHERE
THEY REALLY NEED SOMETHING AS A
TOOL AND THEY FEEL THAT THEY
CAN REALLY SHOW THAT- THEY CAN
HAVE SAFEGUARDS WE ARE OPEN TO
THAT CONVERSATION WE KNOW THAT
THIS IS GOING TO BE A DIFFICULT
VOTE ON THE FLOOR WE WANT TO
MAKE THIS PROTECTIVE BUT ALSO
TO NOT TAKE AWAY TOOLS. THAT
CAN BE USED WELL SO WE ARE OPEN
TO HAVING THAT CONVERSATION
OPEN TO STRENGTHENING THE
LANGUAGE AROUND PEOPLE WHO
WITNESS CRIMES WITHIN THE
PRISON SETTING IF THAT'S A
CONCERN THAT IT TO A BIGGER AS
WE CAN I'M SURE ADD LANGUAGE
ABOUT THAT AS WELL SO THIS IS
GOING TO BE A WORK IN PROGRESS
I WOULD- YOU KNOW I APPRECIATE
THE SUPPORT I HOPE WE CAN
CONTINUE MOVING THIS BILL
FORWARD AND HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION THE THING THAT IS
NOT ACCEPTABLE TO ME IS TO NOT.
HAVE THIS MOVE- YOU KNOW HERE
OR OFF THE FOR THE LEGISLATURE
THERE ARE TOO MANY PEOPLE DOING
HARD TIME BECAUSE OF WITNESSES
THAT WE KNOW ARE UNRELIABLE
WITNESSES THAT WE KNOW ARE
LIARS AND WE ALLOW THIS TO
HAPPEN FOR TOO LONG NOT TO
MENTION THE CONSTITUTIONALITY
ISSUES OF NOT GIVING PEOPLE
MIRANDA WARNINGS WHEN CERTAIN
TYPES OF INFORMANTS ARE USED
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU FOR
BEING USED FOR LIKE I REMEMBER
WHEN THE INCIDENT HAPPENED
ORANGE COUNTY AND I WAS
PREPARED TO BRING GATE A BILL
VERY SIMILAR TO THIS SITE- TO
PERKINS. PART WAS THE ONE THAT
MADE IT. EVEN DIFFICULT FOR ME-
TO MOVE FORWARD SO I THINK
YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE MAKING A
VALIANT EFFORT TO THREAD THE
NEEDLE. BECAUSE I TO JUST LIKE
YOU. DO NOT WANT TO HAMPER LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S. INABILITY TO.
GET PEOPLE WHO'VE COMMITTED
CRIMES AND- TO MAKE SURE THEY-
FIGURE PROSECUTORS SO I COMMEND
YOU AND I HOPE THAT. LAW
ENFORCEMENT TAKE YOU UP ON
YOUR- YOUR OFFER. TO BUT I'M
USED TO WORK THREAD THE NEEDLE
SO THAT THEY CAN GET THEIR WORK
DONE BUT ALSO MAKE SURE. THAT
INDIVIDUALS WHO USE THIS. IN
THE WRONG WAY. WE CAN MAKE SURE
THEY DON'T USE THIS AS A HAMMER
AGAINST ANYONE SO. I WOULD JUST
RECOMMEND AND I BOTH. I'M
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTY NINE BY SOME
MEMBER FRIEDMAN THE MISSION IS
TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER. CHEN SO
YOUR IRAQI YES OR GOOD ISSUED
JUST TOO STRONGNOPE LACKEY NO
BARRICADE CAN. BARRICADE HAD
AYE COURT. COURT FIGHTS
SANTIAGO C. R. TO C. R. TURNOUT
WICKS WICKS I LI LI I. THANK
YOU VERY JUST.
AND THE EFFORTS
OF FIRING. ANY EFFORTS OF
CLARITY AND ESPECIALLY SINCE
IT'S MY BILL- I MEANT TO SAY A.
B. TWO FIVE FOUR JONES SAWYER
IS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR AND
I BELIEVE PEOPLE HEARD ME SAY
TWO FIVE TWO. SO THAT IS A
CORRECTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. MR GABRIEL I DIDN'T
SEE YOU THERE- I MISSED YOU
HAVE A BEAUTIFUL ORANGE TIE. HE.
WHEN EVER YOU READY YOU CAN
BEGIN YEAH THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE HEARING
YOUR ORANGE TIE FOR GUN
VIOLENCE PREVENTION AT THE-
WELCOME. SUPPORT I WANT TO
THANK YOU AND THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND THE STAFF
FOR. THEIR THOUGHTFUL FEEDBACK
ON THE BILL. AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW GUN VIOLENCE PREVENTION
HAS BEEN A TOP PART OF MINE
SINCE I CAME TO THE LEGISLATURE
I'VE BEEN REALLY PRIVILEGE TO
WORK WITH. A NUMBER OF FOLKS ON
THIS COMMITTEE HAVE BEEN REAL
LEADERS IN THAT SPACE. AND THAT
TODAY'S BILL DEALS WITH- AN
ELEMENT OF GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION CALLED MICRO
STAMPING. THIS IS BASICALLY A
SIMPLE RELIABLE. GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION AND CRIME SOLVING
TOOL. THAT IMPRINTS. AS
MICROSCOPIC CHARACTERS ON A
CARTRIDGE CASING THINK OF IT AS
A LICENSE PLATE FOR A BONE. MY
CRISTINA THING IS BEEN THE LAW
IN CALIFORNIA SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN. UNSAFE HANDGUN
ACT REQUIRES NEW SEMI AUTOMATIC
HANDGUNS INCORPORATE
MICROCHIPPING TECHNOLOGY.
SUPPORTING THE GUN INDUSTRY HAS
EFFECTIVELY BOYCOTTED THE LAW.
BY BY REFUSING TO DEVELOP NEW
HANDGUN MODELS FOR SALE
CALIFORNIA. AND SO THIS BILL
SEEKS TO CHANGE THE EQUATION BY
REQUIRING FIREARMS USED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT. TO BE EQUIPPED
WITH MICROSCOPIC TECHNOLOGY NOW
ALLOWS CALIFORNIA TO LEAD WITH
OUR VALUES IN A WAY. THAT HAS
BROUGHT PUBLIC BENEFITS. AND AS
I SEE THERE ARE THREE BENEFITS
TO THIS APPROACH. THE FIRST IS
THAT WE'RE GONNA CREATE NEW
MARKETS FOR MY CRISTINA GUNS WE
HAVE EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND.
ACTIVE LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
IN CALIFORNIA. COMPANIES GOING
TO BE ABLE TO WANNA BE ABLE TO
SELL INTO THAT MARKET. IS WE'RE
GONNA ABLE TO USE. MARKET POWER
TO DRIVE GOOD POLICY. BUT IS
EVER GOING TO SAY. ARE GOING
HELP LAUNCH. SO VIOLENT.
MICROGAMING ALLOWS POLICE TO
IDENTIFY A SHOOTER WITHOUT EVER
PHYSICALLY RECOVERING A GUN.
CURRENTLY 70% OF AGGRAVATED
ASSAULT WITH A- FIREARM GO
UNSOLD. AND SO THIS IS GOING TO
HELP LAW ENFORCEMENT TO SOLVE
NONFATAL SHOOTINGS. INTERRUPT
CYCLES OF VIOLENCE THAT WE TALK
ABOUT. AND IT'S GOING TO HELP
LAW ENFORCEMENT IDENTIFY AND
CRACK DOWN ON FIREARM
TRAFFICKING. AND THE THIRD IS
IT'S GOING TO CREATE MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
IN SITUATIONS WHERE THERE HAS
BEEN AN OFFICER INVOLVED
SHOOTING. IN A WAY THAT IS
GOING TO HELP BUILD COMMUNITY
TRUST. THIS IS TECHNOLOGY THAT
IS UNOBTRUSIVE OBJECTIVES AND
IMPORTANTLY NOT PRONE TO RACIAL
BIAS. AND CONSISTENT WITH OUR
EFFORTS TO ACHIEVE MEANINGFUL
POLICE REFORM. I WANT TO
PREEMPTIVELY ADDRESS SOME OF
THE- OBJECTIONS TO THE BILL-
YOU KNOW QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHETHER THIS TECHNOLOGY IS
RELIABLE. AND EXPENSIVE I JUST
WANT TO NOTE THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAS CERTIFIED THAT THIS
TECHNOLOGY WORKS. THAT THE
INDUSTRY HAS BEEN ADMITTED IN
COURT ADMITTED IN LITIGATION
THAT THEY ARE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT
MICROSCOPIC TECHNOLOGIES. I
KNOW THAT WE'RE NOT IN A FISCAL
COMMITTEE BUT IT BEARS ON. THE
QUESTION OF BURDEN THE
ESTIMATED COST FOR MICROSCOPIC
A FIREARM THE LOWEST ESTIMATE
I'VE HEARD IS FIFTY CENTS PER
FIREARMS. THE HIGHEST AS MY
PART IS SIX DOLLARS PER PHONE.
SO WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE
BURDEN THAT WE'RE GONNA POST ON
HERE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
TOTAL TOTAL COST. OF SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN FORTY FIVE THOUSAND. AT
THE LOW END 255-002-0000 AT THE
HIGH END AND THAT'S TO DO
EVERYONE THAT'S TO DO A WEAPON
FOR EVERY SINGLE OFFICE
CERTAIN. SHOULD THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SENATE SAID WERE
EAGER TAKING TO OUR TO. WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT OF. WE ARE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE FULL AN
ROBUST CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM.
BUT THEY HAVE BEEN KEY PARTNERS
THE LEGISLATURE IN ADVANCING
PRIOR PREVIOUS MICROSCOPIC
EFFORTS. AND WE'RE PROUD THAT
OUR BILL SUPPORTED BY. A BROAD
COALITION OF GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION GROUPS INCLUDING THE
BRADY CAMPAIGN. MARCH FOR OUR
LIVES AND WOMEN AGAINST GUN
VIOLENCE. WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY ARE STEVEN ABRAMS FOR
KEEPING HIM ENOUGH. AND JOSH
FOR WITH FROM THE COALITION FOR
GUN TO STOP GUN VIOLENCE THANK
YOU AND WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SIR IN GENERAL AND WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. AGAIN. HI MY NAME
IS STEPHANIE BROWN AND I'M A
HIGH SCHOOL SENIOR FROM SAN
DIEGO AND I'M THE NATIONAL
GRASSROOTS AND PROGRAM LEAD. A
TEAM MADE UP WHICH IS THE U. S.
BRANCH OF BRADY. I THINK
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS GABRIEL AND
MANY PROVIDING THE OPPORTUNITY.
FOR A YOUNG PERSON LIKE MYSELF
TO REVISED TESTIMONY. ON THIS
VERY IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. MICROCHIPPING IS A
LONG CALIFORNIA- IT IS LONG
CALIFORNIA IN THE TECHNOLOGY
WILL REVOLUTIONIZE MON
PORTSMOUTH ABILITY TO IDENTIFY
SHOOTERS. AND GUN TRAFFICKERS
APPREHEND THEM BEFORE THEY DO
MORE. ARMS AND HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE. NOW THE DENTIST
HAS A FIVE PUT CARD WITH THE BY
WITH. TO NEW HANG THEM FOR SO
HELP. AND TWO THAT THEY MY-
DOWNTURN AVAILABLE TOP.
MICROCHIPPING WOULD FAIL BUT
NOT THE SYSTEM THE BETTER FOR
TOO LONG PORT. UNABLE TO FALL
TO BUY FIRE. I NEED A MOTHER
EVERY TO TELL ME HOW THEY HOPE
THAT MILITARY HAVE TO ENTER.
KNOWING THEIR CHILD KILLERS OUT
THERE OR KNOWING THER FAMILY
WILL NEVER RECEIVE JUSTICE. BY
MANDATING THE MONTFORT AND DOES
HAVE MAKERS AND THE TECHNOLOGY.
AB EIGHT THAT'LL TAKE FOR
CREATE A LAN PORT ENTRANCE
FANCY ANSWER CALIFORNIA'S
OFFICERS ALSO MEET ON FIRE IN
THE BATHROOM AND SET THE STAGE.
FOR WIDESPREAD AND MICROSCOPIC.
I WANTED MORE THAN EVER THIS
BILL WILL ACCOUNTABILITY IN
TRANSPARENCY AND SHALL WE HAVE
TIMELY WAS. IN ANY POLICE BOB
AND SHOOTING. THERE'S NO. WHY
THOSE WHO TRIED TO PROTECT THAT
WOULD BE EXAMPLE TECHNOLOGIES
WILL ONLY HELP MAKE OUR
COMMUNITY SAFER. AND
IMPORTANTLY POINTS CARE
THEMBEKA STAND GUNS ARE
CONTINUES FOR SELLING. IN THE
WHOLE WIDE BY PROVIDING
DENTISTRY WITH A STRONGER
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES. THIS BILL
ALLOWED ENFORCEMENT WE ONLY BE
ON BY. IT ISSUE WHERE NOT LOOK
AT THOSE UPHOLD LAW FOR EXAMPLE
FM. THANK YOU PROPER THING
UNDER THAT THE MARKET TECHNO
WHY ONE POINT FOUR ONE FOURTH
NOT BE EXEMPT. THE LEGALLY FINE
HOW THE- CONTRIBUTE CAN THANK.
AND MAKING OUR SAFER I'M A
PROUD CALIFORNIA IN THE HOPE
FOR THE WE WILL MAINLY BE. IN
DOWN BALLOT CONVENTION AND
INTENSE CAN'T. IN ACCOUNT IMPAR.
THE BILL. BOTH IF I URGE YOU TO
FOR THE FELT. THANK NEXT. MY IS
JOSH FOR WHAT I'M THE GUY
DIRECT OF THE COAL TO STOP GUN
VIOLENCE THANK YOU TO BE
COMMITTEE IN THE CHARM FLOODING
PACKED UP TODAY I WANT TO GO
FROM PRO THIRTY YEARS OR MORE
ON MY PERCENT CALIFORNIA THE
TWO THOUSAND FIVE. I RECENTLY
REVIEWED THE STATE OF
MICROSEISMIC TECHNOLOGY FOR
PORTO'S PUBLISHING FEBRUARY
ENTITLED BY KRISTIN BEING
COLLEGE HELPS ALL GUN CRIMES
IDENTIFIED GUN TRAFFICKING
NETWORKS REDUCE GUN VIOLENCE
I'M HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT. AB
EIGHT SEVEN FAX. THE BILL
REQUIRES ITS OR NOT PISTOL ARE
PERCHED USE BY LAW AFTER JULY
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY THREE
BECAUSE MY PERCENT THE
TECHNOLOGY. THAT WILL INCREASE
LAW ENFORCEMENT ACCOUNTABILITY
BY ENSURING THAT WE HAVE TIMELY
RESULTS IN ANY OFFICER INVOLVED
SHOOTINGS THE BILL ALSO GIVES
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THE
CHANCE TO LEAD THE STATE. I'D
SAY FOR FARMS TECHNOLOGY. MY
PERSPECTIVE LIKE A LICENSE
PLATE PER CARTRIDGE TASTES THE
CREATING EIGHT DIGIT CODE ON
THE BACK OF EVERY EXPAND THE
CARTRIDGE CASE. WILL BARNES ARE
MANUFACTURED TOOL MARKS ARE
LEFT ON THE FARM AND IN OTHER
LOCATIONS ON THE FIREARM. WITH
A GUN IS FIRED THE ONLY PENCIL
TOOL MARKS IN GRADE THE BACK OF
A CARTRIDGE. UNINTENTIONAL
MARKS OR FARMS EXAMINERS REVIEW
WHEN TRYING TO MATCH A
CARTRIDGE TO A GUN. ALL MY
CRYSTAL BINGO- THE TAKE THOSE
SAME FORCES ORGANIZED IN A WAY
THEY CREATE INTENTIONAL. THE
DISCHARGE THE CARTRIDGE
MATTRESS MICROSECOND HELPS
IDENTIFY ILLEGAL TRAFFICKING
CHANNELS IT'S ALL CROXALL
CRIMES. THESE MARKS ARE HIGHLY
ACCURATE WITH CURRENT
TECHNOLOGY ALLOWING EIGHT
CHARACTERS COULD BE THAT
GREATER THAN 97% OF THE CAUGHT.
THE GUN CAN PRODUCE STABLE
MARKS WITHOUT THE THOUSANDS OF
BROWN'S IT WILL NOT INCREASE.
THE CHANCES OF THE FIREARM ON
HEALTH. THE TECHNOLOGY
CERTIFIED BY THIS ON A
COMPARABLE AND INCOME. ANY
POWER RESEARCH. IT COMMERCIALLY
AVAIL TO BOTH MANAGE. AND MAJOR
JOBS. THE TECHNOLOGY I CAN IS
ECONOMIC COSTING BETWEEN SO AND
FIVE DOLLAR PER GUY. FINALLY
THIS IS GLAZER MARKING THE SAME
TECH THE USED IN MANY OTHER
FIELDS AND WHILE MAY IT'S BEACH.
IN REALITY IT IS CALM AND THE
IT DOES APPLICATIONS THE TIME
FOR MY PERCENT IS NOW THANK YOU.
THANK YOU EITHER IN OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE IN THE-
HEARING ROOM FORTY TWO- TO
ANYONE ON THE VIDEO. SCREEN
AND- EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR YOU
NOW GO TO THE- TO THE TELEPHONE.
THOSE ARE IN SUPPORT. AB. EIGHT
SEVEN SIX. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS EIGHT I'M SORRY IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPORT OF AB
EIGHT SEVEN SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN FOR SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
SEVEN SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT TEN IN Q.
FIRST FORWARD TO LINE ONE SIX
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JIM WEINBERG
ON BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT SEVEN SIX THANK YOU.
YOU'RE RIGHT ONE SIXTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
REBEKAH MARKET REPRESENT HOPE
BRADY CAMPAIGN AND STRONG PART
OF EIGHT SEVEN THANK. THANK YOU
OF MINE FIFTY FOUR PER GO AHEAD.
I'M SORRY WHAT WHAT. ONE ONE
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MACKLER
ADVANCEMENT VISORS ON BEHALF OF
MARCH FOR OUR LIVES IN SUPPORT.
ONE ONE FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE ONE FIVE EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WILL MOVE ON
TO LINE ONE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WELL TRY NINE ONE
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ARMENIANS UNDERSTANDING FOR THE
BRADY CAMPAIGN AND I MOVED UP
ORDER FOR THE FAITH IN THE-
YEAH. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONCE
ONE PLEASE AHEAD. HI THERE THIS
IS STARTING MONDAY OF QUE- IN
IN EXCEPT OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU OF MINE FIFTY NINE CALL.
NUMBER TEN BRADY CAMP. INTO
SUPPORT FOR A BI EIGHT SEVENTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
ONE THIRTY TWO GO AHEAD. MERI
LEE BLUE BRAID CAN'T INSTEAD OF.
EIGHT SIX. THANK YOU RYAN ONE
FIFTH FIVE PLEASE AHEAD- JONAH
BERMAN ON BEHALF OF HE INC THE
OF THE P. SEVENTY. THANK YOU I
HAVE ONE MORE. COMMENT TO Q. IT
JUST BE A MORE SURE THAT LINE.
FOR WHAT. YOUR. ALL RIGHT ARE.
TIME THANK YOU. I HEAR.
STOCKTON AND BACKGROUNDS AT ALL.
HERE TO MAKE SURE OF IT ALL THE
FINAL ARE ARE BUT NOT ANY.
ANYONE IS UP. I HAVE SO ALONG.
FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION. YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CORY CELLS
L. ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION. TO
EIGHTY EIGHT SEVENTY SIX THIS
BILL INDEPENDENT OF THE POLICY
IT SEEKS TO ACHIEVE WILL RESULT
IN COSTLY AND BURDENSOME
MANDATES TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AND INCLUDES NO
FUNDING. MANDATE APPLIES TO ALL
AGENCIES WHEN THEY ACQUIRE NEW
HANDGUNS IRRESPECTIVE OF
WHETHER THE AGENCY IS BUYING
MANY HANDGUNS OR ONLY A FEW
WHETHER HANDGUNS HAD RECENTLY
BEEN REPLACED. OR HAVE BEEN IN
SERVICE FOR SOME TIME. THE BILL
ALSO IGNORES THE REALITY THAT
THE PERFORMANCE OF THE FIREARM
IS NOT ONLY CRUCIAL TO THE
AGENCY. BUT DIFFERENT
PERFORMANCE CHARACTERISTICS MAY
BE FAVORED BY SOME AGENCIES
OVER OTHERS. THIS IS IMPORTANT
WHEN CONSIDERING WHETHER
SUFFICIENT CHOICE WILL EXIST IN
THE MARKET BY THE TIME THE BILL
TAKES EFFECT. EVEN IF THERE ARE
THIS UNFUNDED OBLIGATION WILL
CREATE UNNECESSARY OR
UNNECESSARILY CREATE BECAUSE-
THAT WILL BE SOLD BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. WIRING
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO DO SOMETHING
SHOULD NOT BE USED AS AN
ATTEMPT TO DRIVE MARKETS FOR
INDUSTRIES. RESPECTFULLY FOR
THE REASONS STATED CSSA MUST
OPPOSE AB EIGHT SEVEN SIX WE
CONTINUE TO HOPE TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR ON THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE THERE.
ANYONE IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE ANYONE
ON THE VIDEO SCREEN. CNN
OPERATING YOU MAY OPEN UP THE
LINE FOR AB EIGHT SEVEN SIX
GABRIEL AN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF AB
EIGHT SEVEN SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN FOR OPPOSITION OF
EIGHTY EIGHT SEVEN SIX TO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
TWO COMMENTS THANK YOU IT'LL
JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR THE
FIRST COMMENT. AND ONE SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS ANTHONY MENDOZA FROM
FREMONT CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT ONE SIXTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE ONE SIX NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU NUMBER
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND QUESTIONS MISTER
CORK. SO FIRST I'D LIKE TO TALK
ABOUT A REVOLVERS AND PISTOLS.
SO JUST I ONLY FIGURED THIS OUT
BECAUSE I HAD TO BRIBE VOTE ON
THIS BILL I'M NOT VERY FAMILIAR
WITH GUNS BUT- A PISTOL IS
OFTEN REFERRED TO A SEMI
AUTOMATIC IT HAS A MAGAZINE YOU
CAN PULL AND- PUSH AND YOU CAN
GET A LOT OF SHOTS OFF. A
REVOLVER HAS A CHAMBER THAT
REVOLVES AND HAS. FIVE SIX
SOMETIMES SEVEN SHOTS. WHY ARE
YOU NOT- LOOKING AT ME TO- ALSO-
REQUIRE- REVOLVERS- TO- BE IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE STAMPING
AND HOW MANY DO YOU NOTICE LAW
ENFORCEMENT USE ONE OR THE
OTHER. IF YOU COULD ANSWER
THOSE QUESTIONS YEAH AND ALL
ALL ASK MY ONE OF MY WITNESSES
TRANSFORMATIVE HE WANTS TO JUMP
IN HERE BUT REVOLVERS HAVE BEEN
EXEMPT FROM THE- UNSAFE CAN'T
ACT WE'RE JUST FOLLOWING WHAT'S
CURRENTLY. IN THE LAWS WERE
UPDATED TO MY KNOWLEDGE. VERY
FEW OF OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS ARE USING REVOLVERS
BUT NOW I'M OFF WINDOWS TO GET
ANYTHING HE WANTS TO ADD. I
WOULD THIS IS JOSH FOR WHAT I
WOULD ALSO ADD THAT WILL BE. TO
DON'T- DON'T THROW OUT SHALL.
SO WHEN YOU FIRE SOME. PISTOL
THEY JACK SHELKE IN- BUT TO THE
STATE WILL FALL THOSE WITH THEM
IN THE CHOI. OF CHU BURKE THE
TO BE DON'T HAVE- MUCH BECAUSE-
JUST. RAW THE CRIMES. I'M SORRY
THAT'S OUR- UP ON AUTOMATIC
PISTOL THE- WITH THE FACT- IS.
SPONSORED NINETY THAT- WILL.
ARE THESE RALLY CALL CARD BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT. GUN
MANUFACTURERS DON'T WANT TO
COMPLY WITH THIS OBLIGATION AND
AS FAR AS I CAN TELL IT'S MORE
IDEOLOGICAL THAN ANYTHING ELSE
AND SO THIS IS GOING TO CREATE
MARKET INCENTIVES TO ENCOURAGE
THEM TO COMPLY WITH IT. BUT BUT
WHY OF THE IDEOLOGICALLY
OPPOSED TO THEY DON'T WANT.
THEIR CUSTOMERS TO THE- TO. BE
FOUND OUT WHEN THEY COMMIT
CRIMES IS THAT THE IDEOLOGY OR
WHAT IS IT YOU KNOW I DON'T
KNOW YOU YOU'D HAVE TO. YOU'D
YOU'D YOU KNOW YOU'D HAVE TO
ASK THEM DIRECTLY I DON'T WANT
TO SPEAK FOR THEM I THINK OKAY
HAVE HAVE THE MANUFACTURERS
HAVE GENERALLY BEEN BEEN
RESISTANT TO- TO ANY TYPE OF
REGULATION. AND SO I THINK IT
HAS MORE TO DO WITH THAT THAN
ANYTHING ELSE BUT AGAIN I DON'T
WANT TO SPEAK FOR THEM. OUR GUN
USERS I KNOW IN SOME CASES-
THEY ACTUALLY DO NOT WANT- THIS
TECHNOLOGY OUT OF HAVE GUN
USERS YOUR GUN USER GROUPS EVER
TAKEN A POSITION ON THIS. SO
FAR AS AS AS FAR AS I CAN TELL
NO NOT. NO NOT NONE OF THOSE
GROUPS HAVE WEIGHED IN ON OUR
FOR NINE- AGAIN THIS IS REALLY
TARGETING LONG FOR RIGHT NOW- I
WOULD HAVE TO FOR THAT YOU KNOW
CHRIS CERTAIN WANT WANT
CRISTINA PROTECT- BUT I'M NOT
WHY ALLOW GONNA WOULD BE
CONCERNED IT. OKAY SO WHAT
HAPPENED IF. JULY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY THREE COMES BALLOT AND
NOBODY HAS- PUT OUT SOMETHING.
WHAT'S THE FALL BACK WITH SO
THE FALL BACK THERE IS THAT
THEY CAN ACTUALLY TAKE THE
WEAPONS THAT THEY HAVE AND GO
GET THE FIRING PIN ENGRAVED FOR
pFIRING TEN THAT HAS BEEN AT
LEAST ARE GREAT SO IT'S NOT
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO ONLY HAVE
THE OPTION TO GO OUT THERE BY
THERE AND THAT'S WHY. I THINK
THE ARGUMENT WE HEARD FROM THE
OPPOSITION THAT IT WOULD LIMIT
THE CHOICES OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
FOR WHICH TYPE OF WEAPONS THEY
CAN USE I DON'T ACTUALLY SEE
HOW THAT MANIFESTS ITSELF IN
REALITY BECAUSE LAW ENFORCEMENT
CAN PURCHASE ANY TYPE OF WEAPON
THAT IT WANTS AND THEN GET THE
FIRING PENDING GREAT AFTER THE
FACT RIGHT AND THEN THEY'RE
OFF. ANY WEAPON THEY CARRY OFF
DUTY IS NOT REQUIRED TO CORRECT
CORRECT THIS IS ABOUT WEAPONS
PURCHASED BY THE DEPARTMENT OR
ANY WEAPON THAT THEY CARRY ON
TV OKAY HAS THE BILL BEEN MOVED
YET. YES OKAY THANK YOU FOR IT
YES. WICKS THANK YOU CHAIR I
JUST WANNA- THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR THE BILL I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT I THINK IT'S SMART
TECHNOLOGY. WE ARE GRAPPLING
WITH HOW TO- NAVIGATE THE GUN
VIOLENCE OR SING IN OUR
COMMUNITIES I THINK THIS IS.
ONE WAY THAT- WE CAN HOPEFULLY.
MITIGATE SOME OF THAT AND I.
ALSO HOPE THAT YOU CONTINUE TO
TALK TO LAW ENFORCEMENT AS THE
BILL MOVES TO THE PROCESS.
HOPEFULLY BUT- I'M PROUD TO
SUPPORT THE BILL LOOKING OR
DEVOTING FOR. YEAH THINKING OF
IF I MIGHT AS MEDICARE WE HAVE
THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION NOTIFIED ME TODAY
AS I BELIEVE THEY DID THE
COMMITTEE THAT THEY HAVE MOVED
FROM OPPOSED TO NEUTRAL- SO
WE'RE REALLY. LOOKING FORWARD
TO THE CONVERSATIONS WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS
SUPPORTED PREVIOUS
MICROCHIPPING EFFORTS. YOU KNOW
I UNDERSTAND PEOPLE GET A
LITTLE NERVOUS WHENEVER THERE'S
ANY TYPE OF NEW REQUIREMENT.
BUT IS REALLY MY INTENTION TO
WORK WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT GET
TO A PLACE WHERE WE CAN
ACCOMMODATE. AS MANY OTHER
CONCERNS AS POSSIBLE BECAUSE I
THINK THEY- MORE THAN ANYONE
WILL BENEFIT FROM THIS
TECHNOLOGY. RIGHT WILL HELP
THEM IN SOLVING CRIMES WE KNOW
FROM THE FBI. FOR MY TEN YEAR
STUDY THAT 70% OF NON FATAL-
AGGRAVATED ASSAULT INVOLVING
FIREARMS AREN'T SOLVED SO THIS
IS ACTUALLY TOOL THAT'S GOING
TO HELP THE GENERAL PUBLIC. AND
HEALTH PROBLEMS FOR SOME AS
WELL. IT IS THAT YOU'RE CLOSE.
LIFE THAT AND- IN TERMS. SO BUT
I'M KIND OF STRONG WITH THE BAD
GUYS OUT THERE BECAUSE THAT IS
A GOOD WE DON'T. DO YOU KNOW
MOST OF THE LAW BY CITIZEN
WOULD NOT EVER HAVE TO WORRY OF
SOMEBODY IDENTIFIABLE THEY WENT
THROUGH SOMEBODY CAME FROM THEM-
IT'S THE BAD GUYS IS THEY DON'T
NECESSARILY BUY THEIR GUNS
FROM. FROM HERE NOW BUYING FROM
DEALERS. AND THEY BUY AM FROM-
OTHER COUNTRIES. AND MAYBE EVEN
OTHER STATES- WHAT'S TO PREVENT
BAD GUYS FROM CONTINUING THAT
PRACTICE WHILE WE IMPOSE MORE
COSTS ON. OUR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES I. E. R.
R. CITIES- TO DO SOME WHERE WE
ARE KNOW THERE BUT ARE GOING IN
WHERE THEY CAME YOU KNOW WHO
SHOT THEM. WELL SO I GUESS A CO
OF A COUPLE OF RESPOND TO THIS
IN TERMS OF THE ANY I KNOW
WE'RE NOT IN COULD BY- IF YOU
LOOK AT THE CAR THE ESTá COST
STATE. HERE AND THEN YOU THINK
ABOUT COST OF GUN OF MEDICARE
AND OTHER THING TO THE STATE.
IF WE PRESENT IF WE PREVENT ONE
OR TWO SHOOTING HERE WE ARE
PROBABLY THIS IS PROBABLY
REVENUE POSITIVE FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WE'RE ACTUALLY
SAVING TAXPAYER MONEY. NOW ON
THE ISSUE IN TERMS OF YOUR
EITHER THE FIRST PART OF THE
QUESTION ABOUT THE FACT THAT
CRIMINALS OFTEN ACQUIRE LAW-
FIREARMS THROUGH A VARIETY OF
MEANS. IN ANY EVENT WHERE
THERE'S MY CRISTINA CAN
ACTUALLY HELP TRACE WHERE THE
FIRING CAME FROM AND SO THAT'S
WHY. THERE'S AN ELEMENT CARE
PREVENTING GUN TRAFFICKING WITH
RIGHT NOW PEOPLE BUY WEAPONS WE
HAVE NO IDEA HOW TO TRACE THEM
BACK. IF THEY'RE MY CHRISTOPHER
HELPED US TRACE THAT BACK. IF
THEY'RE BUYING THEM FROM A
FOREIGN COUNTRY. THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT THIS BILL CAN
ADDRESS THIS BILL ISN'T GONNA
SOLVE EVERY PROBLEM IN IN THE
ENTIRE WORLD ALL ALL ADMIT THAT
THERE ARE THINGS THAT THIS BILL
CAN'T DEAL- BUT I THINK IT IT
WILL ROLL THE BALL FORWARD. ON
A NUMBER OF THINGS THAT ARE
PART TO THE STATE THAT WILL
BENEFIT BOTH LAW ABIDING
CITIZENS. AND DAM ON FORSMAN.
I'M NOT SURE THAT I UNDERSTAND
HOW IT PREVENTS A SHOOTING FROM
HAPPENING. I UNDERSTAND HOW IT
MAY PREVENT. SOMEBODY WHO HAD
NO INTENTION OF GOING AND BEING
A SHOOTER OF SORTS WHO HAD
THEIR GUN MAKERS. MICRO
MICROCHIPPED WHATEVER. AND THEN
GONE OUT AND- AND GET A
SHOOTING. HOW THAT MIGHT HELP
HEM CATCH SOMEBODY LIKE THAT
SO SERVICE HOW IT PREVENTS
THANK YOU THE IDEA HERE IN
TERMS IT IS A GREAT QUESTION
IT'S A GREAT QUESTION DID YOU
HEARD FROM THE PREVENTING
SHOOTING. IS A LOT OF THE GUN
VIOLENCE THAT WE HAVE IN THE
STATE IS RETALIATORY VIOLENCE
WE SEE THIS IN CERTAIN IN
CERTAIN COMMUNITIES RIGHT AND
SO THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS IN
PREVIOUS YEARS WE'VE INVESTED
HUGE AMOUNT AMOUNTS OF MONEY
AND VIOLENCE INTERVENTION
PROGRAMS. BECAUSE WE'VE SEEN
DATA THAT WE CAN BREAK THAT
CYCLE OF RETALIATORY VIOLENCE
WE CAN BRING THE OVERALL NUMBER
OF SHOOTINGS WAY DOWN. AND SO
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT GIVES
LAW ENFORCEMENT A BETTER LEAD
ON WHO COMMITTED A SHOOTING AND
THEY CAN GET THAT PERSON THEY
CAN BREAK THAT CHAIN OF
RETALIATORY VIOLENCE AND
HOPEFULLY BRING THE LEVEL OF
GUN VIOLENCE DOWN. THANK YOU
FOR ANSWERS. ARE THANK YOU UP
MR LACKEY A QUESTION YEAH I
JUST A COUPLE POINTS OF CLARITY
IS IT TRUE THAT- MICROSCOPIC
TECHNOLOGY HAS NOT BEEN ADOPTED
BY ANY HANDGUN MANUFACTURED TO
THIS POINT. THAT THAT'S THAT
THAT'S CORRECT AND THIS IS ONE
OF THESE AREAS WERE HOPING THAT
THAT TECH THAT CALIFORNIA CAN
LEAD I THINK THAT THEY'VE-
SOUGHT TO EVADE THAT
REQUIREMENT BUT AS I AS I
MENTIONED I DON'T RECALL- YEAH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IF YOU'RE IN
THE ROOM OR NOT DAVID NEEDED IN
COURT FILINGS THAT THEY ARE
TECHNICALLY ABLE TO DO THIS BUT
IT'S NOT A TECHNICAL PROBLEM
FOR THEM TO IMPLEMENT
MICROSCOPIC TECHNOLOGY. AND OUR
ATTORNEY GENERAL CERTIFIED IN
200-010-2000 THIRTEEN THAT
THEY'RE ABLE TO DO IT SO WE
HAVE FROM BOTH THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT SIDE AND THE
MANUFACTURER SIDE. THE
KNOWLEDGE MEANT THAT THEY'RE
ABLE TO IMPLEMENT THE
TECHNOLOGY. IT'S MY-
FRUSTRATION THAT- THE WAY THE
BILL AS I UNDERSTAND IT IS
WRITTEN TO. WILL LIMIT THE
ABILITY FOR PURCHASING- A LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR CERTAIN KIND OF
WEAPONS ARE SURE KIND OF
WEAPONS. THAT MAY NOT BE.
MANUFACTURED BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
THERE'S NONE. AND WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT SAVING MONEY WHO WERE YOU
SAVING MONEY FOR BECAUSE IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING. THAT THIS
BILL HAS NO FUNDING MECHANISM.
SO IT'S JUST GOING TO COST LAW
ENFORCEMENT PART OF THE BUDGET.
YEAH AND I AGAIN I THINK- AND
I'LL JUST ADDRESSED THE DOCTOR
KIRK REYES THE SAME POINT READY
TO GO TO WE DON'T WANT TO LIMIT
THE RANGE OF OPTIONS THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS- WHICH THEY
NEED THE TOOLS TO BE ABLE TO DO
THEIR JOB. SO IF THERE IS NOT A
MODEL OF GUN THAT IS SOLD WITH
MICROSCOPIC TECHNOLOGY THAT
THEY NEED THEY CAN GO OUT THERE
AND BY THAT CATEGORY OF WEAPON
AND THEN ENGRAVE THE FIRING TEN
WITH MY CRISTINA OR REPLACE THE
FIRING PIN WITH A FIRING PIN
THAT HAS BEEN MICRO STAMP AT A
COST OF SOMEWHERE BETWEEN.
FIFTY CENTS AND SIX FIFTY TO
REPLACE THAT THAT FIRING HIM SO
WE'RE NOT ANYWAY GOING TO LIMIT
ANY TYPE OF CATEGORY OF WEAPON
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT COULD USE
TO DO THEIR JOB THEY NEED THE
TOOLS TO DO THEIR JOB. AND THEN
IN TERMS OF THE COST AYE I
MENTION THIS I THINK WHEN
YOU'RE OUT OF THE ROOM. THE
LOWEST ESTIMATE FOR THE COST OF
THIS TECHNOLOGY PER WEAPON IS
FIFTY CENTS. THE HIGHEST
ESTIMATE IS SIX DOLLARS AND
FIFTY CENTS WHEN YOU TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION WE HAVE EIGHTY
SIX THOUSAND ACTIVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TOTAL COST STATEWIDE
EVERY OFFICER IS SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN I GOT TO CHECK MY MATH
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND AND FIVE
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND FOR THE
WHOLE STATE EVERY AGENCY EVERY
OFFICER SO. IN MY MIND IF
YOU'RE HALF A MILLION BUCKS IS
YOUR HIGHER ESTIMATE WE'RE NOT
REALLY IMPOSING A HUGE BURDEN
ON OUR LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGAIN THAT'S SOMETHING WE CAN
ADDRESS TO THE BUDGET FOR A
PROBLEMS I WAS HOPING TO SPEAK
TO A POLICY IN THIS COMMITTEE.
BUT I THINK THIS IDEA OF COST
AND BURDEN HERE WHEN YOU
ACTUALLY DO THE MATH. IT'S DE
MINIMUS. IN MY OPINION THERE'S
TOO MUCH- FOR SOME THE SOAP. IN
THE DEFENSE OF- LAW ENFORCEMENT
SO I WON'T BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THE STUDENTS ARE. MR LEE. I
JUST I THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
ALSO BRING THIS FOURTEEN YEAR
LEADERSHIP IN THEIR
THOROUGHNESS IN THIS ISSUE AREA
ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT THAT HOW
FORWARD THINKING IT IS
OBVIOUSLY THEY JUST RECENTLY TO
CATCH UP TO THIS BUT IT COULD
BRING GREAT TRANSPARENCY IN
ESPECIALLY THE ISSUE OF POLICE
INVOLVED SHOOTINGS BECAUSE UP
UNTIL NOW WE HAVE NO IDEA WHO
SHOT WHICH BILL UNTIL THIS
BALLISTIC TESTS BUT MICROGAMING
WHO CAN TELL CONFIDENCE WHO
FIRED WHAT SHOT AND THAT GIVES
A LOT OF TRANSPARENCY KNOWS THE
PUBLIC BUT TO THE POLICE FAR
WHEN TAKING APPROPRIATE ACTION
ABOUT. WHAT CAN HAPPEN BUT
INCIDENTS HAPPEN OF COURSE WE
HAD ANOTHER DRAMATIC SHOOTING
JUST THIS WEEKEND- IN IN A
SUBURB NORTH OF MINNEAPOLIS AND
IT WOULD BE REALLY BORED TO
KNOW OBVIOUSLY IN ALL THESE
KIND OF CASES WHO FIRED ONE
SHOT AND HAVE DEFINITIVE INSIDE
CASE IT'S A REALLY HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND- THANK
YOU FOR YEAH I KNOW I
APPRECIATE THOSE COMMENTS AND I
THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
BIGGEST- TO ME ONE OF THE
BIGGEST AT A YOU KNOW
ATTRACTIONS OF THIS AND
BENEFITS OF THIS TECHNOLOGY AS
YOU CAN TELL WITHIN A NUMBER OF
HOURS. EXACTLY WHO FIRED
WEBSITE WHERE IT WENT THERE'S
NO IN AND NOT THAT TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY I THINK IT'S
GOING TO HELP BUILD TRUST
BETWEEN- BETWEEN COMMUNITIES
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT. THANK YOU.
IS YOU'RE CLOSE. YES SIR. OKAY
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS AND ALSO THANK
YOU FOR ANSWERINGMY QUESTION
ON. ON MICROTIA STAMPING
RETROACTIVELY. AND WHAT WILL
LAW ENFORCEMENT DO IF THEY BUY
GUNS THAT HAVEN'T BEEN FROM.
MICROSOFT SITE. I APPRECIATE
THAT I NOTICED IT. IS TOUGH
QUESTION BUT YOU TACKLE
RITUALS. THANK YOU. AND SO-
OUGHT. AND I'M HAPPY HERE TO
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S.
ASSOCIATION HAS GONE NEUTRAL AS
YOU KNOW I WAS NEUTRAL AND ON
UNDER ADVISEMENT I'M A VOTE I
FOR THE- FOR THE BILL NOW. AB
EIGHT SEVEN SIX BY SEVEN MEMBER
GABRIEL THE MISSION IS TO PASS
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER. JONES SAWYER HI
LACKEY NO LACKING NO BARRICADE
CAN. THERAPY HAD AYE CORK AYE
QUICK AYE SANTIAGO. C. R. TOKEN
C. R. TEN NO WICKS. WICKS I'D
LI. LI I. THE MEASURE PASS
THANK YOU FOR THANK. WE NOW
HAVE MR GIVES AB FOUR NINE ZERO
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY POLICIES
ARREST POSITIONAL ASPHYXIA. AND
I BELIEVE MISSION THERE BONTA
AG ELECT OR AG. NOMINEE IS ALSO
SPEAKING. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS FIRST OF
ALL LET ME START OFF BY
ACCEPTING THE- COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH MY
TEAM IN ORDER TO MAKING AND
STRENGTHENING THIS BILL AND
WITH CLARIFICATION. WHAT IT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR NINETY. WE'RE SIX THE
BAD LAW ENFORCEMENT FROM USING
RESTRAINTS. RESTRAINTS THAT
CALLS POSITIONAL ASPHYXIATION.
POSITIONAL EXPIATION. IS A
DEADLY CONDITION THAT CAN OCCUR
WHEN A PERSON'S BEING
RESTRAINED. CANNOT GET ENOUGH
OXYGEN I CAN'T BREATHE. WHILE
LAW ENFORCEMENT INTENDS TO
INCAPACITATE OR RENDER A
SUSPECT UNCONSCIOUS WE ALREADY
KNOW THAT CHAU COLES AND
CAROTID ARTERY STRAINS ARE
DANGEROUS AND OFTEN LETHAL.
LAST YEAR AFTER A HIGH PROFILE
DEATH OF MR GEORGE FLOYD BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN MINNEAPOLIS
CIVIL UNREST TOOK PLACE ALL
OVER THE NATION AND
INTERNATIONALLY. RESPONDING TO
THE COMMUNITY WITHOUT WASTING
ANY TIME I AUTHORS LANDMARK
LEGISLATION ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN NINETY SIX. TOBAM LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM USING PRODUCT
SKEWS ME CHUCKLES AND THANK
THIS COMMITTEE. AND THE CHAIR
FOR SUPPORTING THIS VITAL PIECE
OF LEGISLATION THAT I COULD NOT
HAVE DONE IT MYSELF AND WITHOUT
YOU SHORTLY AFTER ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN NINETY SIX WAS
INTRODUCED GOVERNOR EXPRESSED
SUPPORT IMMEDIATELY. BECAUSE HE
SAW THE IMMEDIATE NEED FOR
CHANGE I WANT TO THANK OUR
GOVERNOR FOR SIGNING ASSEMBLY
BILL ELEVEN NINETY SIX INTO LAW.
WE NOW NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL METHODS OF RESTRAINING
SOMEONE DO NOT TURN
UNNECESSARILY DANGEROUS. THE
TECHNIQUES USED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT ON MISTER FLOYD WAS
A NEED TO THE NECK RESTRAINT IS
ALSO COVERED BY THE LARGER TERM
POSITION OF EXPIATION. THEY
NEED TO THE NECK BECAUSE OXYGEN
TO BE RESTRICTED OR TO STOP
THAT RENDER SOMEONE UNCONSCIOUS
LEADS TO DEATH. AGAIN THE TERM
INCLUDES. OTHER WAYS WHICH LAW
ENFORCEMENT RESTRAINTS SOMEONE
AND CAUSE THEM TO LOSE OXYGEN
BEYOND JUST THE CHOKO CHOKO
CAUSES THE BLOOD TO BE
RESTRICTED TO THE BRAIN. WHICH
CALLS ONE UNCONSCIOUSNESS AND
INTO IT LEADS TO DEATH WHEN
APPLIED INCORRECTLY. AND FOR
TOO LONG. IF A PERSON SOME IF A
POSITION IF YOU POSITION
SOMEONE. OWN BODY IN A WAY THAT
THEY LOSE OXYGEN THIS IS ALSO
COVERED BY THIS BILL I WANT TO
REPEAT IS COVERED BY THIS BILL.
AS WE ALL KNOW THAT OFFICER I
WILL SAY IS NINE. PUT ANY OLD
MR FLOYD'S NECK. AND HE DID SO
FOR NINE MINUTES AND TWENTY
NINE SECONDS NINE MINUTES AND
TWENTY NINE SECONDS. UNTIL MR
FLOORED LAID HIS BODY LAID
LIFELESS. IN DECEMBER OF LAST
YEAR ANGELO PINTO. A NAVY
VETERAN FOR NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WAS TRAGICALLY KILLED BY THE
POLICE. MR KATO WITH HAND
CUFFED. MR KANTOR WILL SUFFER A
MENTAL HEALTH EPISODE WHERE HIS
FAMILY CALLED THE POLICE. THEY
RECALL ORDER TO HELP DE
ESCALATE THE SITUATION. WELL MR
KATO LAID FACE DOWN BLOODIED
FROM THE HANDCUFFS BEHIND HIS
BACK A RESPONDING OFFICER NEIL
ON MR CANTOS NECK. FOR NEARLY
FIVE MINUTES GEORGE SCORED NINE
MINUTES TWENTY NINE SECONDS MR
KATO FIVE MINUTES. ANOTHER
OFFICER RESTRAINED HIS LEGS. MR
KING TOLD LOS. AND NEVER
REGAINED CONSCIOUSNESS HIS
FAMILY WITNESSED THIS HORRIFIC
HORRIBLE TRAGEDY NO FAMILY
SHOULD EVER HAVE TO EXPERIENCE
WHAT THIS FAMILY HAS EXPERIENCE
THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF MR KATO
THE DEATH IS A STARK PARALLEL
OF MISTER GEORGE FLOOR WHICH
BOTH EXPOSED GREAT ARIENS. A
LOOPHOLE IN THE USE OF FORCE
POLICY KERN STATEWIDE USE OF
FORCE POLICIES NOW PROHIBIT LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM USING ANY TYPE
OF CHOKEHOLD INCLUDING CAROTID
ARTERY STRINGS. BUT IT DOES NOT
DIRECTLY ADDRESS LISTEN IF IT
DOES NOT DIRECTLY ADDRESS USING
PERSONAL BODY AS A WEAPON. THAT
REDUCE ONE ABILITY TO BRIEF
THIS DOES NOT MEAN A POLICE
OFFICER CAN NOT CAN NO LONGER
RESTRAIN ANYONE THEY NEED TO
PLEASE LET ME REPEAT THIS AGAIN.
IT DOES NOT PROHIBIT LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM USING A
RESTRAINT. WHEN NEEDED. THIS
BILL DOES HOWEVER. MAKE SURE
THAT POLICE OFFICERS DID NOT
USE ANY METHOD THAT CUTS OFF
ONE'S BREATHING. RESTRICTS
OXYGEN FOR A PERSON LOANS BEING
FILLED UP AB FOUR NINETY WILL
CREATE A UNIFORM STATEWIDE
POLICY ON RESTRAINTS THAT CALLS
POSITIONAL ASPHYXIATION TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE RESTRAINTS ARE
NO LONGER USE. MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS I'M HAPPY TO LIVE
JOINT CO AUTHORED MY JOINT
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ROB BONTA FOR A FEW
REMARKS AND THEN AFTER WHICH
JOINT VIRTUALLY. HERE TODAY
WILL BE THE FATHER STEPFATHER
ARE ROBERT COLLINS WHO STEP
FATHER OF ANGELO KETO WHO ALSO-
PROVIDE TESTIMONY. AND THEN WE
WILL ALSO HAVE ROBERT HARRIS
WHOSE REPRESENT SPECIAL COUNSEL
FOR THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF BLACK LAWYERS AND JUST OPEN
THE COMMITTEES- EDIFICATION
I'VE NAMED THIS BILL AFTER
ANGELO CANCEL THEIR ENDS- KETO.
ACT OF TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE.
THANK YOU MR BONTA. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES AND
STAFF AND I THANK YOU SOME OF
EVER GIPSON FOR INTRODUCING
THIS BILL AND ALLOWING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COME PRESENTED
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
ACCOMMODATING ME IN THIS
UNUSUAL CALL PRESENTATION- LAST
YEAR I WAS PROUD. TO CO AUTHOR.
AB ELEVEN NINETY SIX BY
SEPTEMBER GIPSON TO BAN THE USE
OF CAROTID HOLDS AND RESTRAINTS
IT WAS. TIMELY AND NEEDED
LANDMARK LEGISLATION FOLLOWING
THE TRAGIC DEATH OF GEORGE
FLOYD AND THIS YEAR. I'M PROUD
TO JOIN AUTHOR A BEFORE NINETY
TO BAN THE USE OF POSITIONAL
ASPHYXIA RESTRAINTS STATEWIDE.
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT. AS
MENTIONED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON THIS BILL IS NAMED FOR
ANGELA CAN TELL. A YOUNG MAN
AND VETERANS WHO LIVE NOT TOO
FAR FROM MY DISTRICT AND DIED
DURING AN INTERACTION WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT. I WAS ABLE TO
SPEAK TO ANGELES FAMILY IN
RECENT WEEKS AND YOU'LL HEAR
FROM THEM AS WELL. HIS FAMILY
LIT UP WITH STORIES OF A SWEET.
AND CURIOUS CHILD WHO GREW INTO
A NURTURING AND SENSITIVE MAP.
ANGELO LIKE SO MANY OF US HAD
STRUGGLED PERIODICALLY WITH
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. INSTEAD
OF HELPING HIM IN A MOMENT OF
CRISIS. OUR SOCIETY FAILED HIM.
I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE MEMBER
GIBSON'S LEADERSHIP IN
INTRODUCING THIS BILL AND FOR
NAMING IT. AFTER AND LOOKING
DOWN IN HIS LOVING MEMORY SO
THAT WE DO NOT HAVE ADDITIONAL
DEATHS LIKE ANGELO'S AND OUR
STATE. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SIR. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES WITHIN THE- ANY
WITNESSES. DID YOU HAVE YEAH
YES YOU COULD BEGIN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
WE WERE GIPSON TIMER BONTA MY
NAME'S RYAN HARRISON I AM THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA GENERAL
COUNSEL FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF BLACK LAWYERS WE
REPRESENT. OVER SIX THOUSAND
AFRICAN AMERICAN ATTORNEYS
JUDGES LAW PROFESSORS AND
STUDENTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. I ALSO HAPPEN TO
BE A FORMER LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER AND HOLD A MASTER'S
DEGREE IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE. SO
I HAVE BEEN ASKED TO PROVIDE ON
TESTIMONY- REGARDING THAT
TECHNICAL ASPECT OF THE BILL AB
ELEVEN NINETY SIX. AND I'M
GONNA MAKE THIS REALLY SHORT
AND BRIEF BECAUSE THE BILL IS.
PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD AND I'M
ALSO AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MAY HAVE. I JUST WANTED
TO POINT OUT THAT THIS BILL IS
THIS AMENDMENT- PRETTY MUCH-
PROHIBITS LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES FROM AUTHORIZING
TECHNIQUES OR TRANSPORT METHOD
THAT CALLS A SUBSTANTIAL RISK
OF POSITIONAL ASPHYXIA. SO THE
KEY WORD IS SUBSTANTIAL RIGHT-
THE RISK MUST BE SUBSTANTIAL
ABOUT TWO MORE POINTS- AS FAR
AS THE UP PRESSURE OUR BODY
WEIGHT INVOLVED WHEN IT COMES
TO RESTRAINING A SUSPECT. AND
THAT THAT PRESSURE OR THAT BODY
WEIGHT ON THE PERSON WHO'S
RESTRAINT MUST BE ON REASONABLE
THE KEY WORD IS ON REASONABLE.
RIGHT AND SO OBVIOUSLY- LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS HAVE TO-
GENERALLY POVIDE A REASONABLE
RESTRAINT ON A PERSON WHEN
THEY'RE EFFECTING ARREST SO WE
HAVE TO LOOK FOR WHAT
UNREASONABLE AND WHETHER OR NOT
THAT HAS A SUBSTANTIAL RISK OF
CARVING IS FIXED. THE THIRD
POINT IS THAT WHEN A PERSON IS
RESTRAINED ON THE FLOOR IN THE
PRONE OR SUPINE POSITION- EIGHT
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS SHOULD
CHECK TO MAKE SURE THAT PERSON
CAN BREATHE. AND I THINK THAT
IS- SOMETHING THAT WE CAN ALL
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT- SHOULD SHOULD
GO WITHOUT SAYING. AND SO WITH
THAT I AM AVAILABLE TO TAKE
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS REGARDING
THE TECHNICAL ASPECT OF THIS
BILL. I THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THE NEXT YES GOOD AFTERNOON.
ACTUALLY COMMITTEE CHAIR I
JONES SAWYER VICE CHAIR LACKEY
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
YOU TODAY MY NAME IS ROBERT
COLLINS- MY STEP SON ANGELA
CHIU DAHLE WHAT KILLED DURING
THE CHRISTMAS HOLIDAYS BY
ENTERED POLICE OFFICERS WHEN
THEY WERE CALLED BY MY DAUGHTER
TO HELP WITH A MENTAL HEALTH
EMERGENCY HE WAS EXPERIENCING.
WHEN THE POLICE OFFICER ARRIVE
YET CALMED DOWN AND WAS BEING
HELD IN A TIGHT HUG. BY IS FOUR
FOOT ELEVEN INCHES TALL MOTHER.
ANGELO WAS NOT COMMITTING A
CRIME AND THE OFFICERS
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT. ANGELA WAS
PARANOID. BUT HE WAS NOT
VIOLENT DID NOT EXIST IN ANY
WAY AND FOLLOW ALL COMMANDS. HE
WAS SCARED AND PARANOID. HE
PLEADED FOR HIS LIFE NOT GIVE
THE OFFICERS. PLEASE DON'T KILL
ME. YOU DON'T JONES- THE
OFFICERS PUT A MODEST AMERICAN
HANCOCK THEM AND WHILE ONE
OFFICER WHO SPENT HIS LEGS AND
PUSH THEM UP AGAINST HIS BODY
ANOTHER PUT ANY ON THE BACK OF
ANGELES NECK. ONE OF THE
PRODUCTOR GREW TIRED OF TAKING
THE WEIGHT UNENCLOSED NECK.
ANOTHER TOOK ITS PLACE AND
CONTINUE TO APPLYING THE SAME
TECHNIQUE. HE DID NOT CHECK ON
THE CONDITION EVEN WHILE HIS
MOTHER WHO WAS IN THE SAME ROOM
THE WHOLE TIME. ASKED ABOUT
HIM. HE WAS UNRESPONSIVE FOR
EACH ONE A HALF MINUTES OF THE
HOLD. AND REMAIN SO AFTER THE
TRIP CAME OVER. AND LOOKED
CONDITION DID NOT SIGNIFICANTLY
CHANGE FROM FROM WHEN HE WAS
RESTRAINED. HE WOULD NEVER BE
THE GOVERNOR'S OWN. ANY SITES
WERE NEVER ABLE TO CLOSE AGAIN.
AND HAD TO BE PAID SHOT IN THE
HOSPITAL UNTIL HIS OFFICIAL.
DEATH ON DECEMBER TWENTY SIX.
THE USE OF THIS RISK HAVE
WIDELY BANNED LONG. EIGHT
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY. STATES
HAVE SHOWN THAT POLICE
DEPARTMENT THAT HAVE POLICIES
PROHIBITING CHOKEHOLDS AND
STRANGLEHOLD RESULT IN THE
REDUCTION OF POLICE KILLINGS OF
CIVILIANS BY 22% MANY CIVILIANS
HAVE BEEN KILLED IN CALIFORNIA
IN THIS MANNER YOU CAN IMAGINE.
DEPT THAT SHOULD AND COULD HAVE
BEEN PREVENTED. THE TRIAL OF
THE OFFICER TO KILL GEORGE
PLAYED THIS PAST TWO WEEKS HAVE
TAUGHT ACCOUNTING HUMAN THE
THREE STRAIGHT DAYS AND HOW
EASY IT NEEDS TO BACK. I WISH.
ASK YOU TO SUPPORT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIBSON'S MAYBE FOR
NINETY TO PREVENT THE USE OF
RECONNECT AND OTHER RESTRAINTS.
THE CONSTITUTIONAL SPEAKS YEAH.
NO MORE DEPTH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU OKAY ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES WITHIN THE-
FORTY TWO OH TWO. SENIOR NOT
AND THEY ON THE VIDEO
CONFERENCE ROOM IN SUPPORT AND
THEN AT&T OPERATOR- OPEN UP
LINES FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
NAME AN ORGANIZATION. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR NINETY
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN THE
FIRST SUPPORT- EIGHTY FOUR NINE
ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE ABOUT FOR COMMENCING Q.
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE SEVENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HAPPY
SURE FOR ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU I
NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OF MINE
ONE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ERLING RUIZ- VALLEY IMPROVEMENT
PROJECT I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
FORTY FIVE. MY THANK YOU I HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU- NOW
HERE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I
HAVE TO WORRY SILVA- FROM THE
SHERIFF'S. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS CORY CELLS- ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION-
REGRETTABLY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL WE APPRECIATE- ABOUT
THE AUTHOR SPOKE ON THIS ISSUE-
STEMMING BACK TO LAST YEAR IN
THE FORM OF AB ELEVEN NINETY
SIX AND- HIS WILLINGNESS TO
REMOVE THIS LANGUAGE FROM THAT
BILL- BASED ON CONCERNS THAT
WERE COMMUNICATED- I WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT- WE FEAR THIS BILL IS
OVERLY BROAD AND- NEGLECT
SITUATIONS- WITH. IN AS MUCH AS
A DOESN'T INCLUDE SPECIFIC
LANGUAGE- REGARDING- THE THREAT
INCIDENTS WHETHER TO THREAT OF
DEATH OR SERIOUS BODILY INJURY
TO AN OFFICER OR ANOTHER
PERSON. I WOULD JUST NOTE- AND
WE HOPE CA WORKING- WHAT THE
AUTHOR ON BILL BUT BUILDING OF
SCHOOL ANY TECH IN WHICH
PRESSURE BODY WEIGHT IS ON READ
UP AGAINST RESTRAINT NECK TORSO
OR BACK THEM QUOTE- IS OVERLY
BROAD- REASONABLE WILL BE TO
JUDGE FROM TO. THIS IN AND I
WOULD JUST OUT THAT ACCORDING
TO THE THAT RESTRICTS- FORGET
REGARD PLACING A RISK APPROACH
ASSUME POSITION BUT A STANCE
GREENCORE A PERSON WORST TO OR
ON A GURNEY. LIMITING THE USE
OF APPROPRIATE PHYSICAL
RESTRAINT TECHNIQUES BY TRAINED
OFFICERS DECREASES OPTIONS
ALONG THE SPECTRUM OF
APPROPRIATE FORCE AND COULD
INCREASE RELIANCE ON OTHER
TOOLS INCLUDING. ELECTRIC OR
IMPACT DEVICES. YEAH WE WISH TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH YA BOOKS
THOSE THREE- AT NOTED IN AT THE
TIME CSSA FIRST. OPPOSE IT
BEFORE NINE ZERO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES WITHIN THE HEARING
ROOM IN OPPOSITION. AND A ON
THE VIDEO CONFERENCE SCREEN AND
YOU MAY OPEN UP THE LINE
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATORS TO RAINY-
TELEPHONE OPPOSITION. Q. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION-
EIGHTY FOUR NINETY PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN SIR OPPOSITION OUT
AB FOUR NINE ZERO PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE TWO LINES IN
Q. WILL GO TO LINE ONE AWAIT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
FOLLOWS NOT ABLE TO GET INTO
THE QUEUE FOR POSTSEASON-
ALBERT MY NAME WOULD BE CALLING.
I'M AS TO ON. AND I SAW SUPPORT
A FOUR NINE. YEAH ARE YOU
LOOKING FOR A SCHOOL TWENTY ONE
THANK. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT ONCE SO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ALL THE
INFO SHANTI HALF OF. OVER
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND MEMBERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION WE ARE ACTUALLY CO
SPONSORS OF THE MEMBERS OF THIS
BILL EIGHTY FOUR NINETY AND ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT COLLEGES FOR
DIALING IN LATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. RIGHT THANK YOU WILL
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS REBEKAH. POWER QUE
HAN AND MR LEE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND I WANT TO
THANK BOTH THE AUTHOR AND MR
BONTA FOR RINGING THE BELL AND
FOR YOUR COMMENTS ON MR CANTO-
AND HIS. TRAGIC DEATH- I TO
HAVE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH HIS FAMILY AND HEAR
ABOUT HIS INCREDIBLE LIFE AND
WE KNOW THAT IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
AN INCREDIBLE LIFE THERE COUNTY
OTHER OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE-
TO CONTINUE IT AND- SO I THINK
THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
MEASURE THE LOOK SO WHAT
HAPPENED. WHAT IS HAPPENED NOW
WE KNOW TOO MANY BECAUSE ONE IS
TOO MANY INCIDENTS WHERE
SOMEONE LOSES THEIR LIFE
UNNECESSARILY BECAUSE OF THESE.
CHOCOLATES I JUST HAD ONE
QUESTION WHICH IS- WITH MISTER
SAYS A LOVELY SPEAKING FOR THE
SHERIFF'S AT MENTIONED
SOMETHING THAT I KNOW YOU'RE
COMMITTED TO BECAUSE WE TALKED
ABOUT IT HE SAID IT HERE TODAY
WHICH IS. THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
IS ALLOWED TO USE THE SOCIAL
FIXATIONS WHERE THERE IS- WHERE
DEADLY FORCE IS APPROPRIATE BUT
THAT'S WITH. YEAH THIS IS
LEADING TO DEATH AND THAT'S THE
SITUATION WHERE THIS SHOULD BE
USED SO CAN YOU PLEASE ADDRESS
HIS CONCERNS ABOUT THE VAGUE
NATURE OF THAT ALLOWANCE AND
WHETHER OR NOT YOU'RE GONNA
DRESS THAT. SURE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR QUESTION. WE'RE
LAW. IS DO THEIR JOB. WE'RE
SAYING THAT IN THEY'LL MISSION
OF YOUR JOB. YOU SHOULD NOT BE
CUTTING SOMEONE'S OX YOU KNOW.
EVERYONE HAS A RIGHT TO BRING
REAL BREATHING RIGHT NOW. AND
IF YOU'RE IF THERE'S SOMETHING
DONE THAT RESTRICTS THAT
OXYGEN. YOU WILL. ALSO LOSE
CONSCIOUSNESS AND THEN ALSO MAY
DIE FOR SUCH A LONG TIME
SPECIALLY IF IS RESTRICTED
OFFICERS WERE NOT. THIS WILL
NOT- CHANGE- OFFICERS ABILITY.
TO RESTRAIN A INDIVIDUAL- THAT
THEY COME IN CONTACT WITH IT
ONLY FOCUSED IN ON. RESTRICTING
SOMEONE'S ABILITY TO BREATHE.
YOU CAN PLACE THEM ON THE FLOOR
PUT THEIR THEIR NEEDS ON THEIR
BACK IN BETWEEN THE FLOOR AND
THE KNEE IT WILL COMPRESS. THE
LUNGS AND YOU WON'T BE ABLE TO
BRING. WE'RE SAYING THAT YOU.
WOULD YOU WOULD HAVE TO BE A
BRIEF ARE YOU GOING TO KILL
SOMEONE. AND THIS BILL FOR
NINETY SPEAKS THAT VERY ISSUE.
SO I HEAR YOU I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT- THAT THAT AND MR
CELL I DON'T KNOW IF YOU WANT
TO CHIME IN THAT THIS QUESTION
OF WHETHER OR NOT IT CAN BE
USED WHERE THERE IS A RISK OF
DEATH TO THE OFFICER- RIGHT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WHAT
SHOULD BE USED BUT I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS- DOES THAT ALLOW
FOR IT TO BE USED WHEN THERE
IS. WHEN AN OFFICER IS LOST HIS
OR HER WEAPON RIGHT AND THERE
IS A RISK OF DEATH TO THE
OFFICER AND THE OFFICER HAS A
RIGHT TO DEFEND THEMSELVES I
MEAN THAT IS ABSOLUTELY. RIGHT
THE OFFICER HAS A RIGHT TO
DEFEND HIM OR HERSELF IN THE
OMISSION OF RESTRAINING AN
INDIVIDUAL WE'RE SIMPLY SAYING
IN THE ACT EVEN WHEN YOU COME
DOWN TO GEORGE FLOYD- AND HE
WAS ON THE NECK WHICH
RESTRICTED HIS. OXYGEN FLOW
WHICH CAUSING CONSCIOUSNESS
WITHIN SAID BUT THEN IT COST
HIM TO DIE THE SAME AN ISSUE OF
MR CAME TO. THE SAME METHOD WAS
APPLIED THAT CALLS AND
CONSCIOUSNESS AND THEN HE LATER
DIED AS A RESULT OF IT SO THIS
BILL DOES NOT A LOT DOES NOT
HINDER A POLICE OFFICER. FROM
DOING HIS OR HER JOB OR STOP
THE PERSON FROM DOING BODILY
HARM TO THE POLICE OFFICER AND
OR TO SOMEONE ELSE. GOT IT OKAY
SO I MEAN I THINK OBVIOUSLY.
GEORGE ANGELO KANTO ARE
EXAMPLES WHERE THIS WAS
ABSOLUTELY MISUSED AND I THINK
WE ARE TAKING THE RIGHT STEPS
TO ENSURE IT ISN'T USED- I
THINK THAT WE JUST NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DO ALLOW OFFICERS
WHO. I NEED TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES BECAUSE THERE IS-
TRIED TO THEIR LIFE THE RIGHT
TO DO SO BECAUSE THEY PUT
THEMSELVES IN HARM'S WAY NOT
THAT WAS NOT THE SITUATION WITH
EITHER ANGELO PINTO WHO IS
HANDCUFFED TO THE GROUND AND
COMPLETELY NOT A FRAT FOR
CHARTER FLIGHTS RIGHT. I'M MORE
MANY OTHERS AND SO I THINK THAT
THAT'S WHERE I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THE CHANGES MADE- BUT I
APPRECIATE THIS AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING IT AND WE
WILL WORK WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
AS WE'VE DONE IN THE PAST AGAIN
AS WAS STATED. INTO RECORD
ELEVEN NINETY SIX WE HAD THIS
THIS LANGUAGE IN ELEVEN NINETY
SIX WE TOOK IT OUT WE MOVE THE
CHOKEHOLD CHRONIC ARE
RESTRAINS- FORGOT THAT BILL
SIGNED AND WE WORKED WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN THAT REGARD AND
WE WORK WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
THIS REGARD AS WELL. AND ALSO
JUST WANT TO MAKE MENTION THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
WORKED WITH US ON THIS LANGUAGE.
AND A CONTINUING WITH US IN
THIS REGARD. ABSOLUTELY THANK
YOU AND MISTER LEE. I SAW
THANKED THE FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE AND FOR OUR
FUTURE FOR ALL BRING ATTENTION
TO I ALSO AS HOW IMPORTANT AND
ALSO I THANK THE RESILIENCY OF
THE KINGS OF FAMILY FOR COMING
HERE AND SHARING THE STORY I
HAVE TRAGIC IT IS I SERIOUSLY I
CANNOT THANK YOU ENOUGH FOR
BRING MORE ATTENTION TO THE
STORY I THINK. IS TERRIBLE AND
AWFUL IS MORE PEOPLE SHOULD
KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING YOU RIGHT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
ESPECIALLY TO ALL PEOPLE OF
COLOR RIGHT ASIAN AMERICANS
INCLUDED AND THE KIDS ARE CASES
INCREDIBLY TRAGIC AND TERRIBLE
AND I DON'T THINK IT SHOULD BE
CONTROVERSIAL THAT POLICE
SHOULD BE DENYING SOMEONE'S
RIGHT TO BREATHE AS YOU SAID
AND IT'S A COMMON SENSE I THINK
IT'S A COMMON SENSE APPROACH OF
DOING IT THE RIGHT WAY AND I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT AND IT ALSO
HAS TO BE AT ITS A CO AUTHOR
WHEN THE TIME IS APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HONOR TO
ADD YOU AS A CO AUTHOR MISTER
LUCKY WAS NEXT MR WICKS. YEAH
THIS IS ONE OF. AWKWARD TOPIC
FOR ME- ADDRESS FROM THE DO.
BEST I. BECAUSE I TAKE THE- THE
UNPOPULAR POSITION HERE. OF-
JUST TRYING TO EXPRESS TO YOU
THE CHALLENGE OF DEALING WITH
SOMEBODY WHO IS- VIOLENTLY
RESISTING VIOLENTLY- A THREAT
TO THOSE IN AN IMMEDIATE AREA.
I'M THE ONLY ONE PROBABLY IN
THIS ROOM I LEAST I HOPE I AM
THAT OF YOU ARE A COP FOR A
YEAR BUT I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY.
INSTANCES YOU HAD WHERE THIS
WAS A TRUE THREAT TO YOU. BUT I
CAN TELL YOU I'VE HAD MULTIPLE.
MULTIPLE TIMES WHERE. I KNOW
THAT THE PERSON WE WERE TRYING
TO SUBDUE. WOULD BE WILLING TO
TAKE MY LIFE. IN ORDER TO GET
AWAY. AND IT'S HARD FOR. THOSE
OF US WHO HAVE CARRIED THAT
CHALLENGE TO EXPRESS TO OTHERS
HOW THAT FEELS AND I'M NOT
TRYING TO EXCUSE THE MISCONDUCT
OF OFFICERS I DON'T KNOW ONE
PERSON. I'VE LEAST I'VE NEVER
SPOKEN TO ANYONE WHO SUPPORTS
THE ACTIONS TAKEN AGAINST
GEORGE WILL AND THAT WAS AN
OUTRAGE AND I THINK IT'S BEEN
TAKEN CARE OF RIGHT NOW- AND
THE CATO SITUATION I'D- I CAN'T.
DO ANYTHING BUT FEEL VERY
SADDENED THAT IT HAD THE
OUTCOME IT DID NO ONE WANTS A
DEADLY OUTCOME NO ONE THE PEACE
OFFICER DOESN'T WANT THAT AND I
KNOW THE VICTIM DOESN'T WANT
THAT- AND SO. WHAT WHAT SEEMS
TO BE. THE COMMON OCCURRENCE AT
LEAST IN THE SENTIMENT OF THOSE
ON THE OUTSIDE IS THAT OFFICERS
ARE THE AGGRESSORS. AND I WILL
TELL YOU. MAYBE IN SOME
INSTANCES THEY ARE IF THEY ARE
THAT'S REGRETTABLE IT'S NOT
APPROPRIATE. BUT WHAT IS
APPROPRIATE IS THE ABILITY TO
TRY TO BRING ORDER AND CALL TO
A VERY VIOLENT SITUATION. AND
WHEN YOU USE THE TERM
POSITIONAL ASPHYXIA THE SIX
YEAR IT GOES WAY BEYOND CHOKING-
I CAN TELL YOU THAT- WHEN YOU
START WHEN YOU PLAY WITH A
COMMON- TACTIC THAT HAS TO BE
USED WHEN YOU HAVE SOMEONE
THAT'S EXTREMELY VIOLENT. OF
ANIL THIS HAPPENED TO ME SO
MANY TIMES WHERE YOU HAVE A
SUSPECT YOU HANDCUFF YOU PLACED
IN A PATROL CAR AND THEIR SOUL.
ACT UP FOR LACK OF A BETTER
WORD THE KICK OUT THE WINDOWS
IN THE PATROL CAR. YOU HAVE TO
TAKE ACTION AND SO WHAT YOU
HAVE TO DO IS YOU HAVE TO PLAY
A LEG RESTRAINT. ALONG WITH THE
HAND RESTRAINT. AND WHAT
HAPPENS IN MANY INSTANCES YOU
HAVE THE SUSPECT NOW THAT
YOU'RE RESTRAINED. WHAT I
BELIEVE IS AN APPROPRIATE
RESTRAINT AND YOU PLACE THEM
BACK IN THE VEHICLE THEY
CONTINUE TO MOVE ABOUT THEY
CONTINUE TO. TRY TO SHOW THEIR-
DISAGREEMENT WITH WHAT'S
HAPPENING AND IN DOING SO
THEY'LL PUT THEMSELVES IN.
CIRCUMSTANCES ESPECIALLY WHEN
THE RESTRAINT THAT WAY THAT
LIMIT THEIR ABILITY TO BREATHE.
AND YOU HAVE THIS VERY PROBLEM
IT'S POSITIONAL ASPHYXIA AND
THAT IS NOT A TACTIC. THAT WAS
MISUSED BY THE OFFICER- AND I
DON'T KNOW. WHAT YOUR
SUGGESTION IS FOR AN
ALTERNATIVE COURSE OF ACTION
AND I'M HOPING I'M NOT GONNA BE
ABLE TO STOP THIS BILL. BUT I
HOPE WHAT YOU'LL DO IS
GENUINELY REACH OUT TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND COOPERATE WITH
THEM AND- AND TRY TO TACTICALLY
ADDRESS WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
AND BECAUSE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO ADDRESSES IT COMPLETELY
SUPPORTABLE YOU YOU WANT TO
ADDRESS. ABUSE EVERYBODY WANTS
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT WANTS THAT
BUT WE DON'T WANT IS UNINTENDED
OUTCOMES WHERE THE OFFICERS
BECOME. THE FOCUS OF ABUSE SO
WHAT WE NEED IS A BALANCED
APPROACH AND THAT'S WHAT I'M
ASKING FOR AND I HOPE THAT WE
CAN GET THAT FROM YOU. THIS IS
WENT TO VEGAS THE WAY I AND I
KNOW WHAT YOUR TENSIONS ARE.
AND YOU SAY THAT. IT WOULD
RESTRICT THE OFFICERS ABILITY
WELL. BASED ON THE VAGUENESS OF
THE WAY THIS BILL AS CURRENTLY
WORDED. IT MIGHT. AND SO THAT'S
WE GOTTA GET RID OF AND I. I
PROMISE YOU THAT IS TOO BIG
RIGHT NOW. BUT LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND ALL THE OTHER PROFESSIONALS
PLEASE WORK WITH THEM. PLEASE
MAKE THIS BETTER. SO WE CAN ALL
COME TOGETHER AND FIGHT WE WANT.
TO FIGHT AND THAT'S ABUSE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MISTER WICKS. I
THANK YOU- I THINK THE AUTHOR
IN MY SEAT MATE- FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD- APPRECIATE
YOUR WORKING ADVOCACY OF A
SUSPICIOUS SOMEONE IS FORMER
LAW ENFORCEMENT- THESE ARE
TOUGH ISSUES OBVIOUSLY THEY
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED I'M I
WOULD BE HONORED TO BE A CO
AUTHOR AND LOOK FOR TO
SUPPORTING THE BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR SIRIKA. THANK YOU.
SORRY I DON'T I JUST GROWN
FORTUNATELY LIKE- MR LACKEY I
COME FROM SOME SIMILAR
EXPERIENCES- I DID NOT WORK IN
A VERY- KIND AREA. AND I'VE HAD
THE UNFORTUNATE EXPERIENCE OF
HAVING TO TREAT PEOPLE. WHO
APPEAR TO HAVE DIED FROM THIS
OF SPEAKS VIA- WHAT THEY
THOUGHT WAS OF SIXTY UP FROM-
POSITIONAL- TYPE OF- AND-
SITUATIONS- BUT HAVE ALSO BEEN
KICKED IN THE FACE SPAT IN THE
FACE- WE'VE HAD- OFFICERS.
SEVERELY INJURED WITHOUT
OFFICER SHOT. ALL FROM PEOPLE
WHO ARE RESISTING. AND THAT'S
WHEN WE THAT'S WHEN THESE TYPE
OF SITUATIONS. GENERALLY OCCUR.
IS WHEN THERE IS VIOLENT. AND
UNPREDICTABLE- RESISTANCE TO
WHATEVER'S IN A LOT OF TIMES IN
IN THE CASES THAT I WERE ON I'M
GOING ON- I MEAN I'VE HAD
PEOPLE THAT WERE HANDCUFFED IN
THE BACK OF A POLICE CAR. AND
THEY PULL UP TO THE POLICE
STATION THEY OPEN THE DOOR AND
THE GUY'S DEAD. AND THE REASON
THE GUY'S DAD IS BECAUSE HE'S
HE- HE- WHAT RAN THROUGH A
NEIGHBORHOOD. AFTER SPEED
BALLING. AND AFTER TAKING IT
THAT MEANS YOU TOOK
METHAMPHETAMINE AT THE TIME WAS
HEROIN- MACINNES HEROIN AND
COCAINE AT THE SAME TIME-
FENTON ALL WASN'T AROUND YET
BUT THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS
NOWADAYS- D. C. P. A VERY
UNPREDICTABLE DRUG. AND NOT
YOU'VE BEEN ON A GUY WHO HAS
PC. PC PIANE- I'LL TELL YOU
PEOPLE WHO ARE FIVE FOOT SIX
AND WEIGHS A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
POUNDS- WILL TAKE SIX OFFICERS
TO HOLD SOMEBODY DOWN LIKE THAT
AND BY THE TIME THEY'RE DONE
HOLDING THEM DOWN. GUESS WHAT
THIS POSITIONAL. ASPHYXIA MAY
HAVE OCCURRED- SO IT'S LIKE
WHAT DO YOU DO I'VE SEEN PEOPLE
BREAK THEIR ARMS FROM THOSE
THINGS. SO FOR ME YOU KNOW
WE'RE TAKING AWAY A LOT OF
TOOLS THE POLICE OFFICERS WIND
UP USING NOT BECAUSE THEY WANT
TO. IT'S BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO
THEY HAVE TO DO IT TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES THE PEOPLE AROUND
THEM OR OTHERS AND THAT'S MY
CONCERN IS THAT WE'RE REALLY
GETTING AWAY FROM- ALLOWING
POLICE OFFICERS TO TRY TO USE
LESS THAN THAN LETHAL FORCES.
ALTHOUGH IT IS SOMETIMES THE
COMBINATION DOESN'T ALLOW THAT
TO HAPPEN. AND OF DRUG USE AND-
A RESTRAINT- AND SO YOU KNOW
THAT IT'S THOSE TYPE INCIDENT
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO DEAL
WITH IT'S DIFFICULT FOR US-
IT'S DIFFICULT FOR THE POLICE
OFFICERS. AND YOU KNOW IT JUST
VERY LIKE I SAID IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT FOR. FOR US TO GET A
GRASP ON WHERE THAT LITTLE
MIDDLE GROUND IS THAT DOESN'T
TAKE AWAY- THEIR ABILITY TO
DEFEND THEMSELVES AND DEFEND
OTHER PEOPLE. AND AT THE SAME
TIME TRYING TO PROTECT THE
PERSON THAT IS OUT OF CONTROL.
AND SO YEAH THAT'S IT THAT'S MY
DIFFICULTY WITH DAYS AND YOU'LL
HEAR THAT YEAH I'M NOT GONNA
KEEP REPEATING ON ALL THESE
DIFFERENT. TYPES OF BILLS LIKE
THIS. BUT YOU KNOW THAT SOME OF
MY EXPERIENCE AND- IN. YOU KNOW
SO THAT YOU KNOW THAT'S A
DIFFERENT LENS THAT I LOOK AT
THAT THROUGH FROM A LOT OF
OTHER PEOPLE WHO HEAR ABOUT IT
BUT- HAVEN'T ACTUALLY SEEN IT.
SO THANK. YOU THANK YOU MR
CLARK. OUR TWO THINGS FIRST I
IN TERMS SAID YOU TO COMMITTEE.
I SEE WHICH CHECK WHAT YOU TOOK
WAS THE AMENDMENTS. SUGGESTED
BY THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS
SEPARATE. YES YEAH WHETHER ANY
OTHER MEMBERS WHO TOOK. AND NOT
AS OF NOT AS OF YET YOU'RE
GOING TO BE WORKING WITH ONE
FIVE TIMES YES- PLEASE ADD ME
AS A CO AUTHOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU AND SEE YOU
KNOW WHAT. THANK YOU. COMMENTS-
YOU MAY CLOSE YOUR BOTH MY
CLOTHES WERE HI EVERYONE THANK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
BUNDY ONE YEAH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- I'VE CERTAINLY LISTENED
ATTENTIVELY- TO MY COLLEAGUES
CONCERNED LET ME ASSURE YOU-
ONE I HAVE WAS A POLICE OFFICER
MORE THAN JUST A YEAR- IN THE
CITY OF MAY WORK- AND WE HADTO
AFFECT THE NUMBER OF ARRESTS
AND WE GOT INTO SOME SCUFFLES
AT THE SAME AT THE TIME. WHILE
ME PERFORMING MY JOB
RESPONSIBILITY- TO- I WILL AND
COMMIT TO AS I DEMONSTRATED
WITH ELEVEN NINETY SIX MY
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHY IS THAT
IMPORTANT WHAT GLAD U. S. WE
HAVE TO GET A RIGHT. I WANT TO
GET IT RIGHT THE FIRST TIME. I
WANNA GET THIS RIGHT. RIGHT
NOW. AND SO WE HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH EVERY
ANYBODY. IN THIS SPACE IN ORDER
TO GET A RIDE. BECAUSE GUESS
WHAT. I WANT TO MAKE SURE WHEN
I WAS IN UNIFORM. THAT MYERS
WAS ABLE TO GO HOME. SAFELY
JUST LIKE EVERY MAN WOMAN WHO'S
IN UNIFORM WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THOSE INDIVIDUALS GET HOME SAFE
TO THEIR LOVED ONES. AT THE
SAME TIME WE WANT TO MAKE SURE.
THAT IF THE OFFICER OR ANY LAW
ENFORCEMENT COME IN CONTACT
WITH INDIVIDUAL WHO HAS AN
EFFECT ARRESTS. THAT THE PERSON
WHO THEIR AFFECTED ARREST ON.
THEIR OXYGEN IS NOT RESTRICTED.
THAT'S ALL WE'RE SAYING HERE
WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT. TALK ABOUT
ANYTHING ELSE WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY CAN GO TO JAIL
BE ARRAIGNED- YOU KNOW BE TRIED
BY THEIR A JUROR THAT PEERS.
BUT WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE ARE SOME BAD OUT. IN A
PROFESSION THAT ARE. AND WE
CANNOT EVERY WITH THE SAME
BRUSH BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE REAL WIENER
NOW IS THAT PEOPLE WANT TO CAN.
AND TRANSPARENCY AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT ANGELO CAN'T OR
THERE'S NO OTHER CA WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THERE'S NO OTHER
GEORGE FLOYD IN CALIFORNIA. AND
I BELIEVE THIS IS A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION AND IT OPENS
THE DOOR FOR REAL CONVERSATION
AND I'M WILLING TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
BUT I VOTE THANK YOU. MR BONTA.
THIS IS THE RIGHT THING. BOB
BUT YEAH. THANK YOU- END UP AND
I THINK I HEARD FROM FROM YOU
AND MR LACKEY- AND I KNOW I
HEARD COMMUNITY WANT TO MAKE
SURE- LAW ENFORCEMENT IS A
LITTLE UNUSUAL ELOQUENTLY PUT
IT GET THEIR **** ON AND SO WE
WANT BOTH SIDES TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THAT AND I THINK YOU
EARNESTLY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT HAPPENS THAT IS A CONCERN
OF OUR COLLEAGUES FROM ACROSS
THE AISLE YES AND I THINK YOU
YOU YOU MAY EVEN HAVE. THE
EXPERTISE OBVIOUSLY MORE THAN I
DO. IN AN AND ARREST SITUATION
WHERE YOU HAVE TO- REAL LIFE IS
IN. JEOPARDY AND- AS WE GREW UP.
IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD- YOU YOU DO
EVERYTHING YOU CAN TO STAY
ALIVE AND SO I THINK THIS MAY
BE NEED MORE TRAINING MORE
DISCUSSION THERE MAY BE OTHER
METHODOLOGIES WE CAN USE BUT I
THINK YOU'RE OPEN TO. EVEN
TALKING WITH MR LACKEY- GOOD
FROM LANCASTER WHO I BELIEVE
USED TO DO TRADING- WHEN HE-
DOES A COUPLE YEARS AGO BECAUSE
HE'S JUST A YOUNG GUY AND HE HE
CAN SHOW YOUR TICKET TO ABOUT
HOW TO. MAKE SURE EVERYONE GOES
HOME AFTER. IN AND ARREST SILVA
I THINK WE'RE IN A GOOD PLACE
ARE RECOMMENDED AND I BECAUSE I
HAVE FAITH. U. M. BY IN MY BY
SHARED IT WE CAN WE CAN TALK TO
SIR ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU.
COLORADO AN EIGHTY FOUR NINETY
BY SEVEN MEMBER GIPSON THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER BY CHANCE THERE IRAQI NO
LACKING NO BARRICADE HAND THERE
CAN I WORK. COURT I SAN DIEGO
SAN DIEGO THANK C. R. TWO C. R.
TEN NO WAY X. LI. LI I. THE
MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH COMMISSION CHAIRMAN. MR
LOW. A. B. FOURTEENTH. SEVENTY
FIVE. LAW ENFORCEMENT SOCIAL
MEDIA WE COULD YOU COULD JUST
DATE WITH JUST DONE YOU WHEN
YOU WERE HERE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH PRESSURE MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES. YES WE
DO. ONCE I GET THAT PAPER
PLEASE HAVE. THAT'S THE BY NOON
YES ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION.
AND WE'RE NOT SURE ABOUT YOUR
SUPPORT WITH THIS BUT I DON'T
BELIEVE YOU NEED THAT SECOND
WITNESS BUT GO AHEAD. ESTEBAN
NEWNESS CERN. YES SIR. TEN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS ESTEBAN UNIONS I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF ADVOCACY AND
COMMUNITY ORGANIZING WITH ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION. HE WORKS
TO END MASS INCARCERATION IN
CALIFORNIA. CHARDONNAYS ARE
SAFE HEALTHY AND WHOLE. JIM
POWERS FORMING CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED PEOPLE TO DRIVE UP
INVITING A SUPPORT NETWORK
COMPREHENSIVE REENTRY SERVICES.
AND OPPORTUNITIES TO ADVOCATE
FOR POLICY CHANGE. FOR
GRASSROOTS ADVOCACY WE ARE
DEDICATED TO TRANSFORMING THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM TO BE
MORE JUST AND EQUITABLE. FOR
ALL PEOPLE AND MANY OF YOU KNOW
I'M FORMERLY INCARCERATED WHAT
MANY DON'T KNOW IS THAT I HAD
THREE CODEFENDANTS TOMB WHO TWO
OF WHOM NEVER WENT TO PRISON
BUT YOU MAY NOT HAVE KNOWN
BECAUSE THEIR MUGSHOTS DOT
JULIE MADE THE NEWS. OUR SYSTEM
DOES LITTLE TO NOTHING TO
PRESERVE ANYONE SENATE SETS
MUGSHOT POSTING ON SOCIAL MEDIA
IS JUST ANOTHER INSTANCE OF HOW
WE DEMONISE SHANE AND
OSTRACIZED INDIVIDUALS QUITE
YET TO BE FOUND GUILTY OF
ANYTHING. I WANT TO SPEAK TO BE
A REPUTABLE DAMAGES. A MUG SHOT
POSTED ONLINE CAN HAVE. MARCH
THERE ARE DAMAGES TO PERSON. I
WORKING IN IT BY ANY MEANS SO I
WON'T PRETEND TO TELL YOU THE I
DIDN'T DESERVE. THE HARDSHIPS
THAT LAW AHEAD. BUT IT WAS MY
PICTURE MY- ASSOCIATED THE
MURDER. BUT IT'S NOT THE
DAMAGES DONE ON TO ME THAT
COMPELLED ME TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY BUT THE DAMAGES THAT WERE
DONE TO MY FAMILY. MY BROTHER
ELEVEN YEARS YOUNGER WITH NINE
YEARS OLD AT THE TIME. THE
STORY OF HIM ATTENDING SCHOOL
BEEN RIDICULE BY CLASSMATES AND
OTHERS BECAUSE TO ME. SHOWED ME
TO MY CORE TO THIS DAY. MY
MOTHER A LONG TIME THERE'S
SLIPPED INTO A DEPRESSION IN
THE CATASTROPHE I'D PUT MYSELF
IN. EVERYWHERE SHE TURNED
PEOPLE RECOGNIZED HER. AND SOME
CREATIVE USES OF LANGUAGE TO
BELITTLE AND DEMEAN HER AS THE
MOTHER. OF WHAT I HAD BEEN
ACCUSED OF. MY SISTER TWO YEARS
YOUNGER. FOUND HERSELF IN
CONSTANT DISARRAY AS SHE TRIED
TO DEFEND HER BROTHER'S NAME
AND CHARACTER. ANCIENT GREEKS
BECAME SO OVERWHELMING SHE FELL
VICTIM TO DRUGS WE HAVE HAD SO
MANY SUICIDE ATTEMPTS I'VE LOST
COUNT. MY FATHER MY FATHER HAD
BEEN SPENT ON. GOLD CHAINS AND
THE TRIAL WAS STILL YET TO COME.
A MUG SHOT REPRESENTS THE
LOWEST MOMENT IN SOMEONE'S LIFE
POSTED MUGSHOT ON SOCIAL MEDIA
DOES NOTHING TO HELP THE CASE
PROGRESS IN ANY DIRECTION OTHER
THAN HUMILIATING AND SHAMING
PEOPLE. APRIL SIXTEENTH MARCH
MY FIVE YEARS OF BEING HOME I
DEVOTED MY LIFE TO THIS WORK
YET NO MATTER HOW MUCH COULD I
DO THE IMAGERY OF MY MUGSHOT
WILL FOREVER BE BRANDED IN THE
MINDS AND HEARTS OF PEOPLE WHO
ALWAYS JUDGMENT. YET NEVER KNOW
ME. WE MUST REMEMBER AND DO ALL
THAT WE CAN TO PRESERVE THE
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE AND
RECOGNIZED. IN THE BURDEN HARM
CAUSED BY DEMONIZING PEOPLE. IT
IS FOR THESE REASONS. I ARGUED
ABOUT IN SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- IT DID DID YOU HAVE A
SECOND WITNESS I BELIEVE WE
ALSO HAVE A REPRESENTATIVE
BRIEFLY- FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE. IF
THERE SHOULD BE AN ACCURATE ARM
ALL. I WILL BE FAST- I JUST
WANTED TO ADD WERE HAPPY TO BE
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
TODAY WHICH EXTEND TIME OF OUR
LOCAL ADVOCACY BUT WE GET ALONG
SIDE SAN FRANCISCO POLICE
DEPARTMENT CHIEF SCOTT WHOSE
LEADERSHIP ON THE ISSUE IS
GREATLY APPRECIATED. AND REALLY
JUST ADDS ESTEBAN STORY THAT.
INDISCRIMINATELY SHARING
MUGSHOTS ONLINE PLAYS INTO THE
FEARMONGERING AND
MISINFORMATION CAMPAIGNS BECOME
RAMPANT ON SOCIAL MEDIA AND THE
INTERNET AND IMPETUOUS RACISM
BECAUSE BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE
ARE ARRESTED AT GROSSLY
DISPROPORTIONATE RATES. ARE
USUALLY THE ONES IN THE MUGSHOT
WHETHER THEY'RE GUILTY OR
INNOCENT IN THE NEAR CONSTANT
ONSLAUGHT OF BLACK AND BROWN
FACES IN JAIL JUMPSUIT AND
TEACHERS AND REINFORCES THE
RACE OF THE LEAST OF THEIR
SCARY DANGEROUS AND NEED TO BE
LOCKED IN CAGES. SO FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE BUT NOT A PATHWAY.
FORWARD AND I URGE YOU TO VOTE
HI. THANK YOU. BUT THERE THERE
ANY WITNESS IN THE HEARING ROOM
SEEN NONE ARE IN TO SEE ON.
VIDEO SCREEN SEEN NONE-
OPERATOR MAY OPEN UP FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OF MR
LOW'S BILL AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE ON THE TELEPHONE. YOU
AREN'T SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE NOW AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND
THEN ZERO PURE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE OF ONE EIGHTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. KATHY
SHARPER ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT TO A LINE OF NINETY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANKS VERY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF ONE THIRTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. DANIEL GUTIERREZ
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
WITH THE SUPPORT OF COMMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
OPTIMUM WHAT ONE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT OF A LINE OF ONE
SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
SCRAGGLY THOUSAND ISSUE JUSTICE
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO LINE A
ONE EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY A POLAND CALLING ON BEHALF
OF MYSELF IN STRONG SUPPORT AT
EIGHTY FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU IN ORDER ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I SEE
NONE. BUT THE LINE IS OPEN ARE
THERE ANY. WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. TO TESTIFY C. NINE
GOING TO THE HEARING ROOM DON'T
SEE ANY WITNESSES OPPOSITION TO
VIDEO CONFERENCE BOARD AND WILL
STILL WILL OPEN IT UP COLLIDE
FOR ANYONE THAT'S ON THE
TELEPHONE WITNESSES UP IN
OPPOSITION. NAME AN
ORGANIZATION. GIVEN OPPOSITION
OF AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE ZERO UP IN OPPOSITION OF AB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE. MISTER
TERRY OF NO OPPOSITION IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU BRING ME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE MR LEE
AND MR LACKEY. HOW I THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD IS VERY IMPORTANT AND
AS SOME OF THE- WHEN THIS IS A
TEST WITNESSES ATTESTED TO YOU
KNOW SOCIAL MEDIA CAN BE USED
AS A TOOL TO UPHOLD OUR SYSTEMS
RACISM PERPETUATE THESE
STEREOTYPES- BUT IN THAT'S WHAT
I TWO QUESTIONS WHEN AS WE NEED
HOUSES. SO IN THE GREENHOUSES
IT'S STATES WE SHOULD CONSIDER
MOVING THE PROOF REQUIREMENT
ALTOGETHER AND SIMPLY MANDATE
THE POLICE AGENCY REMOVE IT IF
REQUESTED- FOREIGN NONVIOLENCE
IT IN ARE YOU. OPEN TO AMENDING
THAT PART OF THE BILL. I'M
HAPPY TO FOR THE DAY
CONVERSATIONS AROUND THAT TO
BEST OF NOT CURRENTLY IN THIS
COMMITTEE BUT- CERTAINLY OPEN
TO FURTHER DISCUSSIONS AROUND
THE- IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES AS-
REFLECTED THE COMING OUNCES.
OKAY AND ALSO MY SECOND
QUESTION IS. IN THE SAME SPIRIT
OF- MAKING SURE IT'S A
PERPETUATING PEOPLES- YOU.
GUILTY THIS BEFORE THEY'RE
BEING TRIED WOULD YOU ALSO BE
OPEN TO REMOVING MUGSHOTS OF
ALL PEOPLE ARRESTED ALL CRIMES.
NOT CURRENTLY AS YOU KNOW THAT
IS REFLECTED IN THE BILL THEIR
NUMBER OF MECHANISMS THAT STILL
ALLOW FOR OF THOSE- TO BEST TO-
HAVE THE TYPE OF PROTECTION IN
MECHANISM PLACE. FOR THE
PROTECTIONS OF THE INDIVIDUAL
OF ALSO ENSURING THAT IT DOES
RISE TO LEVEL OF PUBLIC FORM
THAT THERE IS ALSO. OF THE
MECHANISM TO HELP ADDRESS THAT
THOSE ISSUES OF ALL TO BUT
UNLESS HAPPY TO HAVE FOR THE
CONVERSATIONS SHOULD LEAVE THIS
COMMITTEE I GET TO THE FLOOR
CERTAINLY I WOULD LIKE THAT
KEEP HAVING THOSE CONVERSATIONS
AS I DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
MAKE SURE PROTECTING THE
INNOCENCE OF A LOT OF PEOPLE
AND- OF COURSE- NOT HOLDING THE
STEREOTYPES. I ALSO SOME
PRIVACY COMMITTEE SO WOULD LOVE
TO- I LIKE SUPPORT THE BILL BUT
ALSO LIKE TO SEE A LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR LACKEY.
YEAH CLEARLY HAVE SUPPORTED OF
YOUR BILL HERE I JUST WONDER
WHY THE RETROACTIVITY. WHY THE
RETROACTIVITY IN TERMS OF THE
APPLICATION SPECIFICALLY YES
YES WELL I THINK AND WE WON'T
WANT TO BEST ENSURE THAT THE
SPIRIT OF THE INTENT- OR TRYING
TO TACKLE HERE RIGHT NOW- INTO.
THERE'S NO CONSISTENCY WITH
RESPECT TO LOCAL AGENCIES AND
SO THAT'S WHY ONE A UNIFORM
APPROACH TO IT- AND BEST A
TACKLING TACKLING THE ISSUE
SPECIFICALLY ON THE A
LOCALITIES SO I THINK THERE'S
THE CHALLENGES EXIST THAT FOR
THEIR EXAMPLE THIS CAME
SPECIFIC FROM SAN FRANCISCO. WE
WANT TO BEST UTILIZE SOME OF
THOSE BEST PRACTICES. THANK YOU
SHE NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS YOU MAY CLOSE MISSILE
ASPECTS WE ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD- CHURCH
RECOMMENDED I RECALLED ABOUT.
THE BILL'S IMPROPERLY MOVED AND
SECONDED ON AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE I SUMMONED LOW THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE PRIVACY AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER- JONES SAWYER
IRAQI. LACKEY ATTY BARRICADE
HAND. CORK BY CORK I SANTIAGO.
C. R. TELL NOBODY THE R. TEN
NOT VOTING WICKS. LI LI I. THE
MEASURES ARE CALLED NEEDS ONE
MORE THANK YOU. NEXT NEXT UP IS
I HAVE OTHER MISTER MCCARTY
CLOSE RECORDED HASN'T ANSWERED
JUST. STONE. OKAY AND I THINK
SPARKY AND SPEAKING OF.
VISITING WILL BE HERE. MISTER
IF THIS BAR KAY AND I BELIEVE
THIS SPEAKING FOR KING AT HER
TWO BILLS. WE COULD DO THREE AT
ONE TIME IS MADE BY R. K. HAD
SHOWED UP. THIS IS DON HOW ARE
YOU DOING. YOU'RE UP NEXT. THE
FACT. A. B. SEVEN ONE SEVEN
STONE PRISONERS IDENTIFICATION
CARDS THE- CAN FIRST RESEARCHER
LET ME. SAY HOW HOW SHE GRINNED
I WAS TO BE TEASING YOU THIS
MORNING HE WAS VERY HEARING. I
ACTUALLY THOUGHT I WAS GOING TO
MEET YOUR COMMITTEE LATER ON
THIS DAY. SILLY ME- WELL. THANK
YOU AB SEVEN ONE SEVEN IS A
CONTINUATION OF WHAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING TO ENSURE THAT WOULD
PEOPLE. COME OUT OF PRISON.
THAT THEY HAVE A INAPPROPRIATE
ID. WE DID THE CAL ID BILL THE
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO AND AS IT
TURNS OUT ONLY ABOUT. 30% OF
PEOPLE COMING OUT OF
INCARCERATION HAVE ACCESS TO
THE ID'S FOR NUMBER REASONS IN
THE AND THIS IS. A STEP THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO TAKE TO IMPROVE
THAT NUMBER BECAUSE NOT HAVING
AN ID IS A SIGNIFICANT
IMPEDIMENT. TO PEOPLE SUCCESS
REDUCING RECIDIVISM. BEING ABLE
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY COME
INTO SOCIETY. DO THE THINGS
THAT THEY NEED TO DO IN ORDER
TO RECOVER REHABILITATE AND-
NAT RECEIPT OF A- SO. WE'RE
WORKING ON A NUMBER OF THINGS
IN AND LOOKING AT THE ANALYSIS
I THINK. THAT THERE'S JUST SOME
SOME POINTS I'D LIKE TO MAKE-
APPRECIATE THAT THE IN DEPTH
ANALYSIS IN THE WORK THAT YOUR
COMPANY IS DONE WITH US OVER
THE YEARS ON THIS. BUT WE'RE
NOT EXPECTING PEOPLE TO TAKE
DRIVER'S TESTS WHILE THEY'RE ON
THE INSIDE THAT THAT IS NOT
LEAVE EXEMPTED THAT DRIVER'S
TEST. AND I DO UNDERSTAND THE
POINTS ABOUT. CMV NOT BEING
ABLE TO MAIL. THE ID TO AN
INDIVIDUAL AND THAT'S CURRENTLY
THE SITUATION NOW UNDER THE
KELLY D. PROGRAM. IS CITIES
HERE HOLD ON TO THOSE ID'S.
UNTIL RELEASE BUT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO HERE IS MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE FACILITATING. GETTING
THAT WORK DONE. GETTING THAT ID
AVAILABLE WHATEVER BACKGROUND
INFORMATION THOSE INDIVIDUALS
NEED TO. GET THAT IF YOU PUT IN
PLACE AND THEN WHEN THEY WERE
LEAVING HAVE THAT ID. WHICH
CONNECT THEM TO SERVICES GIVES
THEM THE ABILITY TO DO THE
PROGRAMMING. YEAH HOUSING AND
MAKE THE CONNECTIONS IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT THEY HAVE
SOMETIMES IT SO I APPRECIATE
THE WORK THAT THIS COMMITTEES
DONE WITH US OVER THE YEARS
WORKING FOR WORK WITH CDC ARE
ON THIS. AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
THAT WE MEET WITH THEIR
STANDARD AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I WON'T. THANK YOU UP
IN YOUR WITNESSES. OUR. I THINK
CHERYL WARD FROM HOUSING AND
BENEFITS COORDINATOR FOR A NEW
WAY AND THEN WELCOME WINDOW FOR
A COMMUNITY ORGANIZER ANOTHER
WAY OF LIFE FOR REENTRY THANK
YOU WHENEVER YOU'RE READY MISS
WARD ARE. THE LONDON. HELLO MY
NAME IS CHERYL WARD I AM
HONORED TO SPEAK TO YOU TODAY
AT THE I'M A HOUSING BENEFITS
COORDINATOR AND IN THE WAY OF
LIFE PROJECT AND I'M SPEAKING.
FOR EIGHTY SEVEN SEVENTEEN I
ASSIST WOMEN RETURNING TO THE
COMMUNITY AFTER HAMMOCKS ARE
CHEN SAID TWENTY TO THIRTY AND
EVEN FORTY YEARS IN THE MARKET
RATIONS TO SECURE NEEDED
DOCUMENTS MANY WOMEN COMES ON
FOR TRADE INS BUT- APPOINTED ID
AND SOME COME WITH NO IDEA AT
ALL AND THEN THE WORLD WE LIVE
IN TODAY. WITHOUT PROPER ID YOU
DON'T GET FAR AND WHILE
MASTERCARD IS ACCEPTED ALMOST
EVERYWHERE REGION I DO NEED IS
NOT ACCEPTED ANYWHERE IN ORDER
TO OBTAIN A BIRTH CERTIFICATE
AND LYFT ANGELES COUNTY YOU
HAVE BEEN SENDING IN A BIRTH
CERTIFICATE APPLICATION AND YOU
HAVE IT HAS TO BE NOTARIZED.
THE NOTARY ASK FOR CALIFORNIA
ID AND WON'T ACCEPT PRISON ID
SO NO ARE GREEN A BIRTH
CERTIFICATE IS NINE AM BE
ONLINE ACCOUNTS CANNOT BE
CREATED AND IT DOESN'T ACCEPT
PRISON ID VERIFICATION OF
IDENTITY SO WE'RE FORCED TO
PHYSICALLY GO TO THE DMV IN
ORDER TO APPLY FOR CALIFORNIA
IDEA LIKE. THEY TELL US THAT
YOU MUST HAVE A BIRTH
CERTIFICATE WE TELL THEM WE
ALREADY TRIED TO ORDER IT AND
CANNOT DEAL THE DMV WON'T
ACCEPT THE PRISON ID FOR
PURPOSES OF IDENTIFICATION TO
ORDER REPLACEMENT THOSE
SECURITY GUARD ONLINE WHEN
LET'S CREATE AN ACCOUNT YOU
CAN'T HOWEVER BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T VERIFY YOU WITH PRAISE
AND ID YOU MUST MAIL THE
APPLICATION WHEN AN ORIGINAL ID
WHICH YOU DON'T HAVE BECAUSE
YOU ONLY HAMPER THE NIGHT THE
AND THEY DIDN'T ACCEPT IT.
THESE DOCUMENTS ARE VITAL TO A
PERSON'S ABILITY TO OBTAIN FOOD
AT THIS HOUSING DRUG TREATMENT
AND EMPLOYMENT YES THE NAME A
FEW THERE ARE MANY IN OUR
COMMUNITY WE CAN'T SERVE
BECAUSE OF OUR CAPACITY
CONSTRAINTS WE ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT EIGHTY SEVEN SEVENTEEN
BECAUSE MORE EIGHT OUR
COMMUNITY BY MAKING THE
NECESSARY. DOCUMENTS FOR
SERVICES READ WILLIAM. MAKING
EASY FOR THE ENTIRE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND CAN. THANK
YOU NEXT- HELLO MY NAME IS NOT
ON AND I AM LOOKING AT OREGON
FOR NEW WE HAVE A RANCHO
PROJECT. IN MY ROOM I HAVE THE
PRE OF BURKE WITH MY OWN
COMMUNITY OF SOUTH CENTRAL LOS
ANGELES MY ROLE IS TO HELP LINK
ANY FORMALLY INCARCERATED
PERSON AND THEIR FAMILIES WITH
SERVICES AND ADVOCACY EFFORTS I
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND OUR LAWS
HAVE CREATED BOTH INTENTIONAL
AND UNINTENTIONAL BARRIERS TO
INDIVIDUALS ABILITY TO SURPASS
THEIR CONVICTION. IN CALIFORNIA
ALONE THERE ARE OVER FORTY
EIGHT HUNDRED LEGAL BARRIERS TO
RE ENTRY WE BELIEVE THAT ONCE A
PERSON HAS DONE THEIR TIME THEN
THEY HAVE SERVED THEIR CRIME
THE ISSUE OF AIDID'S LICENSES
AND CERTIFICATES HAS BEEN OUR
PRIORITY FOR MANY YEARS THESE
DOCUMENTS HAVE ACTED AS A
PRIMARY BARRIER. TO ALL
INDIVIDUALS RE ENTERING SOCIETY.
I MISSED JEREMY THESE. ARE FOR
MUCH NEEDED SERVICES. THAT
OFTEN SERVICE CONDITIONS FOR AT
LEAST. IN SOME CASES THE LACK
OF THESE DOCUMENTS HAVE LED
PEOPLE TO RE OFFEND. NO ONE
WANTS TO RETURN TO
INCARCERATIONS BUT MANY TOO.
MANY TIMES BECAUSE OF
COMPLICATIONS CREATED BY THESE
POLICY. I HAVE HAD COUNTLESS
COMMUNITY MEMBERS CALL ME IN
TEARS OUT OF FEAR THAT THEY
MIGHT HAVE TO GO BACK BECAUSE
THEY'RE UNABLE TO ATTAIN IT
NEATLY IF NECESSARY SERVICES.
MOST OF THE TIME IT'S BECAUSE
OF THE LACK OF DOCUMENTATION.
WE ASK YOU TO SUPPORT EIGHTY
SEVEN SEVENTEEN WITH A YES VOTE
AT IT WOULD ALLOW INDIVIDUALS
BEING RELEASED THE ABILITY TO
ACTIVELY SEEK HELP WITHOUT
DELAY AND ALLOW THEM AND THEIR
FAMILIES TO PASS THEIR
CONVICTIONS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION. YES BUT
BUT ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES AND THE IN THE
CHAMBER. I KNOW WITNESSES ON
THE VIDEO SCREEN. EVERY ANY ANY
WITNESSES A SUPPORT ON THE
TELEPHONE. YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF AB ONE SEVEN ONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE OF ONE TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M GAIL
STEWART CALLING ON BEHALF OF
SUMMER STEPHAN DISTRICT
ATTORNEY IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY WE
ARE A PROUD CO SPONSOR OF AB
SEVEN ONE SEVEN I AM ALSO HERE
ON BEHALF OF ALAMEDA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY. NANCY
O'MALLEY WHO SUPPORT A. B.
SEVEN ONE SEVEN BOTH OFFICES
URGE YOUR IDEA TODAY THANK YOU.
Q. MY NEXT LOCAL LINE OF ONE
NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD EVENING CHAIR MEMBERS PER
THOUGHT HE TALK ON BEHALF OF
THE CENTER FOR EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO
LINE OF NINETY SIX AIRLINES
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MARCO
GEORGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MEXICO ON A ONE
THIRTY ONE THEIR LINES OPEN.
ONE ONE THREE ONE YOUR LINES
OPEN. THIS RAIN SHERMAN WITH
THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
LOCATION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINEOF ONE THIRTY FOUR
YEAR LINES OPEN. DANIEL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF ONE
NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
KATHY SURE FOR ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF TO ALL ONE YOUR
LINES OPEN. UNDER WATER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MEXICO LINE OF ONE SIXTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN SHE-
GREGORY CANAL WITH INITIATE
JUSTICE STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. SH THANK YOU MEXICO ON A
ONE NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SH HI THIS IS SEAN
ROWLAND WITHOUT ROAD PRISON
PROJECT CO SPONSOR IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT WELL ON
A ONE NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS WE ARE
GOING TO TALK ABOUT MY
COMMUNITY MEMBER AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT YES OF EIGHTY
FOUR NINETY. THANK YOU IN ORDER
LINE OF TWO HUNDRED YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. DRPARTY THOUGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION IN. PRODUCTS
COSPONSORING STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE A ONE
NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ANKARA BY MOM HAPPENED THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF TWO OR THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS
IS JAMIE POPPER BUT I'M FROM
WRITTEN REBOUND I AM A PRO
KHALISTAN TERROR AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
OKAY THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY-
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. TODAY.
OKAY CAN EIGHTY ANTI OPERATOR
CAN WE SEE IF WE HAVE ANYBODY
ONLINE THAT'S A ONE DIRECTION
PRESS OPPOSITION. GIVEN
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVEN ONE
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN FEAR OF
YOU IN OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE
NO OPPOSITION QUEUE AT THIS
TIME MISTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DO WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION IN
THE ROOM. IN THE CONFERENCE
ROOM. OKAY DO WE HAVE ANY
COMMENTS FROM- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS GLADNESS
YOU SEE ART OF. SO ON THE
DRIVER'S LICENSE AND SAYS
THEY'RE NOT GIVING OUT THEY'RE
NOT DOING ON BEHIND THE WHEEL
TASKS. HOW DO WE KNOW THAT
THESE PEOPLE CAN DRIVE. THESE
ARE REPLACEMENT DRIVERS
LICENSES SO THEY'VE ALREADY
DONE THAT AND IF NOT THEY'LL
GET A CALIFORNIA IDEA IF
THEY'RE QUALIFIED TO GET A
CALIFORNIA ID AND WHAT'S TO
STOP THE DMV AND THE CDC ARE
FROM GETTING TOGETHER ON A
PROGRAM DOESN'T REQUIRE A LOT.
FOR THE DMV JUST GOES IN AND.
AND PREPARES PEOPLE THAT ARE
BEING RELEASED. BY ENSURING
THAT THEY HAVE THE DMV WE WE'VE
WE'VE HAD GREAT SUCCESS WORKING
WITH CDC ARE ON THIS PROGRAM
LESS WITH DMB. RIGHT I THINK
THE- KEY IS TO STRENGTHEN OUR
DIEM BE A LITTLE BIT. I HATE TO
HAVE TO GET ARRESTED TO BE ABLE
TO GET MY LICENSE. THE IN
DEPTH. AND SOMETIMES I KNOW-
DEALING WITH THE DMV YOU FEEL
LIKE THAT MIGHT BE THE BETTER
ROUTE. SO MAKING. YEAH. SURE
ANY OTHER COMMENTS. HI I'M I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT THAT
APPEARS TO BE THE CALIFORNIA
LAW DOES NOT ALLOW FOR AN
OFFICIAL STATE ID CARD TO BE
ISSUED INDIVIDUALS NOT LEGALLY
PRESENT HERE. AND IT WOULD
THEIR LOGICALLY MEAN BY DEFAULT
AND UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS
MUST BE ISSUED AN AB SIXTY
DRIVER'S LICENSE PLATE RELEASED
FROM CUSTODY UNDER THE BILL.
WHERE MY WRONG THERE NO NO
THAT'S NOT THE CASE THIS IS IF
ELIGIBLE. SO THEY'RE NOT GOING
TO BE ISSUED A DRIVER'S LICENSE
IF THEY DON'T QUALIFY FOR
DRIVER'S LICENSE BUT IF THEY'RE
GETTING A REPLACEMENT OR
DUPLICATE. AND THE OTHER PART
PART OF THIS IS THAT IT'S
ASKING CD'S HERE TO HELP THESE
PEOPLE GET THEIR DOCUMENTS IN
ORDER SO THAT THEY IF THEY
CAN'T GET CALIFORNIA ID OR
DRIVER'S LICENSE OR GET THAT
SETTLED. ON THE WAY OUT THAT
THEY'LL THEN BE ABLE TO DO THAT
EXPEDITIOUSLY ONCE THEY DO GET
OUT. IF THEY'RE NOT ELIGIBLE
FOR PARTICULAR DOCUMENT. ONE
WILL NOT BE ISSUED SHOW THEM
WHAT KIND OF I. D. WOULD- AND
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS BE
ISSUED THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO THE
DRIVER'S LICENSE IF THEY
OTHERWISE QUALIFY. I'M SORRY.
I'M NOT FOLLOWING YOU HERE IF
THEY DON'T HAVE A DRIVER'S
LICENSE. AND THEN THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO GET. OKAY THEN WHAT
KIND OF IDEA THEY'RE GOING TO
GET THERE AND THEY MAY NOT GET
ANY ID BUT WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IS THEN GET CITIES HERE TO
HELP THEM WITH WHATEVER
DOCUMENTATION THEY- DO NEED TO
THE EXTENT THAT THAT'S
FEASIBLE. SO THAT WHEN THEY DO
GET OUT THE THEY COULD HAVE.
TAKEN TO APPLY. AND GET AN IDEA.
SO THIS IS THIS IS GETTING
THOSE WHO ARE ELIGIBLE ID'S OR
DRIVER'S LICENSES. AND THIS IS
TRYING TO GET. HELP TO GET
DOCUMENTS IN ORDER TO THE
EXTENT POSSIBLE SO THAT WHEN
THEY DO GET OUT IF THEY'RE NOT
ABLE TO GET ONE. THAT THEY
WOULD BE ABLE TO APPLY
APPROPRIATELY ONCE THEY'RE OUT
OF THE COMMUNITY. YEAH THE
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL. SAVES TO
SEND A CONFUSING MESSAGE OF
FACTORS I THINK THAT WAS EVEN.
IT UP IN THE ASSESSMENT AS A
CONFUSING POINT- BY THIS
COMMITTEE AND SO BECAUSE OF THE
LACK OF CLARITY I MEAN I AS IT
STANDS RIGHT NOW I CAN'T
SUPPORT. ISSUING A DOCUMENT TO
SOMEBODY BECAUSE I'M AFRAID
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IS THE AB
SIXTY ELEMENT WOULD BE PURSUED.
WHICH I'D I WOULDN'T BE
COMPLETELY OPPOSED TO AS LONG
AS THEY HAD THE DRIVING-
MECHANISM UNDERTAKEN WHERE THEY
ACTUALLY CAN DEMONSTRATE THAT
THEY HAVE DRIVING ABILITY- THIS
IS JUST A VERY CONFUSING.
CIRCUMSTANCE AND HOW WOULD AND
HOW IT ADDRESSES UNDOCUMENTED
PEOPLE. THAT THAT'S MY THE
OTHERS ARE VERY CLEAR AND I
THINK IT'S EVEN NOBLE. BUT THE
REST OF IT THIS LACK OF CARITY
ON THIS ISSUE MAKES ME VERY
UNEASY- OKAY I ACTUALLY THINK
IT'S FAIRLY STRAIGHTFORWARD
BECAUSE THIS IS ALL. WHAT
SOMEBODY CAN APPLY FOR INSTANCE
WE'VE EXEMPTED DRIVING TESTS IF
SOMEONE DOESN'T ALREADY HAVE A
DRIVER'S LICENSE. I DON'T SEE
DMV IS TO A DRIVER'S LICENSE
WITHOUT AN APPROPRIATE DRIVING
TEST. WELL SO THERE'S SORT OF
AN A PRIORITY ISSUE. DO YOU
HAVE ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM
ANYBODY ON THE COMMITTEE YES.
THANK YOU MISTER RIGHT HERE I
JUST WANT TO THANK MR STONE-
FOR BRINGING THIS AND YOU KNOW
I THINK THAT ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE AS A COMMITTEE STRIVE
TO DO ALL THE TIME AND WE AS A
LEGISLATURE IS TO REDUCE
RECIDIVISM OUR RECIDIVISM RATES
IN THE STATE ARE WAY TOO HIGH.
WHICH MEANS YOU KNOW WORSE
OUTCOMES HIGHER COSTS IN OUR
PRISONS AND MORE CRIME IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND I IS SIMPLE
THINGS LIKE THIS THAT ALLOW
SOMEONE TO GET BACK ON THEIR
FEET WHEN THEY LEAVE PRISON.
AND REENTER THEIR COMMUNITIES
SUCCESSFULLY AND I THINK THIS
IS A SMALL MEASURE THAT MAY
HAVE A HUGE IMPACT ON THE LIVES
OF THOSE LEAVING OUR SYSTEM
STUFF TOGETHER SAID AS PART OF
A NUMBER JUST. CLOSE WITH THIS
IT SAYS IN THIS READING
DIRECTLY FROM YOUR BILL IT SAYS
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION DEPARTMENT
OF MOTOR VEHICLES SHALL ENSURE
THAT ALL NOT IF YOU HAD PRIOR
ALL INMATES RELEASED FROM STATE
PRISON ARE RELEASED WITH A
VALID CALIFORNIA IDENTIFICATION
CARD. OR DRIVER'S LICENSE.
THERE'S NO EXCEPTIONS THERE. IF
YOU HAD A PRIOR SO I'M JUST
VERY CONFUSED BY IT AND- I'LL
LET YOU CLOSER ALL RIGHT S.
ZERO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE
READY TO CALL FOR THE QUESTION.
THE BILL'S IMPROPERLY MOVED AND
SECONDED ON AB SEVEN SEVENTEEN
BY SOME MEMBERS DOWN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER. LACKEY NO LATINO
BARRICADE HAN OKAY HAD HI CORK.
CORK HI SAN DIEGO. C. R. TWO C.
R. TONO WICKS. LI LI I
ACCORDING TO IT MEASURES
ONCOLOGY TO MORE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. YOU HAVE TO GO. YOUR
NEIGHBORS ON OKAY. YOU NEED THE
ONES WHERE DOESN'T MATTER. YOU
KNOW TO BE HERE RIGHT. READ THE
ROLE. WE'VE THEM BEING HONEST
BUT WE APPRECIATE HER BEING HER
EVEN MORE. THAT'S UP TO YOU
MA'AM. I WAS VERY MISTER KING
FELT THAT OKAY YES MA'AM. I'M
GONNA PRESENT IN AB. TWELVE
THIRTY SEVENTEEN. THANK YOU MR
VICE CHAIR AND THANK YOU
MEMBERS- FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT ON BEHALF. OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING AB TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN SEEKS TO PROTECT
GUN VIOLENCE RESEARCHERS ACCESS
TO DATA THEY NEED TO STUDY THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF OUR GUN LAWS
DESPITE ITS THIRTY YEAR HISTORY
OF PROVIDING THIS CRUCIAL
INFORMATION AN EXISTING LOG
REQUIRING THEM TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE HAS RECENTLY DECIDED TO
LIMIT ACCESS TO THIS CRUCIAL
INFORMATION. AB TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN RETAIN THE STATE ACCESS
BY REQUIRING DOJ TO SHARE THIS
INFORMATION WITH THE STATE
FUNDED YOU SEE FIREARM VIOLENCE
RESEARCH CENTER UNLESS
EXPLICITLY PROHIBITED BY LAW
ALLOWING A DISCRETIONARY
PROCESS FOR OTHER BONA FIDE
RESEARCH INSTITUTIONS TO ACCESS
THIS DATA. EXTENDING RECORD
KEEPING FROM TEN TO TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AND ENSURING RESEARCHERS
PROTECT INDIVIDUAL PRIVACY.
THIS DATA LEADS TO EVIDENCE
BASED POLICIES AND PROGRAMS
THAT REDUCE DEATHS AND INJURIES
FROM GUNS IN CALIFORNIA MUST
CONTINUE TO SHARE THIS DATA. SO
WE CAN CONTINUE TO IMPROVE OUR
FIRE AND POLICIES AND REDUCE
GUN VIOLENCE WE'VE TWO
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE TO
TESTIFY TODAY AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE. GET GAREN WINTEMUTE WITH
THE UC FIRE RESEARCH CENTER AND
REBEKAH MARKETS WITH THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN. OKAY AT&T. IF WE HAVE
REBEKAH MARKET SERVE OUR
GUARANTEE ON THE LINE.
KARABEKIR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU DR KAREN GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARON MEMBERS REBEKAH MARKETS
REPRESENTING THE BRADY CAMPAIGN
A STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN CALIFORNIA
COLLECTS AND ARCHIVES WE
UNIQUELY RICH BODY OF DATA ON
POTENTIAL RISK FACTORS
CHARACTERISTICS AND
CONSEQUENCES OF GUN VIOLENCE IF
INCLUDES RECORDS OF FIREARM
TRANSACTIONS CRIMES INVOLVING
FIREARMS ARMED AND PROHIBITED
PERSONS WITH PROTECTION ORDERS
CONCEALED WEAPON PERMIT
APPLICATIONS FIREARM RELATED
DEATHS AND INJURIES AND OTHER
VALUABLE INFORMATION
CALIFORNIANS FOR CALIFORNIANS
FIREARM VIOLENCE RELATED DATA.
IS MADE POSSIBLE IMPORTANT
RESEARCH THAT CANNOT BE
CONDUCTED IN ANY OTHER STATE
RESULTS FROM THIS RESEARCH HAVE
INFORMED FIREARM SAFETY LAWS
AND POLICIES IN CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THE NATION PROVIDE AN
IMPORTANT RESOURCE FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS WELL AS PUBLIC
HEALTH AND HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS AND MADE MAJOR
CONTRIBUTIONS TO ADVANCING
UNDERSTANDING OF FIREARM
VIOLENCE IF THIS HELPED IMPROVE
HEALTH AND SAFETY ACROSS THE
NATION THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
DATA CAN'T BE UNDERSTATED TO
THOSE OF US WORKING TO PREVENT
GUN VIOLENCE. WE WANT TO CREATE
SUCCESSFUL POLICY OUTCOMES
WITHOUT THE RESEARCH WE ARE
FLYING BLIND WITH THE EVIDENCE
WE CAN TAKE A LOT FROM
CALIFORNIA AND MAKE IT WORK IN
NEW YORK ILLINOIS AND DC AB
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN WILL PLAY A
CRUCIAL ROLE IN THE ANALYSIS
ULTIMATELY USED TO PREVENT
SENSELESS LOSS OF LIFE DUE TO
GUN VIOLENCE FREE. APPS FOR
YOUR IPAD THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WE'RE NOW READY TO HEAR FROM. I
DON'T SEE THEM DIALED IN YET
OUR GEAR AND IF YOU ARE ON THE
PHONE PLEASE PRESS STAR ZERO SO
I CAN OPEN YOUR LINE. KAREN IS
ON. PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
GOOD AFTERNOON HI AND KAREN
WINTEMUTE DIRECTOR OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
FIREARM VIOLENCE RESEARCH
CENTER WHICH CALIFORNIA
RESEARCHERS HAVE WORKED IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH DOJ FOR THIRTY
YEARS TO GENERATE A UNIQUE BODY
OF SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH AND
PROGRAM EVALUATION ON FIREARM
VIOLENCE AND ITS PREVENTION.
THIS SORT OF EVIDENCE THAT IS
NECESSARY FOR SOUND POLICY
MAKING. THIS WORK RELIES ON
ACCESS TO INDIVIDUAL LEVEL
IDENTIFIED DATA THIS STUDY
SIMPLY CAN'T BE CONDUCTED
OTHERWISE. THERE HAS ALWAYS
BEEN STRICT ADHERENCE TO
PRIVACY PROTOCOLS ESTABLISHED
BY THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AND BY FUNDING AGENCIES SUCH AS
THE NATIONAL INSTITUTES OF
HEALTH AND THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF JUSTICE. AND IN
THIRTY YEARS THERE HAS NEVER
BEEN A PRIVACY BREACH. THIS
WORK PROCEEDED WITH THE
APPROVAL OF THE TOURNEY'S
GENERAL FUND JOHN DANTE CAMP TO
COMELEC HARRIS. IT WAS WITH THE
EXPECTATION THAT SUCH RESEARCH
WOULD CONTINUE AND IN ITS
RECOGNITION THAT CALIFORNIA IS
DEMOCRACY'S LEADING LABORATORY
IN THE FIELD THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CREATED THE
NATION'S FIRST PUBLICLY FUNDED
CENTER FOR RESEARCH ON FIREARM
VIOLENCE IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN. UNFORTUNATELY AN
ATTITUDE UP OPPOSITION TO THE
INDEPENDENT STUDY SCIENTIFIC
STUDY OF VIOLENCE TOOK ROOT AT
DOJ'S EXECUTIVE LEVEL BEGINNING
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. THE
BILL BEFORE YOU SEEKS TO RESET
THE BALLOT IN THE MIDST OF A
NATIONWIDE VIOLENCE EPIDEMIC
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW
RESEARCHERS AT THE CENTER AT
STANFORD UNIVERSITY AND AT
OTHER UNIVERSITIES AROUND
CALIFORNIA TO DO THEIR WORK AND
HELP PREVENT DEATH AND INJURY
FROM VIOLENCE IN OUR STATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
A. T. T. OPERATOR TO HAVE ANY
OTHER CALLERS IN SUPPORT. IF
YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AB AT TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
FIRST SUPPORT OF AB AT TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT SIX IN Q.
ORANGE LINE ONE EIGHTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN- THEN MEMBERS TEND
HADN'T REPRESENTED CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
TWO OH SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MELANIE MILLER
REPRESENTING DIFFERENT OFTEN
FOR. THANK YOU OF MINE ONE
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MERI LEE BLACK BRADY CAMPAIGN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU LINE ONE
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHE
GOT HIM OPTION GRADING CAMPAIGN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NINE ONE
NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE
ARE GOING ON WELCOMING A MEMBER
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU A LINE
ONE NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CHRISTOPHER POLLOCK WHEN
ASSISTANT PROFESSOR AT UCLA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. OKAY THANK YOU I
THINK WE HAVE- KATHY LYNCH.
THAT'S CALLING ON OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU- CAMPING LAND SHALL
HAVE GOOD AFTERNOON HONORABLE
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I AM REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
SPORTSMEN'S LOBBY OUTDOOR
SPORTS INSTALLATION INSPIRED BY
THE INTERNATIONAL RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION AB TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN. CALIFORNIA'S BEEN A
STRONG ADVOCATE FOR PRIVACY
PROTECTION FROM THE PUBLIC HAS
ALSO SPOKEN THROUGH THE BALLOT
BOX THIS BILL UP AND PRIVACY
LAWS IN THE STATE UP TO MAJOR
LIABILITY ISSUES. THERE'S NO
CREDIBLE REASON WHY ANY
RESEARCH ENTITY WITH THE
PERSONAL INFORMATION THAT
VIOLATES CONSUMER PRIVACY. THIS
INFORMATION SHOULD NOT BE
PROVIDED TO ANYBODY BUT G. O.
J. TO OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES THAT HAVE STATUTORY
AUTHORIZATION FOR AN
INVESTIGATION. SOME OF THE
TROUBLING STATEMENTS INCLUDE
THE UCC YOU THREE DAYS
SUGGESTED AS NECESSARY YET
PROVIDE NO NECESSARY DEFINITION
OF NECESSARY OR CONTEXT. OF
PERSONAL INFORMATION DISCLOSURE.
STILL IT'S A CLASS FONG IN HAND
APPROACH FILE YOU D. PROVIDE
DISTRICT TO A BILL OR NOW REACH
AND THE- NO DEFINITE OF THE- OF
PROVIDE AND I'M THIS BILL
SUPPORTER OF THE BILL COULD
QUALIFY PERHAPS TECH COMPANY
DOING RESEARCH ON FACIAL
RECOGNITION. THE DECISION TO
SHARE THIS INFORMATION WILL BE
MADE BY THE RESEARCH CENTERS
OWN INTERNAL INSTITUTIONAL
REVIEW BOARD HERE GT RECORDED
IN A RECENT NEWSPAPER ARTICLE
THEY WOULD PROTECT PRIVACY BY A
SECURE. PASSWORD PROTECTED
SERVER. EVERYONE KNOWS WE HAVE
HAD SERIOUS BREACHES. WITH WITH
MOST OF OUR GOVERNMENT. FRANKLY
AND MOST RECENTLY STANFORD HAD
A HALF OF PERSONAL MEDICAL
INFORMATION THIS PROVIDES
LITTLE COMFORT IN AB TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN STATES NOTHING
ABOUT AFFILIATES PRIVACY
PROTECTION REQUIREMENTS AT ITS
CORE THEY WANT TWENTY FIVE
YEARS OF INFORMATION FROM
VARIOUS AGENCIES. THIS MAJOR IS
SILENT ON ANY REQUIREMENTS OF
THOSE AGENCIES. TO GET AN OFTEN
AUTHORIZATION FROM THE CONSUMER
THIS BILL HAS UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THAT COULD LEAD TO
AN UNDERGROUND MARKET IF
INDIVIDUALS FEEL THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION IS BEING EXPOSED.
THIS BILL HELPS PROFILING
CONCERNS DOCKING AND PUBLIC
SAFETY RISK FOR CONSUMERS THIS
BILL IS A BREACH OF THE PUBLIC
TRUST WITH GOVERNMENT. AND
CONSUMERS THAT BELIEVE THEIR
INFORMATION IS BEING USED FOR
THE PURPOSE AUTHORIZED ONLY
INCLUDING. THIS IS A VERY BAD
PRECEDENT FOR ALL RESEARCH AND
WILL CHILL TRUST WITH THE
PUBLIC IN THE FUNDAMENTAL
QUESTION HAS NOT BEEN ANSWERED.
THAT'S A WIDER RESEARCHER NEEDS
PERSONAL INFORMATION TO CONDUCT
RESEARCH THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PASSED BY TODAY AND
APPRECIATE THE POPCORN NOW WITH
YES AND NO CHEN ABOUT ON THE
TOP. THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OPERATOR WE HAVE ANY
OTHER CALLERS IN OFFICE. THANK
YOU IF YOU TO STAY AND I. OF
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN FOR OPPOSITION
OUT OF AB TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I DO HAVE ONE IN
Q. IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR
THAT LINE.
HELLO I ONE A WIDE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES IS IT IN
REVERSE THE NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION HERE IN OPPOSITION
AB TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU MA'AM WE
HAVE ANYBODY IN THE ROOM AND
WONDER EXPRESS OPPOSITION.
ANYBODY IN THE CONFERENCE ROOM.
OKAY COMMITTEE AND DIVIDED
COMMITTEE THE ONE OF. MAKE ANY
COMMENTS RUSHED GONNA QUESTIONS.
READY FOR CLOTHES LAMP RESPECT
FASTER I THOUGHT THANK YOU OKAY.
I'M SORRY GO AHEAD SIR. PERHAPS
YOU COULD HAVE I KNOW THIS
ISN'T YOUR BILL PERHAPS YOU
COULD HAVE THE RESEARCHERS SAY
WHY HE COULDN'T JUST USED
ANONYMIZED DATA WHERE THEY- AND
I BELIEVE THERE IS A GOOD
REASON FOR THIS BUT THERE'S
ANONYMIZED DATA THAT YOU CAN
USE. THAT ARE SAYING INSTEAD OF
A NAME GIVES YOU A NUMBER AND
SOME OF THE- CONDITIONS AROUND
IT- DO YOU REALLY NEED A NAME.
THANK YOU I WILL SAY AND I'D
ASK THAT COMMITTEE SECRETARY
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG THAT
THIS BILL IS DOUBLE FURRED AND
HEADING TO PRIVACY NEXT WHERE I
KNOW THOSE ISSUES WILL BE
THOROUGHLY VETTED SO I DID WANT
TO POINT THAT OUT TO THE
COMMITTEE- JUST FOR YOUR OWN
KILEY CLAIMS BUT I WILL- LET
GAREN WINTEMUTE ANTICS THAT IF
YES ANSWER. TENSION JUST ONE-
WHETHER WE'RE DOING A
RANDOMIZED TRIAL OR- AN
OBSERVATIONAL STUDY WE'RE DOING
A RANDOMIZED TRIAL OF APPS WERE
DOING. AN OBSERVATIONAL STUDY
OF THE GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDER POLICY- THAT ALL OF THE
MOST RIGOROUS METHODS. FIRE
FOLLOWING INDIVIDUAL CASES THE
REASON WE CAN'T DO THAT WITH
ANONYMIZED DATA SORRY-
BACKGROUND NOISE. THAT WE
FOLLOW INDIVIDUAL PEOPLE TO
MULTIPLE RECORD SYSTEM SO FOR
EXAMPLE I THIRTEEN ASKED TRIAL
STOCK OUTCOME OF INTEREST. IT'S
FIVE. OCTOBER EVERYTHING YOU
MISTER IN I THINK ANSWERED THE
FIRST QUESTION- I'M SORRY WELL
DONE YES THE BILL HAS A BILL
BEEN MOVED YET. I MOVED IT
ALREADY ARE WELL I LOVE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU THANK YOU. I
READ A CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE AGAIN. THANK YOU READY
FOR ROLL CALL. I'M AT TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN PLACE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TEAM THE MOTION IS TO
PATCH THE PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER. LACKEY NO LACKING NO
BARRICADE HAN HI ERIC HE HAD A
CORK BY CORK I SANTIAGO. THEY
ARE TOO SCARED TO KNOW WICKS.
THE LI. MOTOR VEHICLE NEED TO
MORE IN THIS MCCARTY STILL NOT
HERE GOD. YOU'VE GOT IT THANK
YOU MR RICHER I WILL NEVER THAT
AB SO. THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS EIGHTY SEVEN
THIRTY ONE IS THE
REINTRODUCTION OF LAST YEAR IS
AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY THREE
WHICH PASSED OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND WOULD REQUIRE
COUNTY SHERIFF'S STATEWIDE TO
COMPILE AND SUBMIT DATA ON. ONE
OFFENDER RECIDIVISM PROGRAMS
PROVIDED TO INMATES IN COUNTY
JAILS AND OVER TO THE SUCCESS
RATES IN REDUCING RECIDIVISM IN
THOSE PROGRAMS EACH YEAR SINCE
REALIGNMENT WAS ENACTED
APPROPRIATIONS IN STATE BUDGET
DOLLARS. HAVE GONE TO OUR
COUNTIES TO IMPLEMENTED DIVERSE
APPROACHES FOR SUPERVISION AND
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS THAT
AIM TO REDUCE RECIDIVISM. SINCE
THEN INFORMATION ABOUT
CALIFORNIA'S RECIDIVISM
PROGRAMMING SPECIFIC TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN OUR COUNTY JAILS
IS FRAGMENTED AND DIFFICULT TO
DIGEST. IT SIMPLY NONSENSICAL
TO CONTINUE TO INVEST STATE
DOLLARS IN PROGRAMMING WHERE WE
HAVE NO IDEA WHETHER THESE
PROGRAMS ARE SUCCESS OR FAILURE.
TO THAT POINT RECENTLY STATE
AUDITOR CONDUCTED A
COMPREHENSIVE AUDIT OF THE
ALAMEDA FRESNO IN L. A. COUNTY
SYSTEMS AND HER FINDINGS WHICH
WERE PUBLISHED LAST MONTH SPEAK
EXACTLY TO WHAT THIS BILL IS
TRYING TO ACHIEVE. THE AUDIT
FOUND QUOTE THE STATE ALLOCATED
SIX BILLION DOLLARS TO
CALIFORNIA'S COUNTIES IN FISCAL
YEARS TWENTY NINETEEN TO TWENTY
TWENTY. HOWEVER BECAUSE THE
THREE COUNTIES REVIEWED HAVE
NARROWLY INTERPRETED THE SCOPE
OF PUBLIC SAFETY REALIGNMENT
FUNDING THEIR COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS PARTNERSHIP
COMMITTEE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
MONITORING SUCH SPENDING. HAVE
OVERSEEN LESS THAN 20% OF THE
FUNDING THE COUNTIES RECEIVED
EACH COUNTY ALSO MAINTAINS
EXCESSIVE REALIGNMENT SURPLUSES
WHICH THEY COULD SPEND TO
IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY. FINALLY
THE COUNTIES LACK COMPREHENSIVE
PLANNING AND OVERSIGHT FOR
REALIGNMENT SPENDING WITHOUT
WHICH THEY CANNOT MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS. THE AUDIT SKI THE
REPORT SPEAKS DIRECTLY TO THE
HEART OF THIS BILL IT IS
INCUMBENT UPON US IS THE
LEGISLATURE TO BRING FULL
TRANSPARENCY TO THESE PROGRAMS.
AND OUR SPENDING WE HAVE SPENT
OVER SIX BILLION DOLLARS IN
STATE FUNDS AND WE HAVE VERY
LITTLE INFORMATION ON HOW THAT
INVESTMENT IS WORKING. THIS
BILL WILL REQUIRE STANDARDIZED
LOOK AT THOSE PROGRAMS AND FIND
OUT WHERE THEY ARE SUCCESSFUL
WE TALK A LOT IN THIS COMMITTEE
ABOUT MAKING DATA DRIVEN
DECISIONS TO REDUCE RECIDIVISM.
AND YET WE ARE COLLECTING THE
DATA NECESSARY TO DO THAT WORK
SO I URGE THIS COMMITTEE TO
PASS THIS BILL AND GET
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON WHERE
THOSE DOLLARS ARE GOING WHAT'S
WORKING WHAT ISN'T. SO WE CAN
EXPAND ON THOSE PROGRAMS THAT
ARE WORKING BECAUSE REDUCING
RECIDIVISM MEANS BETTER
OUTCOMES. IT MEANS LESS
SPENDING IN PRISON DOLLARS AND
IT ALSO MEANS INCREASED SAFETY
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. WITH ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY OR WHO THEY BURN
OFF FROM THE ELEVATOR SET BAKER
CENTER IN EXTORT OPEN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION. K. OPERATOR. WE'RE
READY TO- HERE THE- TESTIMONIES
SUPPORT. THANK YOU BOTH SIDES
ARE OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS JOSE BUT NOT ON THE
ORGANIZING DIRECTOR AT DELLA
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
BASED IN OAKLAND THE ELLA BAKER
CENTER WORKS TO ADVANCE RACIAL
AND ECONOMIC JUSTICE FOR PEOPLE
WITH LOW INCOMES AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR BY SHIFTING RESOURCES
AWAY FROM PRESIDENT THAN
PUNISHMENT I'M TOWARD
OPPORTUNITIES THAT MAKE OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE HEALTHY STRONG.
AS SOMEONE WITH EXPERIENCE
INCARCERATION FIRSTHAND AND HAS
BEEN HAS BENEFITED GREATLY FROM
SUPPORT SERVICES I KNOW HOW
ESSENTIAL AND LIFE SAVING IT IS
ONE STATE INVESTMENT VALUABLE
TAX DOLLARS INTO HEALT
DEPARTMENT RESOURCES. IS MY
OPINION THAT THIS IS ALWAYS THE
INTENT OF THE LEGISLATURE WOULD
REALIGN FUNDS BECAME AVAILABLE
TO COUNTIES. OVER THE COURSE OF
YEARS THAT MONITOR CONDITIONS
AND BUDGET THAT SEVERAL COUNTY
JAILS INCLUDING ALAMEDA COUNTY
SANTA RITA JAIL ABOUT THREE
YEARS AGO THE ELLA BAKER CENTER
LED A CAMPAIGN THAT HAD A VERY
SIMPLE ASK FOR ALAMEDA COUNTY
SUPERVISORS IT WAS APPROVED A
FINANCIAL AND PERFORMANCE AUDIT
OF THE SANTA RITA JAIL. WE
WANTED CAMPAIGN IN RESPONSE TO
SEVERAL DISCREPANCIES WE WERE
NOTICING A COUNTY JAIL SPENDING
AS WELL AS AN ALARMING RATE OF
CIVIL SUITS ALLEGING
MISTREATMENT AND ABUSE FOR
EXAMPLE THE JAIL POPULATION IT
DECREASED BY NEARLY HALF OR THE
LOST OVER THE LAST QUARTER
DECADE. YET DURING THE SAME
PERIOD OF TIME THE SHARES
BUDGET INCREASED BY AT LEAST
80% PUBLIC RECORDS ALONG WITH
DIRECT COMMUNICATION WITH
PEOPLE INSIDE THE JAIL RATE
VERY SERIOUS CONCERNS OVER
HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSE NEGLECT AND
MISTREATMENT. Y. LOS ANGELES
COUNTY IS BY FAR THE LARGEST
DEALER IN THE NATION BETWEEN
TWENTY FOURTEEN AND TWENTY
NINETEEN GENERATED JAIL HAD A
50% HIGHER IN CUSTODY DEATH
RATE THAN LOS ANGELES THIS IS
NOT ACCEPTABLE AND SADLY JUST A
FEW WEEKS AGO ANOTHER HUMAN
BEING DIED WHILE IN CUSTODY
SANTA RITA JAIL. COUNTY
OFFICIALS NEVER APPROVED OUR
REQUEST REGIONAL AUDIT AND TO
DATE WE STILL DON'T KNOW WHAT
WHERE THE JAIL SPENDING
EXPLAINS I HIGHLIGHTS HOW TO BE
A JAIL AS A CLEAR EXAMPLE OF A
JAIL WITH VERY LITTLE
TRANSPARENCY OR ACCOUNTABILITY
BUT IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT THIS IS A PROBLEM ACROSS
THE STATE. DESPITE CALIFORNIA
ALLOCATING BILLIONS IN FUNDING
TO COUNTIES. FOR RECIDIVISM
REDUCTION PROGRAMMING. THE BY
THE- SPATE AUDITOR WE- FUNDS.
THERE'S BEEN NO REGULAR ORGANS
DATA COLLECTION ON THE PA OF
COUNTY. BALLOT POGUE FOR SIX.
IN THE OF A CALL WITH MY- PAN.
THE STATE. STATE A FIVE DOLLAR
DEBT. AS AS THE- MY PLAN.
CURRENTLY IN FROM. ON THE- OF
RECIDIVISM PROGRAMS THE STATE
PRESIDENT AVAILABLE INSURANCE
STATE DOLLARS ARE USED AS
EFFICIENTLY AS POSSIBLE. WE DO
NOT HAVE THE STATE INFORMATION
SHARED AT THE COUNTY JAIL
LEVEL. THIS PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR LEGISLATORS TO
MAKE FULLY INFORMED DECISIONS
ON THE BEST USE OF FUNDING.
AIMED AT PROGRAMS TO SHOW
PREVENT RATE OF REDUCING
RECIDIVISM. BUT HE WHO DOES THE
ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS- RESPECT EIGHT OF
SUPPORT EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTY ONE
AND RESPECT WE URGE LEGISLATORS.
TO PASS THIS IMPORTANT BILL
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU.
MISTER VICE CHAIR THIS IS NEXT
TO THE SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVEN THIRTY ONE- ADDED PART
EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTY ONE OF THE
TRANSPARENCY BILL ALLOWED WHAT
LEGISLATION PUBLIC DETERMINE
HOW EFFECTIVELY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENTS ARE USING STATE
FUNDS FOR PROGRAM IN COUNTY
JAILS. SOME COUNTY TO
SUCCESSFULLY UTILIZE THE
FUNDING OPPORTUNITY PROVIDED BY
REALIGNMENT TO CREATE
INNOVATIVE AND SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM HAS REDUCED. RECIDIVISM
RATE ALLOWED FORMALLY
INCARCERATED CALIFORNIANS TO
RECHARGE YOUR COMMUNITIES
OTHERS HAVE NOT. THE PROBLEM IS
THAT WHEN A PROGRAM IS
SPONSORED WE AFFECTED THE
REDUCE RECIDIVISM RATES FOR
MORE TROUBLINGLY DEMONSTRABLY
INEFFECTIVE THERE'S NO
STATEWIDE REPORTING MECHANISM
TO REPORT AT THE PROGRAM'S
RESULTS. PUT MORE SIMPLY
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T KNOW WHICH
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS ARE
GOOD ADVENTURE FACT BECAUSE
DATA ABOUT THE SUCCESS RATE IS
EITHER NOT CAPS WERE NOT
SHARED. EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTY ONE
ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE BY
REQUIRING COUNTY SHERIFF'S
REPORT ON HOW THEY'RE USING
STATE PROVIDED ONE TIMES AND
SUCCESS RATES OF THEIR CHOSEN
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS. SUCH A
CRIME NOT ONLY ENSURE THAT IN
EFFECT TO PRODUCE COMMODIFIED
FACT PROGRAMS ANYWAY IT WILL
ALSO PROVIDE THE PUBLIC IN THIS
BODY WITH ACTUAL DATA FUSION
ALLOCATING SCARCE RESOURCES THE
FUTURE. BECAUSE EIGHTY SEVEN
THIRTY ONE MAKE SURE THAT WE
KNOW WHAT WE'RE BUYING WITH
TAXPAYER MONEY ALLOW BETTER
INFORMED DECISION MAKING IN THE
FUTURE CPA. ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OP WE HAVE
A OTHER CALL. CALLERS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK SUCH OF A SO THREE ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN FIRST
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN THREE ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND I CURRENTLY
HAVE TWO COMMENTS IN Q. FOUR
TWO ONE ONE NINETY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. COMMUNITY MEMBERS
WITHOUT HERE IS IN SUPPORT OF
OUR TECHNICIAN BUT IT DOES
REALLY GOOD THING AND WE SHOULD
BE LOOKING FOR PEOPLE WHO OF
COURSE AND- BUT- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M TO FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LYING TWO ONE
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU.
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD YEAH MY
NAME VALLEY FEARS AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT- ON BEHALF
OF ELISSA LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND-
STRONG SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK
YOU OF MINE ONE NINETY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. CANACCORD ARE NON
BEHALF OF THE TEMPERATURES GO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER LINES IN Q. OKAY IF WE
COULD NOW HEAR FROM- COREY
CELLS ELLO. IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
CORY CELLS- ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB SEVEN THIRTY
ONE SHERIFFS ACROSS THE STATE
PROVIDE MEANINGFUL
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING TO
JAIL AND MAKES WITH THE DESIRE
TO ENHANCE FORMALLY
INCARCERATED PERSON YOU RE
ENTRY INTO SOCIETY AND REDUCE
THE LIKELIHOOD THAT PEOPLE RE
OFFEND. UNFORTUNATELY THIS BILL
IMPOSES VAGUE AND BURDENSOME
DATA COLLECTIONREQUIREMENTS
WITHOUT ANY GUARANTEE OF
FUNDING TO COVER THOSE COSTS.
SB SEVEN THIRTY ONE REQUIRE
SHERIFF'S REPORT QUOTE DATA ON
EACH OF THE ANTI RECIDIVISM.
UNIQUE DATA ON EACH OF THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM PROGRAMS THEY
PROVIDE INMATES IN THE COUNTY
JAIL FACILITIES ONE QUOTE. THE
SCOPE OF WHAT IS SOUGHT BY THIS
LANGUAGE IS UNCLEAR AND IS
UNLIKELY TO YIELD DISTRICT
RESPONSES FROM THE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES. ADDITIONALLY THE BILL
FAILS TO DEFINE QUOTE
REASSIGNED AND QUOQUE SUCCESS
AS IT RELATES TO RECIDIVISM AND
THE OFFER PROGRAMS. AS A RESULT
THE BILL COULD BE INTERPRETED
AS REQUIRING COUNTY JAILS TO
ASCERTAIN FROM CORK'S OTHER
JAILS OR STATE PRISONS
POTENTIALLY INCLUDING. SUCH
ENTITY AND OTHER STATES.
INFORMATION AS TO SUBSEQUENT
ARRESTSOR CONVICTIONS.
REQUIRING SUCH WOULD BE VERY
EXPENSIVE A PROBLEM EXACERBATED
BY THE FACT THE BILL PROVIDES
THE FUNDING FOR ITS
REQUIREMENTS. TO THE NOTE ABOUT
THE COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS
PARTNERSHIPS AND THE PLANS
CREATED UNDER PUBLIC SAFETY
REALIGNMENT THOSE PLANS THAT
ARE CREATED- ARE DONE SO IN A
PUBLIC PROCESS THEIR- ENACTED
BY STATUTORILY MANDATED
COMMITTEE OF LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS.
AND THE CCP- ARE POSTED-
INCLUDING WIN UPDATED ONLINE AT
FOR STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS WEBSITE IF THERE
ARE QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW
COUNTY'S INCOME TO SPEND THOSE
FUNDS FROM. APRIL I MET SO FOR
THE REASONS NOTED AND GIVEN THE
FACT THAT A SIMILAR BILL WAS
VETOED LAST YEAR BECAUSE OF ITS
BROAD NATURE AND POTENTIAL FOR
COSTS THIS IS A MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB SEVEN
THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ARE THERE. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- IN
HERE WITNESSES IN THE RIVER AND
THE HEARING ROOM IN OPPOSITION.
I THINK WITNESSES ON THE VIDEO
CONFERENCE SCREEN. AT&T
OPERATOR YOU CAN NOW GO TO THE
TELEPHONE LINES ON AB SEVEN
THREE ONE MARQUESA. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY SEVEN
THIRTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN SIR OPPOSITION FOR AB
SEVEN THREE ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
IF YOU CURRENTLY HAVE ONE
COMMENT JIM CUTEST ONE MALL
AFTER THAT COMMENT. NINE TO
ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BRANDED UP ON
BEHALF OF THE SHARE OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WE APPRECIATE
THE CONCEPT BUT UNFORTUNATELY
MUST OPPOSE THE BILL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK OU RIPPER GIVE BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE MR QUIRK- I FEEL
VERY STRONGLY THAT YOU KNOW IF
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO TELL US
WHETHER OR NOT THE THING IS
SUCCESSFUL. LET'S NOT SPEND THE
MONEY. I FEEL VERY VERY
STRONGLY ABOUT THAT. WE FOREVER
ARE DOING THINGS AND- EVEN IN
PHYSICS YOU EXPECT ONE ANSWER
AND YOU GET ANOTHER DEALING
WITH PEOPLE YOU CAN DO
SOMETHING THAT SOUNDS PERFECTLY
REASONABLE HAS COMMUNITY
SUPPORT. BUT IT DOESN'T WORK OR
MAYBE IT DOES AND THEN WE'LL TO
SPREAD IT. AS FAR AS THE MONEY
GOES THAT ARE TO BE TAKEN OUT
OF THE MONEY THAT USED FOR THE
PROGRAM PERIOD- AND IN TERMS-
YOU WANT SOME BETTER
DEFINITIONS THAT'S ALWAYS GOOD
I KNOW THE AUTHOR WILL DO THAT-
SO I AM SUPPORTING THE BILL HAS
IT BEEN MOVED. NOW I'LL MOVE IT.
THANK YOU SO WHEN HAD ME AS A
CO AUTHOR I FEEL VERY STRONGLY
THANK YOU MR CLARK THANK YOU.
MR LACKEY. YEAH I'M SUPPORTIVE
OF YOUR BILL BUT OF CURIOUS TO
LEARN HOW YOU ADDRESS THE
GOVERNOR'S A CONCERN IS VITAL
MESSAGE LAST TIME. YES SO ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WAS BROUGHT
UP BY COMMITTEE WHICH AM I
RESPECTING AGREE WITH IS
CURRENTLY THERE'S NO DEFINITION
OF RECIDIVISM IN THE LANGUAGE.
LAST YEAR WITH THE BILL THE GOT
TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK DEFINED
RECIDIVISM IS A PERSON WHO
RECEIVED A NEW FELONY OR
MISDEMEANOR CONVICTION OR
PROBATION VIOLATION WITH THREE
YEARS FROM THE OFFENDER'S
PREVIOUS CRIMINAL CONVICTION.
SARVESTAN FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
VETO MESSAGE THAT HE THOUGHT
THAT WAS TOO BROAD A DEFINITION
AND SO WE ARE WORKING TO BEAR
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TO
NARROW IT AND I HOPE THIS
COMMITTEE WILL MOVE THIS BILL
FORWARD TODAY SO WE CAN GET TO
A- AN AGREED DEFINITION WITH
THE GOVERNOR THAT IS NARROW
ENOUGH SO WE HAVE THIS DATA WE
KNOW HOW THESE DOLLARS ARE
BASED BEING SPENT WE INSURE
THEIR BEING SPENT ON PROGRAMS
THAT WORK. AND WE WERE I AM
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO GET
TO AND OR OR DEFINITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
OTHER MEMBERS WITH QUESTIONS OR-
RIGHT. YOU MAY CLOSE. RESPECT
FASTER AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR.
BURKE CAJUN OR IS IT TEHAMA.
QUE HAN QUE HAN. AS TAKES ME A
LONG TIME- BUT YOU KNOW WHAT I
DID TO BE SEC HAS ALWAYS BEEN
ONE OF MY FAVORITE GROUPS OF DO
REPORT BUT IT FROM WHAT I'M
READING HERE YOU PUT SOME
SPECIFICITY IN THERE SO THAT
THEY THEY THEY COME BACK WITH
THIS INFORMATION- RIGHT HERE
ALL THE TIME THAT ALL THESE-
PROGRAMS WORK WHEN I ASKED GIVE
ME THE- GIVE ME THE DATA THAT
PROVES THAT IT IS IT'S ALMOST
LIKE TRUST ME- I THINK WE'RE
LAW PASSED THOSE TIES WERE WE
NEED TO. JUST TRUST. GOVERNMENT
IN GENERAL BUT WE ACTUALLY NEED
TO HAVE SOME ACCOUNTABILITY AND
LOOK INTO WAYS WE CAN WE CAN
GET THE DATA SO THAT WE CAN
MAKE INTELLIGENT DECISIONS ON
WHICH WAY TO GO. AND NOT
SPECULATE OR TAKE PEOPLE'S WORD
FOR IT SO IT IS OUR AYE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THANK YOU.
LAST FOUR. CALDERON. EIGHTY
SEVEN THIRTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BARRICADE HAND
THE MISSION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER HI GENSER IRAQI. LACKEY
INSTANCE BARRICADE HELD HIGH
MARKET HAD I QUIRK AYE QUICK
AYE SAN DIEGO. CA ARE TO NOT
VOTE C. R. TO NOT VOTING WICKS
WICKS I LI LI I. THAT MEASURE
PASSAGE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
IF I MAY HAVE BEEN MY LAST BILL
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX YEP. HI
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS FIRST
I WANT TO START BY PROFUSELY
THANKING THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR INCREDIBLY
HARD WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION. AND WOULD BE
GRANTED SHARE I'VE COMMITTED TO
TAKING THE FOLLOWING MOMENTS IN
PRIVACY AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE IF WE PASS OUT OF
COMMITTEE TODAY WE WILL GO
NEXT- SO JUST WANT TO LAY THOSE
OUT FOR ALL OF YOU BECAUSE THEY
DIFFER SLIGHTLY FROM WHAT. AND
WAS IN THE ANALYSIS SO
RETAINING THE MISDEMEANORS AND
ALL VIOLATIONS IN THE BILL BUT
ELEVATING THE FOLLOWING FOR
VIOLATIONS AS WYLER'S ON A
SECOND OFFENSE OR FOR OFFENSES
INVOLVING THE USE OR THREAT OF
FORCE GOVERNMENT CODE SIX
TWENTY ONE EIGHT POINT OH ONE.
A SECOND VIOLATION WHEN SHARING
PERSONAL INFORMATION ON RECORD
LINE RESULTS IN BODILY INJURY.
PENAL CODE FOR TWENTY THREE
POINT THREE UNDER THE FACE ACT
A SECOND VIOLATION OF A NON
VIOLENT CRIME. PENAL CODE FOR
TWENTY THREE POINT THREE C.
UNDER THE FACE ACT. A FIRST
VIOLATION INVOLVING THE USE OF
THREATS OR FORCE AND IT. COULD
FOR TWENTY THREE POINT THREE D.
INTERFACE ACT A SECOND
VIOLATION INVOLVING THE USE OF
FORCE OR THREAT OF FORCE. IN A
SECOND VIOLATION OF PROPERTY
CRIMES. ALL FOUR OF THE SECOND
VIOLATIONS OR AUTHORITIES
WYLER'S- AN INCREASE PENALTIES
WOULD FALL UNDER A THREE YEAR
SUNSET. IN ADDITION WE ARE
WORKING TO CLARIFY THE INTENT
REQUIREMENTS FOR OFFENSES
RELATED TO PUT. PHOTOGRAPHING
OR VIDEO RECORDING TO
INTIMIDATE PROVIDERS AND
PATIENTS AND DISCLOSURE OF SUCH
IMAGES AND RECORDING. AND I
BELIEVE YOU MAY HEAR MORE OF
THAT AND IT IS A REALLY TO THE
TESTIMONY. AND FINALLY WE ARE
MOVING PENAL CODE FOR TWENTY
TWO POINT SIX FROM THE BILL. I
HOPE THAT WAS CLEAR BUT I THINK
THAT YOU ALL HAVE THAT. AND SO
TODAY I'M PRESENTING THIS BILL
WHICH AIMS TO REMEMBER THE
SENSOR. YES I THANK. SO AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX AIMS TO
UPDATE OUR LAWS TO ADDRESS THE
INSIDIOUS THREATS THAT PATIENTS
AND PROVIDERS AND REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CLINICS FACE PEOPLE HAVE
THE CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO
SEEK SERVICE SERVICES FIRM
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CLINICS
WITHOUT THEIR FREE WILL BEING
VIOLATED WHEN ONE. IS GOING
ABOUT THEIR BUSINESS RECEIVING
THEIR HEALTHCARE THEY SHOULD
NOT. BE GETTING THREATS AND
VIOLENCE THEY SHOULD BE SAFE
AND SECURE AND I THINK THAT IS
THE FUNDAMENTAL THING THIS BILL
IS TRYING TO ADDRESS. LAWS
REGULATING SHARING PERSONAL
INFORMATION ONLINE WERE LAST
UPDATED IN THE MID TWO
THOUSANDS THE FACE FACT
PROTECTING CLINICS WAS WRITTEN
IN. CONTRAST TO CLEAN MORE
EXTREME IN THEIR TACTICS
SOMETIMES USING ADVANCES IN
TECHNOLOGY TO DO SO. PROTESTERS
ARE HARASSING PATIENTS AND
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS WEARING
THEM DOWN MENTALLY AND
CONFRONTING THEM PHYSICALLY.
NEW CAMERA VIDEO CAPABILITIES
ALLOW THEM TO FILM PATIENTS AND
PROVIDERS IN DETAIL THESE
IMAGES WHICH ARE POSTED ON
PUBLIC FACING WEBSITES LEAD TO
HARASSMENT AND THE THREATENING
OF PATIENTS LIVES OUR CURRENT
LAW DOES NOT REFLECT THE
SEVERITY OF THIS THREAT BECAUSE
IN NINETEEN NINETY FOUR. THE
THREATS WERE DIFFERENT. LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS DETERRED FROM
MAKING ARRESTS POLICE ARE
FRUSTRATED BY THE
RELENTLESSNESS OF THESE GROUPS
AND THEY LACK SUFFICIENT
TRAINING TO ADDRESS THE FRAUGHT
SITUATION. THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE
PRIVACY AND PHYSICAL SAFETY OR
PRE REQUISITE. FOR ACCESSIBLE
HEALTH CARE. WHEN A PATIENT
FACES UNMITIGATED HARASSMENT IN
ONE OF THEIR MOST VULNERABLE
MOMENTS THEY'RE BEING ROBBED OF
THAT RIGHT TO HEALTH CARE AND
OUR LAWS ARE FAILING TO PROTECT
THEM. HARASSING IN PHYSICAL
VIOLENCE AGAINST REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH DOCTORS CARRIES LOWER
PENALTIES THAN DOG FIGHTING.
LOW FINDS IN MISDEMEANORS DON'T
DETER GROUPS THAT HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO PAY AND DEFEND
THEMSELVES AND WE'VE ACCEPTED
THIS IS THE STATUS QUO ONE THAT
OVER PENALIZES MARIJUANA
POSSESSION BELIEVES YOUNG WOMEN
VICTIMS OF DEATH THREATS FOR
SEEKING HEALTH CARE
UNPROTECTED. AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
SIX UPDATES ARE A LOT LAWS TO
INCREASE FINES FOR ONLINE
HARASSMENT INTENTIONALLY
TERRORIZING PROVIDERS AND
PATIENTS IT INCREASES PENALTIES
FOR REPEAT AND VIOLENT OFFENSES
IT ALSO INCLUDES THE NEEDED
TRAINING FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
ACTUALLY PROSECUTE THESE CRIMES
AND PROTECT THESE PATIENTS AND
WORKERS. THIS IS NOT ABOUT
ARBITRARY PUNISHMENT IT'S ABOUT
FINDING A SOLUTION THE
PENALTIES THEREFORE WILL HAVE A
THREE YEAR SUNSET IS THE
CHAIRMAN CHEN- THAT WILL ALLOW
US TO ASSESS THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF THESE LAWS IN DETERRING
EXTREMISTS AND MAKE SURE WE ARE
BEST PROTECTING PATIENTS AND
WORKERS- AS NOTED NOT ONLY IS
THERE SUNSET BUT THE BILL
ALLOWS US TO COLLECT DATA ON
HOW THIS IS WORKING SO AGAIN.
YOU'LL SEE AYE I LOVE DATA SO
THIS BILL TWO ALLOWS US TO KNOW
HOW WE ARE PROTECTING THESE
PATIENTS AND WORKERS TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
SIX ISELIN SO LINDA VASQUEZ
VICE PRESIDENT OF EXTERNAL
AFFAIRS AT PLANNED PARENTHOOD
LOS ANGELES AND JESSICA MORAN%
THE DIRECTOR OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD ONE THE GREAT HEALTH
CENTER. THAT HEALTH CENTER IN
MY COMMUNITY WHERE WE HAVE SEEN
VIOLENCE IN FRONT OF A HEALTH
CENTER WHERE PEOPLE ARE JUST
TRYING TO SEE CARE AND YOU'LL
HEAR MORE ABOUT WHAT THE
PATIENTS AND DOCTORS ARE
FACING. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
IT WITNESSES A SUPPORT CAN
BEGIN WHENEVER THEY'RE READY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS YOU
CAN IN THAT BASKET I AM HERE ON
BEHALF OF. LANTERN HAD TALKED
ANGELES INSTALLED SUPPORT. OF
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX WE HAVE.
VERY FOR VERY MANY YEARS
DECADES HAVE EXPERIENCED- THE
CURRENT NATION- THE- ANTI
PLANNED PARENTHOOD EXTREMISTS-
THAT HAVE TARGETED AND SIMPLY
ATTACKED AND HARASSED I'M HERE
KAREN HAD PATIENTS AND ARTS
COUNCIL WORK FOR PROVIDERS AND
VOLUNTEERS. UNFORTUNATELY IN
THE LAST YEAR DURING THE
PANDEMIC WHEN REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE WAS ACTUALLY I'M
STILL IN A STRONG DEMAND AND IT
CONTINUES TO BE SO WE SAW AN
INCREASE IN THESE ATTACKS.
AGAINST PLANNED PARENTHOOD. I'M
INTERESTED MONTHS WE ACTUALLY
SAW A FEW OF THE LEADERS OF
ANTI PLANNED PARENTHOOD ANTI
ABORTION GROUPS INVOLVED IN THE
INTERACTION ON THE U. S.
CAPITOL. AND WE KNOW FOR A FACT
THAT THERE HAD BEEN A LONG
OVERLAP BETWEEN ANTI PLANNED
PARENTHOOD EXTREMISTS AND WHITE
SUPREMACISTS CURRENT TERRORIST
MOVEMENTS. IT IS TROUBLING WHEN
OUR PATIENT POPULATION IN
PARTICULAR IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND CHAIR YOU KNOW THAT
VERY WELL- AND YOU REPRESENT
OUR HEADQUARTERS- IN NEAR USC
AND IN SOUTH LA. WE HAVE SEEN
AN INCREASE IN DIFFERENT
STRATEGIES- USED AGAINST OUR
PATIENTS AND AGAINST OUR
ESSENTIAL WORK FORCE- BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT HAS BEEN YOUR FRIEND
IS THAT THE LAWS HAVE NOT BEEN
UPDATED SINCE THE NINETIES WHAT
WE REALLY HAVE TO ACCEPT THE
COMPLACENCY AROUND WHAT IS
HAPPENING. IN ON A DAILY BASIS
OUTSIDE OF OUR HEALTH CENTERS-
WE HAVE IN LOS ANGELES A FEW
HEALTH CENTER- WE HAVE TWENTY
ONE HEALTH CENTERS THAT SERVE
OVER TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND PATIENT DOES THAT
OUR PATIENT POPULATION REFLECTS
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES.
PROXIMALLY 75% OF OUR PATIENTS.
ARE PATIENTS OF COLOR. EIGHTY
OVER ALMOST NINETY- ARE.
PATIENTS THAT LIVE ATTY BELOW
THE FEDERAL LEVEL. I DO ON A
DAILY BASIS HAVE TO NAVIGATE BY
RENTS THAT WE'VE ACTUALLY JUST
HEARD IN THIS COMMITTEE- IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND THEN ON
TOP OF THAT WHEN THEY SPEAK
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE ARE
FURTHER VICTIMIZED AND
TERRORIZED. WE'VE ALSO HIRED
EXPERIENCE SAYS- WHERE ARE THE
PRIVACY OF OUR PROVIDERS ARE
GETS CLOSE ONLINE. OF COURSE
THE INFILTRATION OF A FEW YEARS
AGO AND INFORMATION WHERE ARE
PROVIDERS LIVE AND- HAVE HAD
PROTESTERS OUTSIDE. OUR TOP
PROVIDERS HOMES- WHERE THEIR
FAMILY THEIR CHILDREN. AND-
PARTNERS LEADS. WE CANNOT NOT
UPDATE THESE LAWS ANYMORE WE
WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE.
UPDATING YES THAT THAT WHAT'S
ON THE BOOKS TO PROTECT
PATIENTS THAT SIMPLE WE JUST
NEED REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
THEY JUST NEED HEALTHCARE
THEY'RE COMING TO PLANNED
PARENTHOOD EVERY SINGLE GAME
WORKING DOING THE BEST THAT
THEY CAN IN THEIR LIVES AND ON
TOP OF JUST TRYING TO GET
SIMPLE BASIC HEALTH CARE
THEY'RE BEING TERRORIZED AND
WE'VE SEEN ACTUALLY- SCHERING
YOUR DISTRICT AN INCREASE WHICH
COULD YOU AND GREEN WRAP UP
THAT YOU'RE AT FOUR MINUTES. WE
USUALLY GET BOTH WITNESSES
OCTOBER. AFTER WILL WRAP THAT.
WE JUST WANT TO BE HELD AT. AND
WE WANT OUR PATIENTS TO ACCESS.
HEALTH CARE WITHOUT ANY MORE
BARRIERS AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT AND YOUR CONSIDERATIONS
OF THIS FILM. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISS BEST GUESS.
YES THAT'S JUST IT I HAD A MORE
INFRASTRUCTURE MARKSMAN. BACK
UP AND GOOD AFTERNOON SHARING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JESSICA MORAN AND I AM THE
FOUNDER DIRECTOR- FOR THE
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AND WALNUT
CREEK I AM HERE IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX. I HAVE
BEEN WITH PLANNED PARENTHOOD
FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS AND IN THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS IT'S
DIFFICULT SINCE THE BEGINNING
OF THE PANAMAX. PROTESTERS AN
INCIDENT AROUND PROTECTING HAVE
ESCALATED TO AN ALL TIME HIGH.
PATIENT DOCTOR FATE DALY WITH
HARASSMENT AND INTIMIDATION.
DURING THE PANDEMIC STOCK
ALREADY FEEL THE PRESSURE OF
PROVIDING CARE OF THE SOCIAL
WORKERS. ADDING THE PRESSURE
DAILY HARASSMENT MAKES STAFF
FEEL UNSAFE ON SO MANY LEVELS.
HAVING SOMEONE SCREAM AT YOU
THAT YOU'RE A MURDERER AND HAVE
BLOOD ON YOUR HANDS BEING
CONFRONTED AND HAVING PEOPLE
PHYSICALLY BLOCKED YOUR PATH.
NO ONE SHOULD FEEL UNSAFE WHEN
WALKING INTO THEIR PLACE OF
WORK ABOUT OF WHAT MY STOCK
BASED ON A DAILY BASIS THAT.
THEY'RE ALSO MET WITH HATE AND
ANGER FROM THE MOMENT THEY SHOW
UP THEY ARE WITH- SHOW UP.
THERE MET WITH SIDEWALKS
COVERED WITH PROTESTERS. AND
BERATING BEGAN. WHAT WE HAVE A
VERY LARGE SPECTRUM OF PEOPLE
THAT SPEAK HEALTH CARE WITHOUT
MANY OF OUR PATIENTS ARE YOUNG
PEOPLE. AND FROM UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. SOME OF OUR
PATIENTS HAVE NOWHERE ELSE TO
SEE CARE AND FAR TOO MANY LACK
TRUST IN THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
ALTOGETHER. EVERY DAY WE HAVE
PATIENTS COMING INTO THE HEALTH
CENTER AND TEARS DUE TO THE
HARASSMENT THEY FACE ON THE WAY
AND TO HELP BETTER. BEING
SCREENED OUT TO STOP KILLING
THEIR BABIES. ONE PATIENT CAME
IN PHYSICALLY SHAKING STATING
THAT SHE WAS TOLD EVEN THOUGH
SHE WAS RAPED HER ACTION TO
ABORT ON JACK AND SHE WOULD
PAY. PUNISHED SHE WOULD BE
PUNISHED FOR HER SPEND. I'M
MORE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PICTURES AND VIDEOS BEING TAKEN
OF THEM TEARING UP THEIR
CONFIDENTIALITY AND RIGHT TO
PRIVACY IS BEING VIOLATED. IN
EXTREME CASES SOME PATIENTS ARE
FELT THREATENED AND INTIMIDATED
THEY LEAVE BEFORE GETTING THE
CARE THEY ARE SPEAKING AND
NEEDS. THIS IS A HUGE BARRIER
FOR PATIENTS TO ACCESS CARE
SAFELY AND EXERT THEIR BODILY
AUTONOMY. GRANDPARENT HAVE BEEN
A LONG TARGET OF PROTESTERS AND
ANTI ABORTION CAMPAIGN. BUT IN
THE PAST YEARS THINGS HAVE
ESCALATED BEYOND CONTROL AND WE
NEED TO ADDRESS THAT. OUR
PATIENTS DESERVE TO RECEIVE
HEALTHCARE WITHOUT INTIMIDATION
AND ARE HEALTHCARE WORKERS AND
DOCTORS. SHOULD BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE CARE WITHOUT THE THREAT
OF VIOLENCE. FOR THESE REASONS
I STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT ON
AB. THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM. UP IN SUPPORT. SHE NONE
ANY WITNESSES ON THE VIDEO
SCREEN INSTEAD SUPPORT. AT&T
OPERATOR ME WE GO TO THE LINE.
TELEPHONE LINES. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN FOR SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. FOR TRYING TO TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT SPENCER
WITH THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OBGYN STRYCHNINE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I'M SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY ARE OPEN
WITH THEIR PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA
PROBABLY SPONSORING THE BALLOT
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN ONE NINETY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS BILL
FOR THE BULK OF MY COMMUNITY
MEMBER AND I'M STRONG SUPPORT
WITH THE OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
BEING AFFECTED BY THERE NOT
BEING ANY UPDATES IN THE LAW
AND WE KNOW THAT THIS IS A
DIFFERENT FIELD THAN WHAT IT
WAS IN THE NINETIES- CHANGES
NEEDED. CHANGES NEEDED. THANK
YOU. FOR THANK YOU RIGHT
NINETY. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GROWING WITH KP PUBLIC AFFAIRS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU I HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU WE HAVE
A WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
MATTHEW MAKE RUNNELS AND KATHY
SURE ACLU AND- PACIFIC JUSTICE
INSTITUTE. GOOD AFTERNOON-
KATHY SHARP FOR ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION- WE OF COURSE SHARE THE
GOAL OF- MAKING SURE THAT
PEOPLE'S RIGHT TO ACCESS TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE IS NOT
INTERFERED WITH. AND I WANT TO
START BY THANKING THE AUTHOR
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THE
CONCERNS WE HAVE RAISED
REGARDING THE BILL- WE BELIEVE
THAT THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
ARE A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING DISCUSSION. FOR NOW
HOWEVER WE REMAIN IN OPPOSITION
FIRST WE BELIEVE THE INCREASED
PENALTIES PROPOSED IN THE BILL-
EVEN AS AMENDED OUR MISGUIDED
RESPONSE TO THE PROBLEM THE
BILL SEEKS TO ADDRESS.
OFFENDERS WHO ARE NOT DETERRED
BY THE EXISTING PUNISHMENTS
PROVIDED UNDER LAW WILL NOT BE
DETERRED BY THESE PROPOSED
INCREASE TERMS OF INCARCERATION
AND INCREASED FINE. WE BELIEVE
THE PROPOSED LAW ENFORCEMENT
TRAINING ALSO INCLUDED IN THE
BILL IS A FAR MORE EFFECTIVE
APPROACH TO ENSURE THAT THE
EXISTING MARKETS. PROPERLY
FORCE. SECOND THE BILL RATE
CONCERN WITH THE TO CREE OF
PANEL THAT ARE APPLICABLES
PROTECTED EXPRESSIVE CONDUCT
WELL THE PROPOSED AMENDMENT
THIRTY SEVEN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION WE BELIEVE FURTHER
WORK IS NEEDED I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR TO
FIND A WAY TO PROVIDE
APPROPRIATE PROTECTIONS
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CENTER.
WELL RESPECTING THE CIVIL
LIBERTIES OF THOSE ENGAGING IN
PROTEST ACTIVITY. AGAIN WE
THANK THE AUTHOR AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH HIM AGAIN WELL. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT MATTHEW
MCREYNOLDS HERE CAN YOU HEAR ME
OK SURE CAN. THANK YOU- ON
BEHALF- PACIFIC YET YES
INSTITUTE AND THE CENTER FOR
PUBLIC POLICY- I DID JUST WANT
TO SAY A COUPLE OF QUICK THINGS
FIRST OF ALL IT'S NOT OFTEN
THAT WE AS A CONSERVATIVE
LEANING CONSTITUTIONAL GROUP
FIND OURSELVES IN ALIGNMENT
WITH THE- ACLU ON A BILL LIKE
THIS BUT I THINK THAT JUST
DEMONSTRATES. THE BREADTH AND
THE DEPTH OF THE PROBLEMS WITH
THE LEGISLATION- THE- BILL
LEGISLATION AS NOTED BY THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS- SKATE.
CLOSE TO THE LAW. OR WE WOULD
ARGUE ACROSS THE LINE IN A
NUMBER OF AREAS ONE BEING THE
PROPER SET UP. AND THAT
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS HAS
ATTEMPTED TO DISTINGUISH THAT
FROM DECISION SUCH AS MCCARTY
COAKLEY- I THINK THAT ANYBODY
WHO LOOKS AT THE CURRENT
MEMBERSHIP OF THE U. S. SUPREME
COURT. WOULD RECOGNIZE THAT
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE
INCLINED TO MAKE THOSE KIND OF
A SUPER FINE DISTINCTIONS BUT
AT A MORE FUNDAMENTAL LEVEL.
WHAT THE BILL DIES IS.
WRESTLING THAT ALL OF THE
THREATS THE INTIMIDATION THE
VIOLIN OR A ONE DIRECTIONAL
THAT THEY'RE ALL DIRECTED. AT
THE CLINIC STAFF WORKERS
PATIENTS AND NEVER AT THOSE
WHO- PRAY AND PLEAD ANNA TIMES
PROTESTS OUTSIDE OF CLINICS WE
REPRESENT MANY SUCH
INDIVIDUALS. THEY CONDEMN
VIOLENCE THREATS AND
INTIMIDATION BUT THIS BILL DOES
NOTHING FOR THEM. I ACTUALLY
THINK IT MAKES IT BLATANTLY
VIEWPOINT DISCRIMINATORY AND
UNCONSTITUTIONAL. AND LASTLY I
DO SAY THAT WE OFTEN ADVISE OUR
CLIENTS IN ORDER TO ENSURE
FAIRNESS AND ENSURE THEIR OWN
DEFENSE IN THE EVENT THAT
THEY'RE BROUGHT INTO COURT. TO
VIDEO OR RECORD THEMSELVES
WHILE THEY'RE OUTSIDE OF
CLINICS NOT FOR THE PURPOSES OF
HAASSMENT OR INTIMIDATION BUT
AND SO THAT- THEY CAN PREVENT
FALSE ACCUSATIONS. THIS BILL
WOULD BRING IN THAT KIND OF
CONDUCT CHANGER IS SOLELY IN TO
CONDUCT IT COULD BE
CRIMINALIZED SO FOR ALL THOSE
IN THE ADDITIONAL REASONS
OPPOSITION LETTER. WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESS IN THECHAMBER IN
OPPOSITION ANY ON THE VIDEO
SCREEN IN OPPOSITION AND WE
WILL NOW AT&T OPEN UP THE- DOOR
FOR TELEPHONE LINES FOR
OPPOSITION FOR AB THIRTEEN
FIFTY SIX. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION- OF
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN SIR
OPPOSITION- AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE TWO COMMENTS THANK YOU
WILL GO TO Y. NINETY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MARCO GEORGE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION WE THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WE REMAIN OPPOSED AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT NINETY NINE. BY
NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS MARINO DELLO I'M
FROM BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA AND
I'M WITH LIKE MINISTRY IS LIKE
WHEN IS TO LIVE A COALITION
MADE UP OF KERN COUNTY CATHOLIC
CHURCHES. IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO AB THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX AND IN
ADDITION I WOULD LIKE TO STATE
THAT I AM ALSO- THANK YOU. WHAT
WHAT WHAT OKAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME OKAY
WE'LL BRING YOU BACK TO
COMMITTEE AND ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS WHEN THE START WAS
LACKING SURE. LISTEN I DON'T
EVER SUPPORT. HARASSMENT OR
INAPPROPRIATE DERISION OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE ENGAGED IN SUCH
A- VERY PERSONAL MATTER
HOWEVER. I FIND AND I THINK YOU
KNOW I HAVE KIND OF TOUCHED ON
THIS PARTICULAR. ASPECT I
BELIEVE THAT THESE PROVISIONS
OF PENALTIES DO NOT PROTECT PRO
LIFE INSTITUTIONS OF PEOPLE
GOING ON THE OTHER SIDE BECAUSE
WE ALSO HAVE. A PROBLEM ON THAT
END AS WELL AND SO. BECAUSE
THIS IS AN BALLOTS TOWARDS
ONLY. ONE SIDE OF THE- THE
EQUATION I FIND IT TO BE
UNSUPPORTABLE AT THIS POINT
UNLESS YOU TOOK AN AMENDMENT TO
ACTUALLY- PROTECT PRO LIFE-
INSTITUTIONS AS WELL. DID YOU
WANT INTERACTION THANK YOU- SO
THANK YOU MR LACKEY AND I KNOW
THAT WE BOTH SHARE THE DESIRE
TO PROTECT EVERYBODY WHO'S
GOING ABOUT THEIR LAWFUL
BUSINESS IN SAFETY AND
SECURITY- WHETHER WE AGREE WITH
WHAT THEY'RE DOING OR NOT- I
APOLOGIZE TO THE MAN WHO
TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION I CAN'T
REMEMBER I'M YOUR NAME BUT THE
SECOND GENTLEMAN WHO I THINK
SPOKE TO WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT. AND THE LACK OF IT BEING
YOU POINT NEUTRAL I WOULD ARGUE
THAT I MEAN JUST IN OUR BODY
ALONE THERE ARE. DEFINITELY
WOMEN WHO ARE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH PATIENTS WHO DON'T SHARE
MY POSITION ON CHOICE. AND THEY
WOULD BE PROTECTED BY THIS AS
WELL. AND THERE ARE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH WORKERS
WHO. WORK TO PROVIDE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH SERVICES TO
I BELIEVE DON'T PROVIDE
ABORTIONS THAT ARE PROTECTED BY
THIS. SO IN THAT WAY I BELIEVE
IT IS YOU POINT NEUTRAL WE'RE
PROTECTING A CERTAIN CLASS OF
PEOPLE BUT IT IS NOT. FOR US OR
FOR THE LAW TO SAY WHETHER
THOSE PEOPLE ARE. ABORTION
PROVIDERS OR NOT OR WHETHER
THOSE WOMEN WHO ARE SEEKING
CARE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTHCARE
ARC SEEKING ABORTIONS OR NOT OR
WHETHER THEY EVER WOULD- AND SO
I THINK THIS BILL FOCUSES ON A
CLASS OF PEOPLE WHO. ARE
CURRENTLY BEING THREATENED BUT
IT BY NO MEANS SPEAKS TO THE
VIEW POINT OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS
AND I WANT THAT TO BE REALLY
REALLY CLEAR AND I DO BELIEVE.
AND IT IS YOU POINT NEUTRAL AND
THAT WAY ALTHOUGH NARROW IN
SCOPE I DO BELIEVE THAT IT
FOCUSES. JUST ON WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN OUR REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH SPACE AND THE- COMPLETE-
DIVISION AND WHERE WE HAVE
GOTTEN WHO IS A SOCIETY THAT.
IN THIS BODY I HAVE PEOPLE WHO
DON'T AGREE WITH ME ON CHOICE
AND WE HAVE. DIALOGUE ABOUT
THAT AND I WANT TO ADDRESS WITH
THE ACLU SAID AS WELL WHICH IS
WE ARE WORKING WITH THEM TO
ENSURE THAT CIVIL LIBERTIES ARE
PROTECTED I BELIEVE IN THE
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHT I BELIEVE
PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE A RIGHT TO
EXPRESS THEIR FIRST MEMBER
RIGHT. I DO NOT BELIEVE THEY
HAVE A RIGHT TO CROSS THE LINE
AND ASSAULT THREATEN OR CAUSE
HARM TO INDIVIDUALS AND THERE
IS A LINE AND WE'LL WORK TO
MAKE SURE WERE THERE BUT I DO
BELIEVE THAT- MATTER YOUR
VIEWPOINT YOU CANNOT CROSS THAT
LINE IN A MATTER OF YOU POINT
OF THOSE WERE BEING SUBJECT OF
THIS BEHAVIOR. THEY DESERVE TO
BE PROTECTED. MISTER THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- AS SOMEONE ON
THIS DAIS WHO HAS WALKED INTO A
PLANNED PARENTHOOD CLINIC ON
MORE THAN ONE OCCASION I HAVE
RECEIVED HEALTH CARE THERE I
RECEIVED ANNUAL EXAMS THERE
I'VE ALSO RECEIVED AN ABORTION
AT A PLANNED PARENTHOOD CLINIC
WHICH I'VE SPOKEN ABOUT
PUBLICLY ON THE FLOOR I HAVE
WALKED THROUGH- YOU KNOW
PROTESTS AND DEMONSTRATIONS AND
EVERYONE HAS A RIGHT TO PROTEST
I'M- I PARTICIPATINGHOTELS ALL
THE TIME. BUT WHAT PEOPLE DON'T
HAVE THE RIGHT TO DO IS TO
THREATEN INTIMIDATE AND
POTENTIALLY CAUSE VIOLENCE
OTHER PEOPLE WHO ARE SEEKING TO
GET THE HEALTH CARE THAT THEY
NEED AND- IT IS IN THAT MOMENT
OF TIME ESPECIALLY IF YOU ARE
TRYING TO MAKE THIS VERY TOUGH
DECISION AS I HAVE MADE IN MY
LIFE. WHEN YOU ESPECIALLY
SHOULDN'T BE SUBJECT TO THAT
TYPE OF INTIMIDATION OR THREAT
OF VIOLENCE. YOU HAVE THE RIGHT
WOMEN HAVE THE RIGHT TO RECEIVE
THE HEALTHCARE THAT THEY THAT
THEY I BELIEVE IS A FUNDAMENTAL
HUMAN RIGHT. IN A SAFE PLACE.
THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO PRIVACY
OF THAT DECISION AND FOR THEIR
IMAGES NOT TO BE. PUBLISHED ON
THE INTERNET WHEN THEY'RE
MAKING A VERY PRIVATE DECISION-
AND FOR THAT REASON I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY I
THINK THE AUTHOR HAS WORKED
VERY HARD. TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE CONCERNS. THAT THE
OPPOSITION IS RACE AND I WILL
TELL YOU I OFTEN VOTE WITH THE
OPPOSITION. IF YOU LOOK AT MY
VOTING RECORD I'VE RARELY VOTE
TO INCREASE PENALTIES BUT I
THINK WITH THIS BILL DOES IS IT
MODERNIZES WHAT WE'RE SEEING IN
REAL LIFE. IN OUR REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH- CARE FACILITIES- AND SO
AND I AND I ALSO TRUST THE
AUTHOR TO CONTINUE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS I KNOW THAT SHE
WILL- AND SO IS WITH THAT
REASON I WILL BE VOTING FOR
THIS BILL TODAY. I I'M OF THE
BILL SECOND. ANY OTHER COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS. YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
THIS RICH DIALOGUE AGAIN AND
THE WHOLE COMMITTEES ENGAGEMENT
ON THIS SUBJECT I KNOW THE
RAISING PENALTIES ISN'T AN EASY
THING FOR MANY PEOPLE ON THIS
COMMITTEE TO DO AND I KNOW THAT
AND PEOPLE WHO DON'T AGREE WITH
ME ALWAYS ON CHOICE OF WORKS
HARD TO CONSIDER WHETHER THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT'S A PART OF
AND I APPRECIATE ALL OF THAT.
YOU KNOW I TRULY APPRECIATE THE
OPEN DIALOGUE THAT WE HAVE THE
COMMITTEE ON WHERE WE CAN FIND
COMMON GROUND WHETHER BE
SOMEONE WHO RARELY SUPPORTS
REYES PENALTIES OR SOMEONE WHO
REALLY SUPPORTS ANTIQUES THE
PROTECTION OF THE RIGHT TO
CHOOSE- AND BUT I JUST REALLY
WANT TO FOCUS ON THESE WOMEN.
AND WORKERS WHETHER THEY BE MEN
OR WOMEN ALTHOUGH THE VAST
MAJORITY ARE PROBABLY WOMEN WHO
WALK INTO THESE CLINICS- TO GET
HEALTH CARE AND SOMETIMES IT'S
FOR ABORTION AND SOMETIMES IT'S
FOR CANCER SCREENINGS OR OTHER
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE THAT
WE ALL AGREE IS NECESSARY AND
IN SO DOING THEY ARE THREATENS
WE HAVE LAWS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND NATIONALLY TO PROTECT OUR
PRIVACY RUN HEALTHCARE THE DAY
WHEN I GO INTO THE DOCTOR
NOBODY GETS TO KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS IN THAT ROOM AND YET
PEOPLE ARE FILMING. THESE WOMEN
IN PUTTING THAT ON THE INTERNET
AND VIOLATING THOSE LAWS THAT
WE HAVE ALL SUPPORTED I BELIEVE
TO PROTECT THE PRIVACY OF
PATIENTS- AND THAT IS WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY IS
PROTECTING PEOPLE WHO ARE
GETTING HEALTH CARE AND
PROTECTING PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING
ABOUT LAW ABIDING ACTIVITIES
ENSURING THEY CAN DO SO IN
SAFETY AND SECURITY AND I
BELIEVE THAT WE ALL. AND WE ALL
SUPPORT THAT AND I JUST LOOK
FORWARD TO MOVING THIS BILL
FORWARD CONTINUING TO LOOK AT A
SPACE WHERE WE CAN HAVE
PROTESTERS WHO HAVE A RIGHT TO
PROTEST IN THE WAY THAT OUR
CONSTITUTION PROTECTS AND ALSO
HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE ABLE TO GET
THE REPRODUCTIVE CARE THEY
DESERVE IN THE WAY THEY DESERVE
AND I THINK BOTH CAN HAPPEN
SIMULTANEOUSLY WITHOUT THE
THREATS WE ARE TRYING TO
PREVENT HERE. THANK YOU ARE
STRICTLY ASK FOR ABBOTT. AND
THANK YOU AT THE YOU FOR TRYING
TO WORK WITH THE CA. ON YOU AND
I'VE- WITH THIS. AND JUST. FOR
ME THIS IS THIS IS LIKE A GRAND
EXPERIMENT FOR ME. AS WELL WITH
A THREE YEAR SUNSET- I
PERSONALLY DON'T BELIEVE. ANY
OF THESE. INCREASES IN
PENALTIES WILL HELP. I TOLD YOU
THAT I TOLD YOU THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT. MAY SAY THAT THEY
NEED FAMILIES. BUT THEY WANT TO
JUST THROW EVERYBODY IN JAIL-
WHEN WAS THAT WHEN IT WAS A
BROKEN WINDOW. MISDEMEANORS
WERE WORKED ON THE BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES LIKE CRAZY
AND THEY DID MISDEMEANORS AND A
LOT OF A LOT OF PEOPLE. NOW I
WANT TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
WE NOW HAVE MISTER MUSIC
INTERNET TO FELONIES. FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT OF COLOR
WHICH IS MOST OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE OUT THERE
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS IF LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACTUALLY DOES WHAT
THEY TOLD YOU THEY WOULD DO. IF
WE INCREASE THE PENALTIES ON
THE EVE REPRODUCTIVE AGENCIES
THAT THEY WOULD MAKE SURE YOU
HAD YOUR BUFFER ZONES THAT YOU
KEEP YOUR PEOPLE SAFE AND MOST
IMPORTANT THAT THEY WOULD GO
AHEAD AND REST PEOPLE ON
MISDEMEANORS AND SO YOUR SECOND
CHALLENGE OBVIOUSLY IS THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY OF IT. AND
WHAT WHAT BOTHERS ME IS I NEVER
GOT AN ANSWER FROM THE ACLU.
THAT I WON IT BEFORE THIS AND
SO HOPEFULLY YOU MOVE FORWARD
WITH GETTING THEIR- THEIR
OPINION ON THIS BECAUSE IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT. OFF ON THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY OF IT. IT IS
NOT UP. IT REALLY IS NOT UP TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT ASIDE IF THE
PENALTIES IMPOSED FOR A
PARTICULAR CRIME A STRONG
ENOUGH. RATHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
IS TASKED WITH ENFORCING THE
LOS. PASSED BY THIS LEGISLATURE
WITHOUT PREJUDICE THAT'S WHAT
I'M SAYING. AND YOU CAN NOT
PICK OUT A CERTAIN GROUP YOU
CANNOT DECIDE WHICH ONES YOU
CAN AND CANNOT DO BECAUSE ALL
THESE LAWS ARE VERY IMPORTANT
TO PROTECTING EVERYONE IN THE
SYSTEM. AND- WE'RE GONNA FIND
OUT WITH THIS BILL. IF IT
PASSES AND GET THROUGH WE'RE
GONNA FIND OUT WITH THE DATA
THAT YOU COLLECT. HOW MANY
PEOPLE. PROBABLY MOSTLY NOT OF
COLOR THAT ACTUALLY GET. FIND
OR GOTTEN DONE ON THESE FOR
GOING AFTER REPRODUCTIVE
AGENCIES IN A LAWFUL MANNER WE
WILL FIND OUT FAIRLY QUICKLY.
HOW LAW ENFORCEMENT DEALS WITH.
THESE TYPES A LOT OF I HOPE
THEY'RE VERY EFFECTIVE I HOPE
THEY THEY WORK WITH YOU I HOPE
THAT THEY CREATE A POP STAR
OKAY MAKE ALL THESE THEM SAFE
BUT I AM SKEPTICAL BUT I'M ALSO
WILLING. TO GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY THIS PRESENTS IS
NARROW IN FOCUS VERY VERY
NARROW AND WE CAN ACTUALLY SEE
WHAT THE DATA SHOWS- ULTIMATELY
OF. WHEN WE WORK TOGETHER. WERE
ABLE TO GET TO THAT WERE NOT
WORKING TOGETHER. IT THE WHOLE
THING FALLS APART SO- GOOD LUCK
AS YOU MOVE FORWARD TO CHECK
RECOMMENDED I BOOKED. I'M AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX BY SEVEN
MEMBER BARRACK HE HAD THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
PRIVACY AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER. JONES
SAWYER HI BLACKIE BLACKIE KNELT
BARRICADE HANAI BARRICADE HAD A
CORK BY CORK I SANTIAGO. C. R.
TO KNOW THEIR TURNOUT WICKS
WICKS HI LEE. LEE I. THE
MEASURE PASSES. MR MCCARTY FOR
THE LAST BILL. MY LAST BILL.
OKAY DID NOT KNOW. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR- PATIENCE MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS- I ALSO WANT TO MISTER
CHAIR THINK HERE YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US WE
DIDN'T ALWAYS SEE EYE TO EYE
OUT ON THIS ISSUE IN IN COMING
BEFORE US TODAY. BUT I REALLY
APPRECIATE THEM TRENER STAND
WHERE WE'RE COMING FROM. AS IT
ALSO POINTS OUT I HAD BEFORE
OUT A DISTRICT BILL FOR MYSELF
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER-AGUIAR-CURRY IT'S A DISTRICT
BILL FOR YOLO COUNTY. OFFERING
A PILOT PROJECT TO CREATE THE
HOPE YOU'LL- SECURED
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT PROGRAM
FOR INDIVIDUALS SUFFERING FOR
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDERS WHO
HAVE BEEN CONVICTED. OF DRUG
RELATED FELONIES TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO NOT GO TO JAIL
OR PRISON BUT INSTEAD GET
TREATMENT FOR THEIR ADDICTION
AND HOPEFULLY GET ON THE ROAD
TO RECOVERY- THIS IS A
VOLUNTARY PROGRAM AGAIN ANOTHER
PIZZA PLACE IN. A DEBATE ABOUT
THAT THESE ARE FOR I KNOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF OUR CAN'T
JUST LAUGH ASK WHAT KIND OF
FELONIES THERE'S ARE NONVIOLENT
FELONIES NO TO NINETIES NOPE-
SEX CRIMES THESE ARE FELONIES
RELATED TO. A DRUG ADDICTION I
WE DO KNOW THAT- THE CURRENT
SYSTEM IS NOT WORKING LOOK AT
ANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES WE HAVE
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO GET.
ARRESTED FOR- A NUMBER OF
FACTORS THAT ARE RELATED TO
THEIR DRUG ADDICTION AND NEVER
GET TREATMENT WE HAVE AN AN
EXAMPLE ARE. ARE ARE ARE WITH
THIS IS GONNA TALK ABOUT
INDIVIDUALS ARRESTED HERE IN
YOLO COUNTY NEARLY TWENTY TIMES
AT A LOCAL TARGET. FOR THEFT
AND- AND OTHER INCIDENTS
RELATED TO HIS DRUG ADDICTION
AND NEVER WENT AND GOT
TREATMENT. SO THIS WOULD
PROVIDE A- CHOICE FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL TO GET TREATMENT AS
OPPOSED TO INCARCERATION- IT
ALSO ALLOWED THE VIGILS TO GET.
A A- AN EXPUNGEMENT OF THEIR OF
THEIR RECORD FOR THE RATE TO
THEIR FELONIES- YOU KNOW THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT'S EVIDENCE
BAY. UPON TO WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO HEAR FROM SOME OTHERS AS
WELL WE KNOW THAT- THE SECURED
FACILITIES ACTUALLY DO WORK AND
SOME PEOPLE SOMETIMES HAVE TO
HIT ROCK BOTTOM. AND THIS IS
BEEN OPPORTUNITY PEOPLE TO
CHOOSE TREATMENT OVER
INCARCERATION BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT INCARCERATION IS NOT THE
BEST PLACE FOR PEOPLETRYING TO
KICK A DRUG ADDICTION. WE ALL
KNOW OF INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
LOST TO THE STREETS. WHO ARE WE.
ARE DESPERATE- O TRY TO DO A
DIFFERENT THEIR ADDICTION. AND
RIGHT NOW OUR. COURTS AND OUR
DEFENDER COULD NOT JUST SYSTEM.
OUR HANDS ARE TIED WITH LACK OF
OUR ARE COURTS ESSENTIALLY
WORKING- WE DID SOMETHING. THIS
IS WHY THIS IS A PIE PROJECT
WHICH I. OUR COUNT HERE NEXT
DOOR IN YELLOW. FOR FIFTY YEARS
FOUR THREE THREE AND HALF YEARS%
UP TO TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. TO
COME TOGETHER AND COME UP WITH
A. SOLUTION I THINK CAN
POTENTIALLY BE. WRAPPED MUSIC
CALIFORNIA. THIS ALLOWS US TO
GET OUT FRONT OF THIS ISSUE AND
NOT. AND NOT WAIT AROUND WHILE
MORE- LIVES ARE RUINED. WITH ME
TO TESTIFY TODAY. OUR JEFF
REISIG. THE DA FROM YOLO COUNTY
AND DOUG THAT EXACT DIRECTOR
FROM FOURTH AND HOPE TO. FOR
THANK YOU THANK YOU. GENTLEMAN
WHO WHEN YOU'RE READY. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS RETURNING
UPRIGHT AND YOU'LL COUNTY. NOW
TO ME PEOPLE WHO FOR SERIOUS OF
TO SO ARE GOING TO PRISONS AND
JAILS FOR CRIMES THAT ARE
MOTIVATED BY THEIR ADDICTION-
IN PRISONS AND JAILS ARE SIMPLY
NOT PLACES WHERE PEOPLE WHO ARE
SICK. GO TO GET BETTER AS YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STATED WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS WORKING I'VE
SEEN THAT FIRST HAND. TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AS A PROSECUTOR. HAS
THE REFERENCE WE HAVE PEOPLE
BEEN ARRESTED DOZENS OF TIMES.
UP FOR BURGLARY AND AUTO THEFT
AND OTHER CRIMES WHO ARE JUST
NOT GETTING HELP IN THE SYSTEM.
AB. FIFTEEN FORTY. WHO HAVE
BEEN CONVICTED OF A FELONY
LEVEL CRIMES THAT ARE MOTIVATED
BY THEIR SERIOUS ADDICTION TO
DRUGS. BUT WHO KNOWS TO MUCH
RISK FOR A JUDGE. TO SIMPLY
RELEASE THEM INTO AN UNSECURED
RESIDENTIAL FACILITY IN THE
COMMUNITY. WHERE THEY CAN
SIMPLY WALK AWAY OR CRAWL OUT A
WINDOW ONE DAY ONE. AND
POTENTIALLY CAUSE MORE HARM TO
THEMSELVES OR OTHERS. SO
INSTEAD AB FIFTEEN FORTY TWO
ENVISIONS CREATING A SECURE
HOSPITAL LIKE TREATMENT
ENVIRONMENT WITHOUT JAILS IN
BARS AND GUARDS AND GUNS. THAT
CAN SERVE AS A SANCTUARY. FOR
SERIOUSLY ADDICTED FELONY
OFFENDERS. WHO VOLUNTARILY
CHOOSE TO TRY LOCAL COMMUNITY
BASED TREATMENT AND WRAPAROUND
SERVICES IN A SAFE AND SECURE
SETTING RIGHT HERE AT HOME.
INSTEAD OF BEING SHIPPED OFTEN
WAREHOUSE BEHIND BARS. WE'RE
CALLING THIS PLACE THIS
POTENTIAL PLACE HOPE YELLOW.
WOULD ALSO MAKE THIS TREATMENT
ALTERNATIVE UNIQUE IS IT'LL BE
DESIGNED AND STAFFED BY
TREATMENT PROVIDERS AND THEY
WILL DECIDE. WHO IS AN
APPROPRIATE CANDIDATE AND WHO
IS NOT AND ALSO DECIDE WHAT THE
TREATMENT LOOKS LIKE. FOR THOSE
PEOPLE WHO SUCCESSFULLY CHOOSE.
AND COMPLETE THE TREATMENT OVER
PRISON OR JAIL THEY WILL HAVE
THEIR CONVICTIONS CONVICTIONS
EXPUNGED. AGAIN WE GET A CLEAN
START RIGHT HERE INYO COUNTY.
SO ULTIMATELY YOU KNOW AB
FIFTEEN FORTY TWO IS A VERY
MEASURED PILOT BILL JUST
HEARING YOU A LITTLE THAT IS
DESIGNED TO OFFER VOLUNTARY
TREATMENT ALTERNATIVES. THOSE
PEOPLE WHO ARE ALREADY ON THEIR
WAY TO PRISON OR JAIL SO THIS
IS ANOTHER DOOR THAT THEY CAN
CHOOSE. WE'VE DONE A
PRELIMINARY REVIEW OF FILES
FROM TWENTY TWENTY AND WE
EASILY IDENTIFIED APPROXIMATELY
TWO HUNDRED PEOPLE. WHO WERE
SENT TO PRISON OR JAIL FOR DRUG
MOTIVATED CRIMES WHO COULD HAVE
QUALIFIED. FOR THIS TYPE OF
TREATMENT THAT HOPE KILL IF
THEY WANTED IT- SO I WOULD URGE
THIS COMMITTEE TO GIVE THIS
PILOT PROGRAM A CHANCE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT. ROOF HELLO
NEXT. OPERATOR HI I HAD HERE
MISTER CHAIR THAT HE HAD TO
LEAVE- SOMETHING OUR- ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN THE CHAMBER.
N. N. SUPPORT ANY WITNESSES ON
THE VIDEO SCREEN IN SUPPORT- AT
T. OPERATE YOU MAY OPEN UP THE
LINE FOR SUPPORT SUPPORT FOR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN FOR YOU TO PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN FOR SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTEEN FORTY TWO. PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO ACTRESS TIME.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT SHERRY
IN THE QUEUE WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO I THINK THAT- FEW PEOPLE
WANTED A MOVE TOWARD
LEGALIZATION OF THINGS THAT ARE
NON VIOLENT YOU BRING IMPORTANT
FOR ALL OF US IN COMMINGLED
TOGETHER AND SO I AM HERE IN
SUPPORT. OF THE MEASURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU LYING TO TWENTY
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THANK
YOU MY NAME IS MAUREEN PALEY-
I'M A COMMUNITY MEMBER AND ALSO
SOCIAL WORK INTERN WITH MAYOR
MARKET GROWTH AND WEBER
SACRAMENTO IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO COMMITTEE ON A CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND- MY NAME
IS GRANT DEARY ON BEHALF OF OUR
FAMILY OWNED COMPANY IN
YORKTOWN BEVERAGE COMPANY WAS
SACRAMENTO- G. STRONG SUPPORTER
OF. YOU STILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU- BUT IN A WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION. I THINK I HAVE A.
TYLER ROCK RIND AND JOSEPH
RATHLIN. SHE IN YOUR POLICY
POLICY ADVOCATE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTOR
ASSOCIATION AND HUMAN RIGHTS
WATCH. GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TIRING
DEPICTED COUNTY VEHICLE
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION EACH
YEAR REPRESENTS THE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTY AND CITY PAPER HOW GORDY
PROVIDING MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS
CERTIFICATE HELLO INCOME
CALIFORNIANS DRAMATIC ALLEN
OTHER FUNDING STREAMS. EBITA
THEN PRESS BACK OPPOSITION TO
AB FIFTEEN FORTY TWO WHICH
WOULD CREATE A LOCKSTEP IN THIS
ORDER PROGRAM IN YELLOW COUNTY
COMPULSORY YOUR COURSE TO STD
TREATMENT IS NOT AN EFFECTIVE
MEANS OF PROMOTING POSITIVE
CLINICAL OUTCOMES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS OFFERING LOCKED
FRIEDMAN AS AN ALTERNATIVE TO
INCARCERATION WHEN THE
INDIVIDUAL BUT NOT OTHERWISE
EXPECT TREATMENT OUTSIDE OF
THIS SITUATION. CAN FOSTER
DISTRUST BETWEEN TREATMENT
PROVIDERS AND CLIENTS AND REYES
OVERDOSE REST PROBYN
INDIVIDUALS TO LIKE WE ARE BY
THE UNLIKELY TO SEEK OUT HELP
IN THE FUTURE IN A STUDY OF THE
NORTH CAROLINA PRISON SYSTEM IN
THE FIRST TWO WEEKS AFTER
RELEASE FORMER INMATES.
POPULATION INDIVIDUALS UPON
BRUMBIES HAVE LACKED TOLERANCE
TO THE FACTS AND THEN PRIOR TO
INCARCERATION WE BELIEVE THE
SECURED RESIDENTIAL PROGRAM
WHICH FUNCTION SIMILARLY WITH
AN INCREASED RISK OF DEATH BY
OVERDOSE IT DOESN'T ADDRESS THE
PUBLIC SAFETY IN A TIME WHEN
CALIFORNIANS ARE EXPERIENCING
HIGHER THAN AVERAGE RATES OF
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER AND
OVERDOSE DEATHS DUE TO THE
IMPACT OF CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. MARICAO COULD NOT BE
UTILIZED FOR THAT SECURED
PRESIDENTIAL PROGRAM WHICH IS
THE KEY FUNDING STREAM IN
CALIFORNIA FOR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER SERVICES. MEDIC COW IS
FEDERALLY RESTRICTED TO PAY FOR
SERVICES BEEN INCARCERATED
SETTING ADDITIONALLY CALIFORNIA
AFTER A DRUG MEDI CAL ORGANIZED
DELIVERY SYSTEM WAVER HAS
DEVELOPED AN EVIDENCE BASED
SYSTEM OF CARE AND TREATMENT
WITH GUIDELINES DEVELOPED BY
THE AMERICAN SOCIETY FOR
ADDICTION MEDICINE APPEARANCE
THE DAVENANT'S BASE STANDARDS
IS REQUIRED FOR RESIDENTIAL
FACILITY LICENSURE. AND FOR
MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT UNDER
TìM COD AT A SECURED
RESIDENTIAL SETTING IT'S NOT
ONE OF THE- EVIDENCE BASED
STANDARDS UNDER FEDERAL- BATIC
OUR STANDARD WITHOUT MEDICARE
FUNDING THIS PROGRAM WOULD
REQUIRE SUBSTANTIAL NEW
INVESTMENTS THAT COULD BE
UTILIZED FOR I'M- MORE
EFFECTIVE INVESTMENT THE PHD A
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR NO
VOTE ON. EIGHTY FIFTEEN FORTY
THREE. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT AFTER MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
IS JOHN RATE HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH
THANK YOU FOR OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ON AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
AB FIFTEEN FORTY TWO ON
APPRECIATED SEVEN NUMBER
MCCARTY INTENTION WITH THIS
BILL. WE BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD
BE PROVIDING DRUG TREATMENT TO
THOSE IN NEED HOWEVER.
INVOLUNTARY TREATMENT
ESPECIALLY IN A JAIL LIKE LOCKS
DISABILITY AS PROPOSED BY AB
FIFTEEN FORTY TWO IS THE WRONG
APPROACH. THERE'S A VARIETY OF
PROBLEMS WITH THIS PROPOSED
PILOT THE PRECEDING SPEAKERS
CULTURE UP SEVERAL OF THEM I
WOULD ADD VIEWS OF RISK
ASSESSMENT TOOLS MAKING
HEALTHCARE DECISIONS THE LACK
OF DUE PROCESS AND STANDARDS
GUIDING JUDGES DISCRETION. WANT
TO SPEAK. MOST DIRECTLY TO THE
OVERALL PROMISE OF THE
DETAILING OF THE PILOT PROGRAM.
SO FIRST AT HOME WERE CALLING
FOR ALTERNATIVES TO
INCARCERATION. IT AB FIFTY FOUR
FIFTEEN FORTY TWO WHICH IS
PROPOSING MORE A LOCKED
FACILITY. NOT ACTUALLY
DECRIMINALIZE ATION THIS IS
TURNING HEALTH CARE INTO
INCARCERATION. SECOND DESPITE
THE AMENDED LANGUAGE AND AGAIN
APPRECIATING THE INTENT WOULD.
LANGUAGE AND THE LANGUAGE YOU
USE WORDS LIKE CONSENT
INVOLUNTARY. HOW IT WILL COERCE
PEOPLE INTO TREATMENT. THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER DESCRIBED
GENERALLY HAVE TO BE READY TO
EMBRACE TREATMENT FOR TO WORK
STUDIES- YOU NOT SHOW POSITIVE
OUTCOMES FROM INVOLUNTARY TREAT.
THE TREATMENT REQUIRES TRUSTING.
BETWEEN PATIENTS AND PROVIDERS
WHERE THIS PILOT A LOUSE
PROBATION OFFICERS PROSECUTORS
AND JUDGES TO INTERFERE WITH
THAT RELATIONSHIP. THE RIGHT TO
FREE AND INFORMED CONSENT
INCLUDING THE RIGHT TO REFUSE
TREATMENT IS ESSENTIAL. THE
VOLUNTARY MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT. WHILE IT'S NOT RIGHT.
EMENDED LANGUAGE DOESN'T CHANGE
THIS PILOT'S COURSE OF NATURE.
THE DEFENSE ATTORNEY IN
CALIFORNIA COURTS FOR TWENTY
TWO YEARS. NEARLY ALL CASES IN
OUR COURTS MISSTATING
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY FOR THAT
MATTER ARE RESOLVED BY PLEA
BARGAINS. THIS POLITICIAN
PROSECUTOR YOU GONNA SET WE
THINK YOU NEED TREATMENT. IF
YOU DON'T AGREE TO IT THEN WILL
LOCK YOU IN PRISON FOR A LONG
TIME. SHOULD BE A CUTE PERSONAL
JUST GIVE N. GO TO THE LOCK
TREATMENT FACILITY WITHIN THEIR
READY OR WILLING TO CONSENTING
ON. IT ENDS UP BEING ALL ABOUT
WHO IS LEVERAGING THE COURTS
NOT ABOUT THE INFORMED CONSENT
WHICH IS REQUIRED FOR REAL
HEALTHCARE. NOTHING TO LIVE ON
ABOUT. DO YOU NEED TO INVEST IN
TREATMENT FOR PEOPLE WITH
PROBLEMATIC SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS WE NEED TO MAKE A
WIDESPREAD MAKE IT EFFECTIVE
AND MAKE IT NOT PART OF THE
SYSTEM HONESTLY. WE REJECTED
STILL LET'S ALL WORK TOGETHER
TO EXPAND VOLUNTARY TREATMENT
OPTIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
BUT ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES ANOTHER. ROOM IN
OPPOSITION THREE NINE AND A ON
THE- VIDEO SCREEN SEEN NONE
AT&T OPERATOR CAN YOU OPEN UP
FOR- OPPOSITION ARE AB FIFTEEN
FORTY TWO MCCARTY. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION AND EIGHTY FIFTEEN
FORTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN FOR OPPOSITION. EIGHTY
SIXTEEN FORTY TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT NINE IN Q.
OVER TRYING TO TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. KATHY SURE FOR
THE ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT ONE NINETY PLEASE CALL
ASKED. DENICO ROAD ARE NOW ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER AND ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION BACK WAY
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. BY
NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORE GIVE ME I'M SORRY MARK AND
GEORGE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GENDRY HALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU RIGHT ONE SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ROBERT HARRIS
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA SOCIETY
OF ADDICTION MEDICINE IN
OPPOSITION AND ALL I HAVE ALSO
BEEN ASKED TO- BOISE OPPOSITION
IN THE CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD EVENING YOU GOT AWAY AT
IN YOUR POLICY LEAD WITH
DIGNITY AND POWER NOW PART OF
THE JUSTICE LA POLISH AND THEN
THE CAREFIRST COALITION AND WE
ARE IN FIRM OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT TO THIRTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU ANDREAS GARCIA
BONTA GIVING YOUNG AND I AM A
WITH SOMEBODY DO YOU KNOW IF WE
DON'T ALL AND FROM GAMES TO
COREY OPPORTUNITY FOUNDATION-
WE ARE STRONG AND STRONG.
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU RIGHT TO TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
FRANCESCA RIGHT AND I'M ON THE
COORDINATING TEAM OF YELLOW
COUNTY PEOPLE POWER WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB FIFTEEN
FORTY TWO AS AN ALL VOLUNTEER
NETWORK OF YOLO COUNTY RESIDENT
SPEAKING ABOUT BEING. RESIDENTS
FAMILY SUPPORT VOLUNTARY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON OAKLAND BAPTIST
THE ELEVATOR CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS AND DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU GLENN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU WE NOW
BRING YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR ANY COMMENTS QUESTIONS. OR
MR LACKEY MISS WICKS. YEAH LET
ME JUST SAY- A COUPLE THINGS
REAL QUICKLY- GROGAN ACTION. IS
A VERY SERIOUS PROBLEM IN THIS
COUNTRY AND IN THE STATE AND I
THINK WE'VE LEARNED A GREAT
DEAL FROM. PAST TRAGEDIES AT
LEAST I'VE- I'VE INVOLVED ON
THIS I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CALL
THEM ALL BUT AT LEAST THAT
CHANGED- AND THAT I HAVE.
REALLY COME TO GRIPS WITH THE
FACT THAT- DRUG ADDICTION IS
REALLY A MEDICAL ISSUE- AND IN
MANY CASES I THINK IT'S NOT AND
OVER CHOICE I THINK MAYBE SOME
OTHER. FOUR CHOICES LED TO
ADDICTIONS BUT THAT'S NOT THE
POINT THE POINT IS ONCE THEY'RE
IN A DETECTIVE STATE. THESE
FOLKS NEED I HAVE THEY NEED
HELP. AND I KNOW THERE WAS A
CLAIM THAT- PUSHING PEOPLE INTO
TREATMENT AS A INEFFECTIVE AND
MY OBSERVATIONS OF MY LIFE
EXPERIENCE SAY JUST THE
OPPOSITE THAT- I KNOW VERY FEW
PEOPLE THAT HAVE SUCCESSFULLY
BEATEN ADDICTION THE WORK
PUSHED AND PUSHED VERY HARD. TO
THE POINT OF DISCOMFORT. AND I
KNOW THAT THOUGH WHEN. A LOT OF
THIS THE PROVISIONS. THAT THE
DIVERSION OFFERED. AND MANY
OTHER ARREST SITUATIONS THAT I
OBSERVED- THEY TOOK AWAY. THE
MANDATORY DRUG TREATMENT AND
WHEN THEY DID THAT THE
DIVERSION PARTICIPATION FELL
OFF PRECIPITOUSLY. AND
UNFORTUNATELY I THINK THAT LED
TO- TREATMENT. THAT NEVER TOOK
PLACE SO I- I HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS BILL BUT I
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT IT BECAUSE
I BELIEVE THAT. IT FILLS A GAP
THAT IS VERY VERY CLEAR. THE WE
NEED A REMEDY AND WHEN YOU
HAVE. YOU KNOW THIS PROPOSAL TO
BE STUDIED TO BE OBSERVED LET'S
SEE WHAT HAPPENS AND I THINK
THAT IT'S GONNA PROVE IF IT'S
CARRIED OUT. OF THE WAY I
UNDERSTAND IT. SOME LIVES ARE
GOING TO BE FIXED. AND I THINK
THAT THE- THAT'S POWERFULLY
IMPORTANT I THINK YOU WILL BE
ABLE TO LEARN FROM THIS
PROVISION AND- I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT. YES THIS WORKS. THANK
YOU- MISTER CHAIR- JUST SOME
QUESTIONS HERE- HAS A PILOT
LIKE THIS BEEN DONE ANYWHERE IN
THE COUNTRY YOU KNOW MR MCCARTY.
NOT TO MY KNOWLEDGE THAT'S WHY
WE'RE ATTEMPTING HERE
CALIFORNIA'S A PILOT AS OPPOSED
TO A STATEWIDE AFTER I DID
ATTEMPT TO COME UP WITH A BILL
TWO YEARS AGO LOOKING THE SAME
IDEA. STATEWIDE REVIEW THE
BETTER OFF TO START SMALLER
SMALL COUNTY LIKE YOLO WITH-
STAKEHOLDERS FROM THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THE DA WHO WANT TO
PURSUE IT. OKAY AND I'M TO THE
OPPOSITION- IS IT YOUR VIEW
THAT GOING INTO FORCED
TREATMENT I KNOW YOU FALL IT
WOULD BE VOLUNTARILY MAKING
THAT CHOICE BUT IT WOULD BE
SORT OF. I GUESS ENTER THE
TERMS YOU ALL USE LOCKS
TREATMENT. IS THAT WORSE THAN
NO TREATMENT AND- AN
INSTITUTION. ANYONE OPPOSITION
WANNA AND. HAPPY TO- ACTUALLY
ARE AT CAN CANCER AT THAT THE
QUESTION I WOULD SAY THAT-
FORCE TREATMENT MAY HAPPEN
THERE HAVE THE POSSIBILITY OF
THE UNINTENDED- OUTCOME OF THE
RAISING THE RISK OF OVERDOSE
AND SO I WOULD SAY THAT IN OUR
PERSPECTIVE- GOTTEN RID OF FOR
THE INDIVIDUAL TO HAVE AN
OVERDOSE AND PASSED AWAY FROM
AN OVERDOSE IT'S A GREATER.
THAN HAVING NO TREATMENT AT ALL
IT BY WILL BE EFFORT SHOULD BE
MADE TO ATTEMPT TO ENGAGE IN
COMBAT A PERSON AS MANY TIMES
AS POSSIBLE TO BRING THEM INTO
VOLUNTARY SERVICE THAT IF
THEY'RE NOT MOTIVATED TO BE
INTO VOLUNTARY SERVICE THAT AND
THE TREATMENT IS NOT GOING TO
BE AFFECTED BY THE INDIVIDUAL
BUT WHEN THEY STILL BE AT RISK
COMING OUT OF JAIL OR PRISON.
OF THE SAME OVERDOSE RISK. NOW
TO THE OPPOSITION I SORRY
RESTRUCTURING ANSWERED THEY DID
IT THE OPPOSITION DID YOU
EITHER ONE OF YOU WANT TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION. MMHM
OKAY- OKAY. AND THEN I. CAN GOT
SOME TO ANSWER THE QUESTION
THIS IS JOHN RIFLING FROM HUMAN
RIGHTS WATCH ON NO I'M NOT A
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS BUT I
HAVE. OTHER GREAT UNDERSTANDING
OF THE- THE SYSTEM IN JAIL SO
THAT CERTAINLY PEOPLE. COMING
OUT OF ON. YEAH OF. MAYBE AT
RISK AND SO WE NEED TO REALLY
BOLSTER UP BOTH TREATMENT
PROGRAMS WITHIN THE JAILS AND
PRISONS BUT ALSO TREATMENT
OPTIONS. THAT ARE OUTSIDE OF
AND NOT CONNECTED TO THE
CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM- IT
FORCING PEOPLE INTO- INTO
TREATMENT IS NOT GOING TO BE
EFFECTIVE AND IT'S
CRIMINALIZING THE TREATMENT
SYSTEM. SO I MEAN I AGREE WE
NEED TO BOLSTER UP TREATMENT
FOR THE FOLKS ARE COMING UP BUT
I DON'T THINK THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS AIMING TO DO AND- IT IS
A STRANGE DAY WHEN I'M- VOTING
AGAINST THE OPPOSITION ON THIS
BILL BUT I DO THINK I'M IN A
VOTE FOR THIS BILL AND SEE IT
MOVE FORWARD BECAUSE I ALSO.
THINK THE STATUS QUO ISN'T
WORKING I THINK THE BILL HAS
ISSUES I DO SHARE SOME OF THE
CONCERNS OF OPPOSITION. BUT I
ALSO TRUST THAT THIS AUTHOR AND
I'VE SEEN HIS WORK OVER THE
YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN HERE IS
GOING AND WITH REALLY GOOD
INTENT. AND WE'LL WORK THROUGH
SOME OF THOSE ISSUES- AND I DO
BELIEVE HIS VALUES ARE SIMILAR
TO THOSE OF. OF THE OPPOSITION
TRYING TO HELP AND FIND
ALTERNATIVES AND FIGURE OUT
OTHER WAYS THAT WE CAN- SOLVE
SOME OF THESE PROBLEMS SO- MR
MCCARTY I WILL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL TODAY. I HOPE TO SEE
IT GET FIXED THERE ARE SOME
THINGS I THINK ARE HAVE ISSUES-
BUT I DO THINK WE SHOULD
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION
MOVING FORWARD. MISTER CORK
CAP. SO WE'VE TALKED A BIT
ABOUT THIS. BUT YOU DID NOT
MENTION OR PERHAPS I JUST
DIDN'T HEAR ANYTHING IN YOUR
OPENING ABOUT CHANGES THAT YOU
WERE WILLING TO MAKE IN THE
BILL. AND WHERE YOU WOULD BE
GOING WITH THEM DO YOU WANT TO
ADDRESS THAT. YEAH AT THAT
FIRST OF ALL I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
SOMETIMES IT TAKES AN
UNCOMFORTABLE SOLUTION TO DEAL
WITH THOSE. SERIOUS PROBLEMS WE
HAVE AND SO THIS IS ONE WHERE.
YOU THINK OUTSIDE THE BOX- I'M
VERY MINDFUL ABOUT THE
VOLUNTARY VERSUS COERCION. I
THINK THIS IS VOLUNTARY SELECT
SOMEONE'S CHOOSING TO GO HERE-
HANG OUT IN THEIR LIVING ROOM.
IF THERE DON'T GO HERE TO THIS
TREATMENT FACILITY THEY GO TO
JAIL OR PRISON SO IT'S NOT
LIKE. THERE'S NO THIRD CHOICE
HERE. BUT ONE THING THAT. I
WITH MINDFUL OF AFTER TALKING
TO YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. IS
UPON THE COURT THE JUDGE MAKING
THE DECLARATION THAT IT WAS- AT
THE DRUG MOTIVATED CRIME AND
GIVING THE THAT THE
PARTICIPANTS THE OPTION OF
INCARCERATION OR TREATMENT.
THEY SAY OKAY FINE I'LL DO THIS
TREATMENT MAYBE IT WAS A
CONTROLLED OR I'M NOT YOU KNOW
MAYBE THEY WERE. ENTICED TO DO
THIS. THE HIT ROCK BOTTOM
WHATEVER HAVE YOU. SO. ONE
THING I TALK TO THAT TO OUR
LOCAL DA ABOUT TO. IN THE PIE.
AS WE WOULD GIVE THE PARTIES.
ENOUGH CHANCE AN OPT. IN THE
FIRST FEW DAYS OF THEIR
TREATMENT. IF THEY SAY YOU KNOW
WHAT I WANT TO DO THIS. FIND
THE EXIT WE'RE NOT FORCING THEM
AGAIN BUT AGAIN THEY'RE NOT
GOING HOMES IT'S HANGING OUT.
WATCHING THEIR- TV WITH THE
ANKLE BRACELET. THEY'RE GOING
TO BE INCARCERATED SO LIKE
THERE'S A CHOICE TO MAKE BUT WE
WILL. GIVE THE PERSON ANOTHER
CHOICE THAT I THINK. IS ANOTHER
FAIROFFRAMP FOR INDIVIDUALS
WHO WERE MAYBE. IN THE HEAT OF
THE PASSING OF COURSE IN THE IN
THE COURT SYSTEM TO CHOOSE
THIS. BILL AB ONE MORE CHOICE
TO DO SOMETHING DIFFERENT YEAH
AND THAT DOESN'T I THINK ANSWER
THE OBJECTIONS OF THE
OPPOSITION. FOR MY OWN- AND-
AGAIN IT'S- FIVE I JUST DON'T
THINK THIS WILL WORK. AND
CLEARLY THE- ISN'T WORKING BUT
IF WE'RE GOING TO TRY SOMETHING
DIFFERENT I DON'T THINK THIS IS
THE WAY TO TRY IT SO I WON'T BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL
UNFORTUNATELY- THERE'S ALSO A
LOT OF OTHER THINGS THAT ARE IN
HERE ONE IS THAT. YOU CAN'T GET
MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT- WILL
THE DA BE TRYING TO RAISE THE
FUNDS IN OTHER WAYS. THAT IS
THERE'S NO FUNDING ATTACHED TO
THIS OKAY I GET IT DONE IT IS
STATUTORILY AUTHORIZES. THIS
JUDICIAL DISCRETION FOR THE
YOLO COUNTY COURT SYSTEM TO FOR
TO PROVIDE THIS. IT'S UP TO THE
YELLOW COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND THEIR- THEIR
THEIR THEIR DA TO FIND FUNDING
THERE IS A FACILITY ONE THING
WE'VE DONE HERE IN CALIFORNIA'S
CHANGE OUR JUVENILE COURT
SYSTEM OUR JUVENILE HALL. AND
THEY HAVE A BRAND NEW JUVENILE
ALL OVER THERE THAT'S LESS THAN
YOU KNOW TEN FIFTEEN YEARS OLD
BUT HAS LIKE THREE KIDS IN
THERE. AUTHORIZED FOR HUNDRED
FIFTY SO THEY ACTUALLY HAVE A
FACILITY WHICH COULD BE EASILY
MODIFIED AND TURNED INTO. A
RESIDENTIAL DRUG TREATMENT
SECURE DRUG TREATMENT FACILITY-
JUST THE STAFFING COSTS AND SO
THEY'RE PREPARED TO WORK ON
THAT ISSUE IF THIS BILL IS
AUTHORIZED WHAT ABOUT THE
QUESTION OF HAVING SOMEONE
WHO'S AN EXPERT IN TREATMENT.
INVOLVED IN THIS DECISION. SO
THAT- IT'S JUST NOT A JUDGE BUT
IT'S THAT AT LEAST YOU'RE
GETTING SOME ADVICE FROM
SOMEONE WHO UNDERSTANDS THIS.
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT THEY THINK
THIS PERSON WOULD BE A- I
BELIEVE I WILL TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THAT I'M ALMOST
POSITIVE THAT THAT'S PART OF IT
THAT THERE'S- THAT MEDICAL-
DECISION THAT'S A
RECOMMENDATION TO THE TO THE TO
THE- WITH WITH THE COURT AND
THE JUDGE. THANK YOU MISTER
REISIG ADDRESS THAT ISSUE THIS
PROJECT. SURE YEAH THAT'S
EXACTLY RIGHT THE BILL
ENVISIONS TREATMENT PROVIDERS
WOULD BE MAKING THE ASSESSMENT
AND MAKING THE RECOMMENDATIONS
TO THE COURT. AND THE BILL IS
WRITTEN IN SUCH A WAY THAT
REALLY EMPOWERS THE TREATMENT
PROVIDERS WITH ALMOST YOU KNOW
VETO POWER ESSENTIALLY OVER.
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS AND
DECISIONS SO THEY WEREREALLY
TRYING TO FOCUS ON THIS BEING
TREATMENT ORIENTED AND FOCUSED
AND DRIVEN. OKAY AND THEN THE
QUESTION OF WHO WOULD STAFF
THIS YEAR YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
USE PROBATION OFFICERS ARE YOU.
IT'S UP TO THE COUNTY OF YOLO
HI I'M I'D I DON'T HAVE AN
ANSWER TO THAT- YOU MISTER
RISING DO YOU HAVE AN ANSWER
THAT QUESTION. WELL WE HAVEN'T
FIGURE THAT PIECE OUT I MEAN
THE IDEAS THIS IS A HOSPITAL
LIKE SETTING IN MIDDLE BE
OBVIOUSLY WHAT THE TREATMENT
STAFF THERE- WHAT FORM THE
THERE WILL BE SOME. SOMEBODY
THERE TO KEEP PEOPLE SAFE FOR
NOT A VISIONING BARS AND GUNS
AND GUARDS. BUT WHETHER IT'S-
SOME OTHER STAFF WE JUST DON'T
KNOW. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER LEE AND IMAGE TO SEE
ARTHUR- I'M JUST GONNA SAY YOU
KNOW I DO APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S INTENT WITH THIS
CLEARLY AND I AGREED SOME OF.
OUR COLLEAGUES HEAR THE STATUS
QUO IS NOT WORKING OF COURSE
INVOLUNTARY TREATMENT IS THE
INVOLUNTARILY GO AND SEE CREATE
REAL BILL TO REBUILDING
SERVICES FOR THE DRUG
ADDICTION. BUT THAT IS IN THE
PERFECT CHOICE SETTING IN THIS
SETTING THEY WERE CHOOSING
ESSENTIALLY BETWEEN GOING TO
PRISON OR PERHAPS THIS PROGRAM
WHICH OF COURSE ITSELF IN IT IF
ITSELF IS NOT A PERFECT CHOICE
BUT IT IS A CHOICE IN A WAY.
AND I DO BELIEVE- HAVING THAT
CHOICE IS IMPORTANT AND SEE HOW
IT PLAYS OUT- I ALSO DO LIKE
THAT IN THE BILL YOU YOU DO
INCLUDE RIGHT NOW HAVING THE-
DEALT THE YELLOW COUNTY HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
PERFORMING RISK ASSESSMENTS AND
WORKING CLASS RELEASE I HOPE
THERE WILL BE MORE. EMPHASIS ON
THAT AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD
OBVIOUS WE DEFINITELY DON'T
WANT AS MANY OF OPPOSITION I
STRUGGLE THIS IS TO WRITE WE
DON'T WANT- WE DON'T WANT TO.
TRY TO CREATE AN ALTERNATIVE TO
INCARCERATION AND PUTTING IT IN
THE SAME SYSTEM JUST. GIVING IT
A NEW NAME I THINK THAT'S WHAT
SOME CONSTERNATION COMES FROM.
AND I UNDERSTAND OBVIOUSLY
HAVING THE FACILITY. IS IT
CONVENIENT BUT I KNOW THAT SOME
PEOPLE COULD BE ALARMING TO
JUST BE REUSING YOUR
FACILITIES. BUT I THINK IN OUR
UNCOMFORTABLE PERHAPS
CONVERSATION ABOUT REIMAGINING
OUR PUBLIC SAFETY INSTITUTIONS.
I THINK IT MIGHT BE A PLUS THAT
WAS A REPURPOSE THESE BUILDINGS
ARE REPURPOSED THINGS. AND I
THINK SAID- AS A LEVER CORKS
POINT IS TO MAKE SURE THE
STAFFING ISN'T WITH. JUST RE
PURPOSING- THE SAME OLD SYSTEM
OF A PRISON AND JAIL- SO I'LL
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY BY DO HO GOING FORWARD IT
IS MUCH MUCH MORE- GROUNDED IN
EVERY THOUGHT OF SENSE AND
SPIRIT OF DIVERSION AND ALSO
MORE- FOCUS ON ON THE MEDICAL
TREATMENT AS WELL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER SINISTER. IT
APPEARS TO ME THAT THE CURRENT
SYSTEM IS. SOMEBODY WHO COMMITS
THEIR PETTY CRIME TO GO TO
JAIL- THEY SERVE FOR A- COUPLE
WEEKS THEY GET OUT THEY TAKE
THEIR DRUGS THEY COMMIT ANOTHER
CRIME TO SUPPORT THAT HABITS.
AND THEY KEEP DOING THIS UNTIL
THEY WIND UP DEAD ON THE GUTTER
DEAD IN THE GUTTER. AND THEN
EVERYBODY LAMENTS ABOUT OH MY
GOD WHY CAN WE DO ANYTHING
ABOUT THIS. AND IT SEEMS THAT
WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO DO IS TO
DO SOMETHING ABOUT THAT BY
ALLOWING. SOMEBODY WHO GETS
ARRESTED. AND IS GOING TO BE
SERVING TIME. TO ACTUALLY DO
SOMETHING PRODUCTIVE WHILE
THEY'RE SERVING TIME. WHICH IN
THIS CASE IS TAKING CARE OF THE
PROBLEM THE PUT HIM THERE IN
THE FIRST PLACE. AND SO THEY
CAN EITHER DO NOTHING OR TAKE
CARE OF THE PROBLEM TO PUT IN
THERE IN THE FIRST PLACE. AND
BEING. THAT YOU KNOW. ONCE
THEY'RE OUT HOPEFULLY. THERE A
COVER. OR THERE ARE WELL ON
THEIR WAY TO RECOVERY AND CAN
ENTER A SUPPORT. PROGRAM OR
WHATEVER IT IS. AT I DON'T KNOW
HOW THAT'S ANY. THAN BEING IN
PRISON AND GIVING THE CHOICE TO
YOU KNOW GET YOUR G. E. D. L.
DO SOMETHING PRODUCTIVE. GOING
TO PRISON AND SITTING THERE IS
NOT PRODUCTIVE IT'S NOT
REHABILITATION AND IT DOES THE
PERSON ABSOLUTELY NO GOOD FOR
THE FUTURE. SO I'M I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL- NUMBER ONE
IT'S NOT A STATE WIDE THING-
NUMBER TWO IT'S YOU GUYS ARE
TAKING THE INITIATIVE TO TRY TO
DO SOMETHING AND SEE IF IT
WORKS. BECAUSE WAITING UNTIL
SOMEBODY'S DEAD IN A GUTTERIS
NOT WORKING VERY WELL. AND
WE'RE DOING THAT A LOT AND WE
SEE THAT ARE HOMELESS
POPULATION AND- AND WE SEE THAT
WITH A LOT OF OUR ARE ADDICTED
PEOPLE THAT AREN'T NECESSARILY
HOMELESS. BUT APPEARED TO BE
HALF THE TIME BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE NO OTHER WAY. SO SO
I I'M I'M GOING TO SUPPORT YOUR
BILL AND- I THINK THERE'S
ALREADY IT AND MOVED ON YES. IT
IS OUR MOTION. YOU WANT TO DID
HAVE A COMMENT. OKAY WELL SHALL.
I'M MISS MCCARTY WHEN I THINK
YOU FOR THIS THESE ARE. HE ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE STRUGGLING MR
LACKEY POINTED OUT WITH- YOU
KNOW I'VE TRIED DISEASE AN
ADDICTION THAT WE IT IS
INCUMBENT UPON US TO. DO
EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER TO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO AND I
BELIEVE THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
DOING HERE YOU'RE SAYING.
SENDING PEOPLE TO- CARCERAL
SITUATION ISN'T HELPING THEM
AND SO WE'RE GONNA PROVIDED
OPTION WHERE THEY CAN GET THE
TREATMENT THAT WILL HOPEFULLY
TURN THEIR LIVES AROUND AND I
THINK THAT WE SHOULD NEVER
FORGET THE PEOPLE. WHO ARE
IMPACTED BY THESE BILLS AND
WHETHER THEY ARE PEOPLE WHO
STRUGGLE WITH DRUG ADDICTION OR
VICTIMS OR PEOPLE WHO STRUCK
SUFFERED THE INJUSTICES OF OUR
SYSTEM THESE ARE PEOPLE AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE WORK
YOU'RE DOING FOR THEM THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NO IN THE
COMMENTS. YOU MAY CLOSE MISS
MCCARTY YEAH THE THESE ARE
PEOPLE THERE'S A YOUNG MAN
NAMED MR REISIG NOT R. DA. FOR
THE NEPHEW OF RDA. HEROIN DRUG
ADDICT HUNDRED BOULEVARD I
FIVE. KEEPING THEIR COMMITTING
CRIMES TO FEED HIS ADDICTION
AND HE'S BEEN ARRESTED INTO THE
SYSTEM OVER AND OVER SO THESE
ARE INDIVIDUALS THAT WE KNOW I
KNOW PEOPLE IN MY OWN. CIRCLE
AS WELL WE ALL DO THESE ARE ALL
INDIVIDUALS AND THE CURRENT
SYSTEM IS IT UTTER FAILURE AND
I HAVE GREAT RESPECT FOR THE
OPPOSITION PEOPLE WHO ARE
COMMITTED TO ADDICTION MEDICINE
AND TRYING TO MAKE IT WORK THE
RIGHT WAY BUT THERE IS NO RIGHT
WAY FOR MANY OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS THE CURRENT SYSTEM
OF GOING TO JAIL OR- THE COUNTY
JAIL OR STATE PRISON AND HAVING
A GREAT. DRUG TREATMENT PROGRAM
THERE IS NOT OF VIOLENCE NOT
WORKING SO THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT- I RESPECTFULLY JUST
DISAGREE MISTER GREG I DON'T
SEE ANY HARM HERE BECAUSE-
WORST CASE SCENARIO. WE FIND
OUT WHAT WORKS AND DOESN'T WORK
AND COME BACK AND DO IT A
DIFFERENT COUNTY RIVERSIDE OR
SOMEWHERE ELSE. BEST CASE WE
SAVE SOME LIVES BEST BEST CASE
WE FIND A WAY TO MAKE THIS
WORK. ALL ACROSS CALIFORNIA SO-
THE STATUS QUO AGAIN LIKE YOU
SAID MR LEE IS UNACCEPTABLE. I
THINK THIS IS A FAIR- SOLUTION
WHEN WE CAME OUT WITH THIS IDEA
SIX MONTHS AGO IT WAS A VERY
DIFFERENT WE LISTEN TO THE
OPPOSITION. MADE IT NOT JUST
MISDEMEANORS AND FELONIES JUST
FELONIES MADE IT SO IT'S
ABSOLUTELY VOLUNTARY NOT DOES
NOT WITHOUT A CHOICE. BUT A
JUDGE TO DO THIS AND WE CAME UP
WITH ANOTHER SOLUTION TODAY
WHICH I THINK IS IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION ALL. YOU DID CAN YOU
TO CONTINUE TO WORK- WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO- TO WORK ON THE
CRAFTING OF THIS WITHOUT ASKING
RIGHT THANK YU. THIS THIS MUST
BE A SPECIAL DAY FOR THIS
COMMITTEE- BASALMOST LIKE PILOT
PROJECT DATE IF YOU HAD ONE
TODAY WAS THE DAY TO DO IT- NOT
ONLY DID THIS COMMITTEE IN A
PREVIOUS BILL- BASICALLY DID
FOR WOBBLER FELONIES WHICH- I
THINK ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
I WOULD SAY IS THIS PROBABLY
CONSIDER HISTORIC L. A. N. UP
IN A LOT OF WAYS- BUT IT BUT IT
BUT IT WE'RE DOING IT AS A
PILOT PROJECT SO WE COULD SEE
WHETHER OR NOT. AS MANY HAVE
PRESCRIBED AT THAT ADDING
PENALTIES ARE FELONIES- WORK
AND WE GET WE GET OPPORTUNITY
IN A IN A LIMITED SCOPE TO SEE
THAT YOUR BILL NOW ACTUALLY IT
TAX DRUG ABUSE AND COMING UP
WITH A DIFFERENT WAY TO ACHIEVE
WHAT WE ALL WANT IS TO GET
PEOPLE OFF THE STREET CAN OFFER
DRUGS- AS I REMEMBER CA. UP IN
IN HIGH SCHOOL IF YOU YOU HAD
THE BAD KIDS WOULD GO BEFORE A
JUDGE AND THEY WOULD HAVE A-
CHOICE BETWEEN THE- THE
MILITARY ARE GOING TO JAIL. AND
IF YOU WERE REALLY BAD LIKE
SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES YOU YOU
END UP IN THE MARINES BUT- YOU
YOU DEPENDING ON WHERE YOU
WORK. THEY WOULD THEN SHOP FOR
YOU TO THAT. AND SO- BUT THAT
PROGRAM IS NO LONGER DOES NOT
DONE. ANYMORE AND- I KNOW SOME
PEOPLE THAT CHOSE THE AIRFORCE
OR WHATEVER AND THEY CAME OUT.
BECAUSE THEY HAD A STRUCTURED
LIFE AND IT CAME OUT PRETTY
GOOD- I THINK YOU'RE TRYING TO
STRIVE. TO DO KIND OF THE SAME
THING BUT HOPEFULLY AND I THINK
YOU'RE ON THE RIGHT TRACK USING
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS.
AND HAVING THIS MORE OF A
TREATMENT CENTER. IN A FACILITY
THAT- THAT'S IT'S ABOUT KEEPING
PEOPLE THERE AND YOU'RE GIVING
THEM A CHOICE IT DAVE. IF THEY
DON'T WANT TO BE TREATED THEY
CAN THEY CAN TAKE THE
ALTERNATIVE WHICH WE WOULD
THANK IS NOT IN THE BEST
INTERESTS. BUT THEY HAVE
ANOTHER OPTION AND MORE OPTIONS
YOU GIVE PEOPLE WHO ARE ON
DRUGS. I THINK THE MORE THAT
THEIR SUCCESS RATE MAY GET
BETTER AND BETTER AND THIS MAY
JUST BE THE START OF ONE WAY TO
DO IT. TO HOPEFULLY COME UP
WITH ANOTHER WAY IN ANOTHER WAY
AND WE GIVEN UP DOORS. THAT WE
GET MORE MORE PEOPLE- ON THE
ROAD TO RECOVERY SHOULD. SHE I
AM NOT. IT THE CALL THE ROLL.
ON AB FIFTEEN VOTE FORTY TWO BY
SEVEN MEMBER MCCARTY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER IRAQI LACKEY I CAN I CAN
I LIKE WORK- NOT VOTING. CORK
NOT VOTING SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
pWICKS WICKS I LEE. PLEASE I
THAT MEASURE THAT MEASURE
PASSES IF YOU PARK. OKAY NOW
WE'RE GONNA DO THE ROLE ALSO
WRITTEN. WILL MOVE ONTO THE ADD
ONS AND ALL CALL ITEMS VOTE
CHANGES MATTER SECRETARY PLEASE
GO THROUGH THE THROUGH ALL THE
MEASURES. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I
DON'T NUMBER ONE A. B. SEVEN
THIRTY ONE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
THAT MEASURE PASSES. I REMEMBER
CHIU AB THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX
SANTIAGO. YEAH. YEAH I NOW. I
CAME A QUICK GOOGLE AB THIRTEEN
FIFTY SIX BY MISS BARRICADE CAN.
SANTIAGO HI THAT MEASURE PASSES
ITEM NUMBER THREE WAS ON
CONSENT. I DON'T NUMBER FOUR AB
EIGHT NINETY TWO THIS MOTION
FAILED THIS BILL BELL PASSAGE
SANTIAGO. SAN DIEGO NOT VOTING.
ON ITEM NUMBER FIVE EIGHTY TWO
SIX SIX THIS MOTION THIS EXCUSE
ME THIS MEASURE FAILED PASSAGE
BAUER CAN'T BARRICADE CANNOT
VOTING SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO NOT
VOTING. ITEM NUMBER SIX WAS
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN WITH A CONSENT
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT WAS ON
CONSENT ITEM NUMBER NINE EIGHTY
SIX SEVENTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I. ITEM
NUMBER TEN AB EIGHT SEVENTY SIX
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO HI THAT
MEASURE PASSES. I ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN AB FOUR NINETY WICKS.
WICKS I THAT MEASURE PASSES
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE ON CONSENT
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN WAS ON
CONSENT. ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN
THIS MEASURE WAS ON CALL EIGHTY
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE BY A
FAMILY MEMBER LOW BARRICADE
HAND BARRICADE HANNAH I.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I WICKS WICKS
I THAT MEASURE PASSES. ADAM
NUMBER FIFTEEN WAS JUST
DISPENSED WITH THAT PASSED OUT
SEVEN ZERO AT A NUMBER SIXTEEN
WITHOUT CONSENT ADAM SEVENTEEN
WAS PULLED BY THE AUTHOR ITEM
NUMBER EIGHTEEN THIS MEASURE
WAS ON CALL AB SEVEN SEVENTEEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER ICE
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I WICKS
WICKS I THAT MEASURE PASSES. I
DON'T NUMBER NINETEEN THIS
MEASURE WAS ON CALL AB TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TEEN JONES SAWYER- JONES SAWYER
HI SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I WICKS
WICKS HI THAT MEASURE PASSES
AND ITEM TWENTY WAS ON CONSENT.
ALL THE ITEMS WE'RE WE'RE NOW
STAND A JOURNEY. I ALSO ONLY
THOSE THREE THE PROPOSAL BY. I
DON'T. LIKE TO SUGGEST MAYBE
CALL THE I'VE BEEN BLOWN OUT OF
PROPORTION WHAT IS YOUR YES HI
UNANIMOUS BY UNANIMOUS CONSENT
RECONSIDERATION OF THE- MIKE I
JUST SAID MY UNIT HOUSTON
REQUESTS. ON THE COOPER BILL AB.
TWO SIX. AB AB. TWO SIX SIX.
THANK YOU AND WHAT DID YOU WHAT
MISTER. THE FINAL FULL WHICH IS
WHY OKAY. SO I NOW WILL
OFFICIALLY CLOSE TO MEETING.